foreign
they gave me all right they gave me the
small chair I get it
it's all funny
um
well thanks everyone for joining us I I
think we're just having a discussion I
don't know if uh additional designees
from the legislature have been uh
designated yet um so I'm not sure if
someone from the senate or house finance
will be joining us but uh we will get
started here
um I just want to kick it off with a few
kind of opening statements and just so
folks kind of understand where I've
envisioned the budget process moving
forward
um
I think there's a lot of opportunity on
the table to be sure but we also have to
be cautious with
um where the economy as a whole could be
going and therefore what some of the
variables that we'll have to consider as
we move forward in in the budget process
and again this is a budget that
effectively begins in July of 23 and
will run for the subsequent two years
following so we it really has to be a
budget that puts a lot of forethought
into where not just where we are today
but uh the very different aspect of
where we're likely to be uh in the
coming years
um so we are in a very strong position
financially there's no doubt about that
I think we've managed our finances here
very very well over the past couple of
years in the past couple of years have
been very tumultuous in a variety of
ways both nationally
um uh and uh here within New Hampshire
uh but I think we've managed our
programs very well we've managed a very
tight budget with uh the 2122 budget
cycle uh that we're currently in making
sure that the programs that we have are
fully funded making sure that the
opportunities that we want to that we we
can provide our citizens and that our
citizens are depending on are really
there for them so I think we've had a
lot of success in in that Arena on the
economic front locally again we're in a
very good position in that we are the
fastest growing state in New England
businesses want to be here families are
moving in those are all very very
positive uh economic variables that we
really key into
and that can provide a lot of
opportunity in in what will I think be
undoubtedly some more economically
unsure times uh for the nation as a
whole
um some of the challenges that we're
looking at really revolve around
Workforce right it's all about Workforce
now uh whether you're looking at New
Hampshire or across the country and
Workforce is especially important not
just in the private sector but as it
pertains to the budget within the state
of New Hampshire and so again we can
have the it's not about the dollars and
cents as much as it is about making sure
that we have the teams and the
individuals to fulfill on the commitment
of the programs uh that that we do want
to implement and we want to continue
implementing we've tried a lot of new
programs here in New Hampshire over the
past couple years and some of them have
been extremely successful
um everything from you know embracing
the a new model with uh how we treat
opioids the huge Investments we've
recently made in mental health uh the
Investments and the changes we've we've
implemented at dcyf making sure that
child welfare is is really at a foremost
um uh position in terms of our
priorities but at the end of the day all
of these opportunities don't really
exist for the citizens of New Hampshire
if you don't have the staff if you don't
have the people some of the the more
macro economic challenges that will have
to be brought into consideration with
this budget
is just looking at everything from
inflation inflationary costs and whether
they be on the capital side and the
capital budget uh interest rates which
continue to rise and likely will
continue to rise and unfortunately with
the extreme rise in those interest rates
there's really no way to avoid some form
of a national recession it is real it is
coming my guess is and this is just my
guess and we can all have our debate I'm
going to look at Lindsay
um uh in the audience and Charlie and
and James the the smart economic people
the real brains of the operation so to
say uh to tell me where I'm wrong but my
sense is you're we're going to start
really feeling a pinch of a recession
somewhere in 23 into 24.
um there's you just cannot have
inflation like this in interest rates
Rising like this uh the math just works
out that a resection is is unfortunately
very very real but again given in the
Northeast that we are the state right
now that is uh the most desirable place
to come to and businesses want to be
here and we have I think Far and Away
the most growth opportunity of of any
state in the Northeast that does give us
an upper hand on a lot of these
impending and more negative variables
that you'll see macro macro economically
across the country
just also on the capital side of things
to note with those Rising interest rates
the reality of borrowing money becomes a
much more difficult proposition we can
borrow money and we get great rates when
we borrow money but those rates no
longer really exist when we were
investing in a lot of our capital
projects on the capital budget side uh
just a few years ago interest rates were
at historically low levels it made a lot
of sense to borrow the you know 125
million dollars or whatever our budget
was granting us for those capital
projects and move forward I think that
legislature needs to be extremely
careful I will be proposing a capital
budget much much smaller than anything
that we've we've proposed before for a
couple reasons number one the federal
government has granted us a lot of money
for one-time Capital Investments through
arpa and some of these other the
infrastructure programs with everything
from broadband and you know fixing up
our buildings I mean there's a little
bit of everything in there parks we're
doing more capital investment in the
state of New Hampshire today
Far and Away than we've ever done before
and that that is a huge gift if you will
from the federal government in terms of
the dollar so one-time money I think
we're spending it very wisely but what
it also means is do we really have to go
forward with a full Capital 125 million
dollar Capital plan knowing that to do
that would have to borrow money right
now
um quasi-historically High interest
rates well that might not be the
smartest thing either also understanding
that the inflationary costs of all these
projects are absolutely huge so I think
those bigger negative variables on the
capital budget will have to be taken
into very serious consideration
when we look at not just how much we're
going to spend or where the dollars are
going to be but the timing timing plays
a lot into the opportunities that you
have and we've been given a lot of
opportunities we're moving forward on a
lot of these capital projects but in
terms of how the state borrows money and
our responsibility to the taxpayer and
not over borrowing and overborrowing it
at a exorbitant rates I think that
definitely has to be it has to be
um we're going to have a couple of
presentations here this morning I think
from the Department of Revenue first
from commissioner stepp and then from uh
attorney general formella from the
attorney in the Department of Justice I
will say this overall My Philosophy in
in the budget process overall and I'll
be sorry just to be clear I'll be
submitting the budget around Valentine's
Day is is that is that right is it on
Valentine's Day I always have that in my
head that it's Valentine's Day so I know
it's on or about Valentine's Day I think
the final date will actually be to be
determined with the legislature
um once they uh for the led the new
legislature forms up in early December
so around Valentine's Day we will uh
present the the full budget
we've obviously been working uh James
Gary and uh my as my budget director has
been working diligently with all the
different departments uh on what their
needs assessments are
um where they are in Staffing but I'll
say this overall without kind of giving
away too many of the details because
we're still a few months away this is
going to be a budget probably more than
ever before where it's people over
programs because I I go back to that
Workforce issue it has to be about
Workforce it has to be about our state
employees we have some great programs
and we've been very Innovative with new
programs in the state and that doesn't
mean we're not going to keep trying new
things of course but again if we don't
really Shore up where where we are and
what our staffing levels are going to be
and making sure that at the end of the
day we have the individuals to deliver
these Services none of the other
programs the program doesn't matter
right and unless you have the the people
in the drive behind it and so I think
overall that is a good
um umbrella philosophy that you'll see
at least out of out of my office and
hopefully the legislature will share
that that our priority really needs to
be about a lot of the individuals our
state employees
making sure not just that we retain them
but we create opportunities for them and
understand that we are competing with a
unprecedentedly expensive private Market
uh for for labor right now and there's a
variety of reasons for that that's
nothing we have to debate right now but
there's a whole variety of reasons why
the entire uh private Market is is uh
really tight with Staffing
um and and that's from teachers to
nurses to folks that work in restaurants
in the hardware store to folks that
deliver quality child welfare services
and opioid Recovery Services and all of
these really uh programs I've been that
I would consider prioritized and
necessary at the state level
so with that uh I guess I guess we can
what that would not this is where I go
and ask James what I missed any of the
key points that I missed there you hit
them all sir okay great at this time I'd
like to invite the Department of Revenue
good morning Lindsey stepp commissioner
Department of Revenue Administration
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity this morning to present the
fiscal 24 and fiscal 25 operating budget
request from the dra with me today our
assistant commissioner Ora Lemire and
business administrator Shelly garlano
the mission of the dra is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due incurring
the least cost of taxpayers in a manner
that merits the highest degree of public
competence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to Municipal
units of government in matters of Budget
Finance and the appraisal of Real Estate
together we developed a thoughtful
operating budget that will provide the
resources for our team to administer the
tax laws of our state for another two
fiscal years in a manner consistent with
this Mission we also worked hard to
produce a budget that is consistent with
the targets that were provided
in fiscal year 22 the dra collected 2.7
billion in state revenue with operating
expenses of less than 18.7 million
some of which
um of those operating expenses are for
activities unrelated to revenue
collection such as local assessment
review and state aid when those
unrelated costs are accounted for our
cost of collection is just over one half
of one percent
the slides included with this testimony
explain how we were able to build a
biennial budget that continues to be an
unparalleled return on state tax dollar
investment we look forward to working
with you governor and members of the
legislature as you build the next
two-year budget
foreign
moving to the slides
slide two is just a repeat of our
mission statement which I already went
over in the testimony
slide three just a high level overview
of dra who we are what we do we have the
administration unit which is my office
and the assistant commissioner's office
they also the unit also performs our
legal and tax policy work our back
office support our project management
Human Resources Etc
in our audit division our audit division
is divided into multiple bureaus we have
the in-state Bureau which audits
in-state taxpayers our multi-entity
Bureau which audits more of your
Regional New England businesses our
multi-state Bureau which typically
focuses on those very large
multinational companies think Fortune
500 and the like
our Discovery Bureau which uses federal
tax information that we receive from the
IRS to identify new taxpayers that when
they come into the state
and our tobacco unit which ensures our
compliance with the master settlement
agreement and reviews
um tobacco tax collected out in the
field
we have our collections division which
does exactly that they collect past due
uh collections for the dra our taxpayer
services division which does our
document processing that's where all the
money all the documents flow into they
also man our call center if you call
into our dra we have a five-person call
center they are wonderful they'll answer
any questions that you have and the
taxpayer services division also performs
routine maintenance on accounts
lastly the municipal and property
division uh they are busy at the moment
setting Municipal tax rates uh they also
oversee property appraisal the utility
property tax and gravel and Timber or
moving on to slide four the big picture
of our fiscal 2425 budget
we have fiscal 23 adjusted authorized
total for all funds of just over 22
million our 24 efficiency request is
22.6 million and our fiscal 25 is
22.9 almost 23 million
the budget is approximately 90 General
funds the education trust fund uh
expenditures that you see there are for
the low and moderate property tax relief
program which we administer and the
agency income is related to flood
control for the Merrimack River Valley
and the Connecticut River Valley
both years are consistent with the
targets as I mentioned that were
provided
moving on to slide five just highlights
of our 2425 budget current position
count is maintained at 156 full-time
classified and unclassified positions
including an additional four part-time
positions
our efficiency budget request does fund
six full-time positions that are
unfunded in our current budget two of
those positions are Revenue generating
and with each produce an estimated 1.5
million dollars over the biennium so
those are two multi-state tax Auditors
they obviously generate Revenue those
positions are currently unfunded if they
were funded we would anticipate about a
three million dollar increase in
revenues from those positions
our general fund operating budget is 75
of 75 salary and benefits we are a
department of people not things or
programs
our budget request includes sufficient
funding for employee training
out-of-state travel for audits overtime
for Peak periods and taxpayer services
and collections
maintaining a fleet of state-owned cars
for our in-state Audits and property
appraisal work and also a sufficient
postage for Dra Communications to
taxpayers
there are no budget increases for
one-time State Workforce efficiency
enhancement programs or Suite projects
we did receive funding for three
projects we are using one-time money for
one-time expenses so there's no increase
in our operating budget related to the
Sweet money that we received
division directors business office and
other managers worked hard to budget
conservatively and accurately requesting
on Page Six
so the Dre's efficiency budget as
submitted maintains all current
operations however there are certain
areas where dra has requested additional
funding in the form of prioritized needs
the first is for low and moderate income
hardship grants so chapter 95 laws of
2021 increase the income limitations and
the maximum amount of relief available
for the low and moderate program
so the change was effective for April
1st 2021 property tax year and there
were 500 and
5912 claims issued for about 1.4 million
dollars and that's compared to
5572 claims totaling 800 000 for the
prior year so we've seen almost doubling
of the program
the prioritized need of seven hundred
thousand dollars is to bring the
appropriation to the 1.5 million which
is what we expect to spend out of the
program going forward
in fiscal year 23 the difference between
the appropriation of eight hundred
thousand dollars and the actual expense
of close to 1.4 or 1.5 million will be
covered pursuant to RSA 198 colon 61
where the governor is authorized to draw
a warrant from the education trust fund
to satisf to satisfy the state's low and
moderate obligation so we'll draw a
warrant for this year but the
prioritized need is looking to have the
appropriate
moving on to page seven
we also have additional prioritized
needs related to our Revenue information
management system or rims just as a
reminder rims was a 30 million one
hundred and sixty thousand dollar
Capital appropriation that included
hardware and software maintenance
um or sorry software licensing through
fiscal 25 but it only included software
maintenance and Consulting through the
first quarter of fiscal 2024. so our
request includes maintaining our current
levels of software maintenance and
Consulting through fiscal 25 so that's
about 2 million dollars and 24 and 3.6
million dollars in 25.
and this also includes funding for two
doit positions that are embedded at dra
that are currently unfunded
there's really two reasons for these
positions one is to prepare for about 40
to 60 percent of our current embedded
doit staff will be eligible for
retirement during the next biennium and
so we're looking to add additional
positions higher employees so we can do
some knowledge transfer and make sure we
don't have a lot of knowledge walking
out the door with those retirements and
also those new positions would learn
from our rims Consultants to continue to
take on more of the rims maintenance
responsibilities
a portion of this request will also help
us prepare for the version upgrade of
rooms to core 21 and the funding for
that upgraded upgrade was uh received
through the suite program
I would just note that the reason why
we're now looking to kind of
operationalize these expenses that had
been covered in the capital budget is we
when we went out to bid for this work
and procured this work we opted to not
select predetermined levels of support
ongoing for rims because we really
didn't know what we were going to need
we didn't want to overbuy or under buy
so we have moved into a time and
materials model where we're getting just
the right amount of support that we need
and that gives us some flexibility again
to make sure that we didn't sign on for
support that was more than what we were
going to need or that we were left
short-handed in terms of support so
that's how we're kind of transitioning
from the capital appropriation into the
operationalizing of these costs through
on to page eight we have
um one other very small prioritized need
of three thousand dollars which comes
through the department of administrative
services
um in the budget that we submitted in
our efficiency budget there were two
additional prioritized needs and those
were funded by The Sweep program so one
was in fiscal 24 of 400 000 for a
high-speed scanner which is what we use
to process the tax returns and they come
into the building
um that will replace our current it5
scanner which is at end of life and so
we will be discontinuing that bringing
in a new scanner so we will be made
still maintaining two scanners so
they'll always have continuity of
operations so we haven't currently have
an it5 and an it6 the it5 will go away
we'll bring in the brand new scanner and
maintain the it6 so we can run both at
the same time
also in fiscal 24 there was a 400 000
upgrade
um an enhancement to our 11 year old
property Equalization web application to
the latest version and to include some
enhanced functionality again to help us
maintain continuity of operations within
staff in that division those two
prioritized needs are no longer needed
so they're included but they can be
removed because they were funded via
Suite
and lastly I just wanted to provide an
update of how the Department's doing in
its current two-year budget the fiscal
2223 our budget priorities
first related to rims the final rollout
went live on August 9th of 2021 with the
remaining tax types we really have
realized many benefits related to The
Rim system over the past year the
efficiency of the system has allowed the
dra to continue timely processing of
documents received even with a vacancy
rate close to 15 percent
we also saw Revenue uplift as part of
the Rams project
so Revenue increases from existing taxes
attributable to the Implement
implementation of rims reached the cap
of 4 million dollars in fiscal 22 we can
transfer up to four million dollars into
our rims Revenue uplift account every
year to help pay for the bonds that were
used to purchase the system reminder to
pay letters just a simple letter that
reminds you that you have a bill due to
the dra that generated 2.3 million
dollars and use enhanced use of federal
tax information again the information
that we receive from the IRS that we can
use to help identify non-compliant
taxpayers that generated 1.7 million
dollars
also customer service remains a priority
of the dra in fiscal 22 and fiscal 23 to
date we have maintained a rating of
three or higher on a scale of one to
five from 98 of our customer
satisfaction surveys the callers receive
at the end of the call into our call
center they have the opportunity to rate
the knowledge and the effectiveness of
the person that they spoke with they can
also leave a comment
um and some of those comments are very
uh
entertaining to to listen to there's a
lot of Praise of oh dra in New Hampshire
answers the phone I don't get that in a
lot of other states I don't get that
when I call into the IRS I really
appreciate being able to speak with a
live person
so customer satisfaction uh Still
Remains high and included with rims was
the launch of granite tax connect which
is the online portal which allows
taxpayers and practitioners to access
their accounts online make payments file
documents check their account status and
more we currently have over 30 000
external GTC users about 2500 are
third-party preparers and 28 000 are
taxpayers themselves so that's a huge
step forward for customer service for
the dra
that's where we are for 22 and 23 that's
all I had prepared for today and I'm
It's a combination So within the
contract we have negotiated hourly rates
so it's the hourly rates that we
negotiated in the contract and it's for
five to six of what we call fasties the
vendor is fast Enterprises five or six
fasties to stay on at time and materials
that were negotiated as part of the
project and the number of five to six
has been a joint
um decision between the vendor and dra
in terms of again not wanting too many
but making sure that we have the right
level of support
foreign
My Hope Is that we will always have a
few on site
um just because of their knowledge and
expertise within the system I do think
that in as we move forward we might find
that five is more than we need and we
might be fine with two or three
um but that will kind of depend as we
continue to move out of this
implementation phase and more into
actual the actual operation phase
foreign
that was our expenses for 22 18.7
million
that's total expenses right so and then
when you remove
the non-revenue collecting expenses is
correct roughly I think I did
correct it would be about yes 10 to 15
maybe 13 I think actually when I did out
we're currently about 15 so on November
15th we had 133 filled positions 27
bacon
and what we've really seen is the
we've seen a lot of opportunity for Dre
employees to receive promotions so we
have folks that have been promoted
within their division
um just last week I signed off on two
hires of people moving into a different
division you know so a slightly
different career path but we're doing
our very best to retain the employees
that we have right we taught them taxes
we'd like them to stay and so most of
our vacancies at this point are at more
of our entry level positions and so
we're able to keep morale High by making
sure that the folks have the opportunity
for promotions and rewarding folks with
those when they become available
foreign
yeah good morning commissioner I just
wanted you could talk a little bit about
how uh and we we dealt with a little bit
with sweet but how technology has
enabled you with with the work shortage
that not only your department says but
but the entire country is facing that uh
how that technology has helped you uh
bridge that Gap with your uh with your
vacancy rate and and how you can use
that technology maybe going forward or
the next biennium sure so
really especially now that we have
upgraded to Rams I mean technology is
how dra runs
um so
very simply there's basically two ways
you can file a tax return today you can
file it online either through the
modernized e-file system which is done
through the IRS or through granite tax
connect our online portal from rims if
you don't file online you're going to
send us a paper return
we're going to open it and we're going
to put it through our scanner that
scanner can has optical character
recognition so it can read what is on
the return or many Returns come in with
one of those 2D barcodes at the end
where all of the information is pulled
right out of that barcode so take dra
back 15 years that return would have
come in and it would have been hand
keyed everything would have been hand
keyed into the system it would have
taken months now we either get the
information off the form
or it's electronically filed what the
staff does at that point is they verify
the amounts if it is a paper return
they'll go in and say all right the
scanner thought this was a hundred was
it really a hundred dollars yes and they
they do more of data validation as
opposed to straight up data entry that
allows us to process all of our returns
by the end of each month so October is a
very large filing month for us Returns
on extension all of our returns that we
received in October were in the system
as the last as of the last day of
October
then once it's into the system rims does
its work so there's some automated
processes in rims
um also the rims will allow us to
prioritize certain types of work so when
you're processing a return you want to
First prioritize those returns with
money right the hundred dollars came in
with that return we want that money to
go into the bank next we're going to
prioritize returns that didn't have
enough money we're going to want to get
that bill out to that taxpayer as soon
as possible so the state can receive the
money next we're going to prioritize
refunds we're going to want to get that
money back to the taxpayer so that we
don't pay interest and so that the
taxpayer receives the money as quickly
as possible rims allows us to prioritize
all of that we can see how many
documents are within each queue and so
we can allocate our resources
appropriately so when we're down some
number of Staff we'll know okay hey guys
you have to work on this today rather
than just kind of a free-for-all in
terms of whatever returns had come in
once the returns are processed refunds
are processed bills are sent out I
mentioned the 2.3 million dollars we
generated just from sending an automated
reminder to pay letter that in the past
would have been work that would not have
gotten done until it made it to the
collections division so that's work that
the system is able to do
um on its own automated without having
bodies or people that needed to do that
so when we have vacancies and
collections that fills up frees up some
of their work and then also even when
when collections is fully staffed rather
than reminding folks to pay their bills
they can focus on actual Collections and
collect more money at the end of the day
so that's really everything we do at dra
these days is related to technology
um
and the sweep requests that we asked for
and received will just enhance and allow
us to do more with the technology that
thank you okay well thank you
commissioner
[Applause]
so next up we have the Department of
anyways
mm-hmm
why
foreign
good morning good morning Governor good
morning Mr budget director commissioner
all members of the panel uh my name is
John from Ella attorney general
department of justice I'm joined this
morning by Kathy Carr our director of
administration so I will try to answer
all the questions but if I miss one I'm
going to rely on Kathy to fill in the
fill in the gaps
so
we're we're happy to be here with the
opportunity to present our budget for
fiscal years 24-25. I wanted to start
out just by giving kind of an overview
of the department we didn't originally
include an organizational chart in our
presentation because we're redoing our
org chart so the one I've passed out is
a little bit out of date but it does
help you it helps give a just an overall
picture of the office so on slide two I
just give a list of you know the many
roles of the Attorney General so the
attorney general has multiple jobs and
through that the Department of Justice
has has a number of functions the first
is chief law enforcement officer we
supervise all law enforcement in the
state we work on policy for law
enforcement we coordinate with law
enforcement Chief prosecutor we
prosecute cases within the Department of
Justice and we also supervise all of the
County attorneys around the state chief
legal officer we provide legal advice
and client counseling to All State
agencies and we defend All State
agencies when they're sued public
protection the attorney general has
constitutional and common law locations
with regard to public protection though
there's sort of no firm border around
those the AG and the Department of
Justice have broad authority to
intervene in cases where they think the
the protection of the public is is a
play and then of course the AEG has to
be head of the Department of Justice so
functions as a commissioner and then we
also head up the state's drug task force
which operates throughout the state but
focuses mostly on the North country in
the southwest part of the state where
the police departments are smaller and
there are less they're less resources in
local departments so we help supplement
those resources through our drug task
force
as you'll see with the organizational
chart the department is broken down at a
high level into two divisions the
division of public protection that
contains the criminal justice Bureau the
Environmental Protection Bureau and the
consumer protection and Anti-Trust
Bureau the division of public protection
is best thought of for shorthand as as
the Criminal part of the office and then
the other division the division of legal
counsel for shorthand is best thought of
the Civil part of the office there is
some crossover and overlap between the
two public protection does some civil
work legal counsel does some criminal
work but for the most part it breaks
down between criminal and civil under
Kathy Carr the director Administration
we also have our business office our
victims compensation unit and our grants
management unit and then the office of
the solicitor general functions kind of
as a standalone entity within the office
we'll be looking for some tweaks in hb2
to clarify that but it functions as a
standalone entity it handles appeals so
we handle all Criminal Appeals in the
state and we also handle Civil Appeals
where the state is a party so the office
of the solicitor general really does
Criminal and civil work
so that's a high level overview of the
department we currently have 166
authorized positions so those include
full-time positions that does not
include part-time and temporary
positions we have a few temporary
positions right now including our YDC
positions which we don't expect to last
forever but to last for the next few
years
the next slide that that's in front of
you slide three just gives a snapshot of
some statistics I won't run through
these one by one but this is just uh
some highlights of of the things we've
handled over the past couple of years so
we do one of the one of the functions
that I'll point out is just our consumer
protection hotline we're really the only
entity in the state that takes those
types of calls so when consumers have an
issue with a business or they think
they've been ripped off by a contractor
it's the Department of Justice that they
call and it's the Consumer Protection
Bureau that does that work that looks at
those complaints that prosecutes those
cases that's just one example of where
in this state the Attorney General's
office acts as kind of the catch-all
where County attorneys may not have the
resources to take complaints in
prosecute cases we do that work and it's
real on the ground constituent service
what some might call small dollar cases
but they're the types of cases that the
average person experiences you know most
people don't experience a multi-million
dollar case the app average person might
experience an issue with their
contractor where they're out ten
thousand dollars but to an average
person that that's a lot of money and
that's potentially life-changing so the
work that the department does really
spans from that type of work all the way
up to the high profile homicides and the
multi-million dollar cases that you see
uh in the news
[Music]
with that I just I'll go into giving a
high level overview of our efficiency
budget the first thing to note which is
on page six
of the presentation is that we are a
mostly non-general-funded agency a good
chunk of our budget is General funds
about 38 but most of our budget is
either federal funds or other funds or
interagency transfers or Highway funds
it's Highway funds that fund our
transportation and construction Bureau
so that's that's important thing to keep
in mind when you're thinking about the
total budget for the Department of
Justice
so going to page eight
just on the efficiency budget highlights
the first thing I should note I did not
include this in the presentation but it
is important
we came in over Target in our efficiency
budget from a general fund standpoint
but if if you look at the the overall
budget in the budget booklet our total
adjusted authorized and efficiency for
fiscal year 23 was 40 million three
hundred ninety thousand sixty four
dollars
and our fiscal 24 efficiency budget is
40 million one hundred and eight
thousand eight hundred sixty four and
for 25 the efficiency budget is 40
the important point to make there is
that we are basically flat in our
efficiency budget from fiscal year 24 to
24.25 but where there are a couple
components that are causing our general
fund spend to go up which I'll talk
about now
the first that you see on page eight
uh says position moves
what we're doing here is moving
positions out of our consumer consumer
escrow fund to the general fund so the
consumer protection escrow fund right
now funds a number of positions within
the department and it's always really
been intended to fund the positions that
work within the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau
that fund brings in a fair amount of
money or has brought in a fair amount of
money over the years with large
multi-state settlements other fines and
penalties
each year we're allowed to keep up to 5
million and whatever is over 5 million
in that fund gets swept to the general
fund
for many years that fund has given a lot
of money back to the general fund so we
brought in far more than 5 million a
year the past few years we've seen
multi-state settlements Trend down I
think part of the reason for that is
covid but I also think the dynamic
between attorney general offices around
the country and the business Community
is changing businesses are pushing back
on some of these efforts I think offices
are bringing less of these cases because
they're trying to work with the business
community and be more collaborative so
it's not the cash cow that it has been
in past years it still brings in
sufficient funding
but one thing we saw probably over the
past four or five years is that because
that fund was bringing in a lot of money
gradually positions that were not
actually within the Consumer Protection
Bureau were being moved on to that Fund
in other words that fund was paying for
non-consumer Protection Bureau positions
what we're proposing to do in this
budget and requesting to do is move I
think it's six positions
out of that fund into the general fund
those six positions are positions that
are not part of the consumer protection
and antitrust Bureau so it's it's my
recommendation and proposal that we move
those positions back on to the general
fund for a couple reasons one is I have
a concern that over the long term the
consumer escrow fund is not going to
bring in enough money year to year to
fund positions that aren't related to
the Consumer Protection Bureau so that's
one concern the second concern is I just
think from an Institutional standpoint
it's better from an incentive alignment
point of view to not have a bureau you
know have to bring in money so have to
bring lawsuits or have to impose fines
and penalties to to pay for itself or
pay for everything that it's responsible
for so I think long term institutionally
it's a good idea to move those positions
back on to the general fund at the end
of the day it's a it's kind of a wash
financially because in years where we
bring in a lot of money anything over 5
million is going to go back to the
general fund anyway and in years where
we might be shorter or under 5 million
by having less positions on that fund
there's less of a chance that you have
to make a budget adjustment so that's a
big part of why we came in over Target
in the general fund component of our
efficiency budget
the second reason we came in over Target
was just benefit increases we have we've
been pretty successful with Recruitment
and Retention and bringing in new
attorneys along the spectrum of
experience but one thing we're seeing
which I think is good for the state
are a lot of young families our
demographic are is attorneys with young
families and young families bring High
benefit costs so that that's another
reason for us coming in over Target in
another big component of our efficiency
request
which doesn't result in an increase in
spend but results in an increase in the
number of full-time positions that the
department would have is our assistant
eight assistant Deputy medical examiners
or admes they are basically the
investigators for our chief medical
examiner and deputy chief medical
examiner so admes if there's a death
they go out to the scene they
investigate they do an external
evaluation of the body and they gather
information for the medical examiners in
the event that the medical examiner is
going to do an autopsy so admes operate
all over the state they're an important
component of the office of chief medical
examiner and they
they right now they are contractors so
that presents a challenge for us a
if you look on uh page 10 of the
presentation
there are a number of issues with having
admes as contractors they've been
contractors for a long time but the IRS
has raised concerns with that structure
in the past the reason is that while
admes are contractors in many ways they
function as employees they they can be
difficult to manage when they're not
employees because they're contractors
they're they're all over the state and
we don't have the the level of control
over them that we would have if they
were employees we sometimes struggle
with coverage in certain parts of the
state and when admes are are contractors
and not employees we don't have as much
flexibility to send them to different
areas of the state
um so we are proposing in this budget if
something Governor you're interested in
and then the team is interested in to
convert the admes from contractors to
full-time employees we think we can do
this
and actually have our total spend go
down slightly because right now we're
paying
if you look on page 12 of our
presentation
The Five-Year average spend
for admes for paying for them to be
contractors is one million three hundred
sixty seven thousand one hundred and
fifty dollars
and our total request which would
involve converting these contractors to
10 full-time employees with some
additional expenses would be one million
269 532 dollars in fiscal year twenty
four and one million 282 1 158 in fiscal
year 25.
so we think there are we think there are
advantages to having the admes be
full-time employees and we actually
think we can reduce the total spend by
doing that so I think there are some
efficiencies there so we thought we
would propose that in this budget this
is also something that Dr Duvall our
chief medical examiner and Dr Weinberg
our deputy chief medical examiner are
strongly supportive of and they have
asked for this they believe that their
their operation will will be much more
efficient and much easier to manage if
if we make this conversion
as you know we've also struggled now for
about a year and a half to hire a third
medical examiner we do have an open
position for a third medical examiner
and Dr Duvall and Dr Weinberg think that
by making this conversion we'll be more
in line with other states and we will be
more competitive from a recruiting and a
retention standpoint we'll this will
just bring us up to par with other
states
so that is that's a big part of our
efficiency budget and while it doesn't
result in a overall spending increase it
does result in 10 new positions so we
know that that is always something that
both the governor and the legislature
think seriously about adding that many
full-time positions to the state roles
happy to answer more questions on that
but that's a high level overview of that
so that is that's our efficiency budget
in in a nutshell
um I've hit it pretty quickly but again
we are while we're increasing our
general fund spend we are basically flat
in the efficiency budget so I think we
we overall from a total spend standpoint
certainly came under the three percent
Target but we did exceed that Target
next I'll just go into our prioritized
needs we do have about
on top of an efficiency budget of
roughly 40 million dollars we do have
total prioritized needs request of
roughly 9 million dollars but I think
that number sounds higher than it really
is and I'll explain why
if you look at page 14 of our
presentation
this lists out
our major requests and prioritized needs
the first one that jumps right off the
page is the litigation fund request
that's five million dollars
typically
the governor and you and the legislature
don't actually budget our full
litigation fund needs in the budget
typically we get maybe a few hundred
thousand then we go back to fiscal as
needed to get litigation funds
our litigation fund spend has been going
up in recent years so I felt it would be
prudent to include this in our budget
requests just to sort of give everyone a
sense of what we think we will spend
but that is five million dollars of our
prioritized needs so that's that's a big
chunk in our prioritized needs that
typically wouldn't even be budgeted but
we felt it was important to present that
to you for consideration as to whether
you might want to budget part of that
this year
the next big piece of our prioritized
needs is rent for the new space that
we'll be moving to over a granted place
that lease was just approved as we know
last week at the exec at the governor
and council meeting so because we will
now be renting a non-state building at
least for the first year
our rent is much higher from a budget
perspective than it than it has been so
in talking with Das we felt it was most
appropriate to include that in in
prioritized needs it's certainly a need
but it
you know we would not have come anywhere
close to our general fund Target had we
included that in the efficiency budget
so that's another big piece of our
prioritized needs
the third piece is autopsy expenses we
and
this is we this is in prioritized needs
because this includes mostly expenses
for locums so essentially temporary
medical examiners to fill in when our
medical examiners aren't available I
think we have enough inefficiency to get
by but there's some additional budget
space that that we would like and so
we've included that in prioritized needs
we included some money for attorney
raises in our efficiency budget we
included some additional money for
raises and prioritized needs again I
think we we met the Baseline in our
efficiency budget but as we all know
with inflation and with the competitive
market there are some there's some
additional budget capacity we'd like to
have for attorney raises happy to answer
questions about that but we included
that in prioritized needs because while
I think it's important I don't think it
would be fair to say it's a it's a core
necessity given that we already had some
money for raises in our efficiency
budget
and then
the the last major component of our
prioritized needs as it is for many
agencies comes in positions
so if you look on page 15 of our
presentation that gives a snapshot of
the additional positions we're asking
for and prioritized needs we're
requesting six attorney positions two
investigator positions and five support
staff positions
on the next page page 16 goes into a bit
the attorney positions are
in the Civil Bureau two civil litigators
one Criminal Justice attorney
one Environmental Protection Bureau
attorney
One Transportation construction Bureau
attorney and one training attorney
so the civil litigation
attorneys the easiest explanation for
the need for those can be seen in the
litigation Fund in the increase in
spending out of that fund that we've
seen over the past few years essentially
what happens is when we don't have
enough civil litigators to cover the
work that we need to do to defend the
State against lawsuits that are brought
against the state we have to tap our
litigation fund by bringing in
assistance from outside Council and
tapping different e-discovery tools and
other things to help us manage documents
and manage our civil litigation load
we certainly could never
eliminate all of the litigation fund
spending by adding civil litigators but
I do think that our civil litigation
unit is under resourced and has been
under-resourced for some time and while
we currently have one vacancy there I
think we could use we could really use
two additional civil litigation
positions so that is the reason for that
request
the Criminal Justice attorney request
comes basically from our our Cold Case
unit a couple years ago the legislature
added a second full-time attorney
position to the Cold Case unit I think
for very good reasons through covid we
didn't have the department did not have
the chance to increase the operations of
the Cold Case unit the way it wanted to
and one of those positions was
ultimately unfunded in the last budget
when I came in I moved a position from
somewhere else in the office into the
Cold Case unit to expand it back to two
two full-time positions which we're
currently recruiting for now so this
additional Criminal Justice attorney
position is essentially to
backfill the position I moved into the
into the Cold Case unit
the Environmental Protection Bureau
attorney position this is a request from
our Bureau but it's also a need that's
been expressed by the Department of
Environmental Services part of the
funding for that position comes from Des
so
our I think the Environmental Protection
Bureau has been flat position wise for
for quite a few years there's a lot of
work there that Bureau doesn't just
handle Des it also handles energy work
and with the new Department of energy
now being its own department and not
just the puc there's enough additional
work there that that we felt it was
appropriate to request a new position at
least in prioritized needs
our transportation construction Bureau
which is kind of deceptively or
confusingly named I should say because
it covers not just the Department of
Transportation but the department of
safety that Bureau could really use an
additional attorney because over the
past couple years as we know with all
the criminal justice reform efforts uh
the new litigation surrounding the EES
now that it's public all of the efforts
the department of safety has undertaken
there are just additional needs for the
department of safety that could be
served in that Bureau by a new attorney
there are also some temporary needs in
the short term that a new attorney could
help with given all of the money coming
in uh through the federal infrastructure
bill that the Department of
Transportation is is managing
and then the last attorney position is a
is a training attorney we currently have
one attorney who is uh essentially a
training prosecutor they both help train
prosecutors in the office they train
prosecutors out in the county attorney
offices given all the workforce
challenges right now that we're seeing
throughout the Criminal Justice System
including uh among the prosecute
prosecution bar we think it would be
helpful to have an additional training
attorney who can help all of the new
attorneys coming into the various County
attorney offices around the state so
that explains our position requests from
an attorney standpoint
support staff positions we have five
requests there one thing that I think is
important to emphasize is that the
Department of Justice at the end of the
day is is basically a law firm and while
when you think of a law firm the first
thing you think of is lawyers support
staff are just as critical and frankly
in many ways more critical than the
attorneys and I think the office has
fallen behind
in recent years from a support staff
position
sometimes in tough budget Cycles when
you have to make a cut and you're a law
firm your first instinct is not to cut
an attorney position it's to cut a
support staff position so part of what
we're looking to do here is is make up
for some of that we won't make up for
all of that I don't think you can in one
budget cycle I don't think you should
try to in one budget cycle but adding
one civil paralegal and one civil Legal
Assistant is part of the effort to make
up for that
another position that we're asking for
on the support staff front is a HR
coordinator
when it comes to prioritizing our
prioritized needs I would say we
probably have no more important need
within the Department of Justice than an
HR coordinator the department has grown
big enough that I think we really need
someone dedicated to managing our human
resources issues I think a lot of
agencies have that function we have not
had that function our chief of staff
manages a lot of that but the chief of
staff is also an attorney and so having
having an HR coordinator to work with
the chief of staff to manage the many HR
needs that we have within our office is
perhaps our most important
prioritize need when it when it comes to
positions
and then we also have two position
requests for our office of victim
witness assistance both an additional
victim witness Advocate and an
additional victim Witness Program
specialist that office the office of
victim witness assistance is is a
critical component of the office because
it works with victims of crime it works
with Witnesses in our cases who often
are also victims as as you can imagine
with with various criminal cases
and it also does a lot of important
programming working with the Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence
with Casa with the child advocacy
centers around the state to train to
provide continuing education for these
various these various professionals
around the state so that office could
use a bit more resources but we've
included that in prioritized needs
because I think the office is doing a
great job now that office can get by but
it could certainly use some additional
resources
so that is our presentation I know I ran
through that pretty quickly happy to
answer answer questions I
have a couple of quick ones just so on
the
asmes I'm sorry the apmes you think a
million dollars is enough to cover the
cost of 10 individuals am I bringing
that right that sounds low but if that's
what it is that's that's what it is so
it's it's about one point
uh yeah oh yeah the total is 1.2 the 10
full-time positions is a million so
admes are different than medical
examiners they're not doctors right so
they they are basically technical
support staff for the medical examiners
so yeah based on the labor grade they
would be we think that's enough okay
great
um
okay that's all I had
okay good morning uh one of the great
things about when you contract out is
typically you don't have to find the
employees you apply the contract and
they find the employees with the admes
if we go this route how confident are
you that you can be able to actually
find the employees to take these jobs
that's a great question and something
we've we've thought about as well I
think Dr Dr Duvall and Dr Weinberg are
confident that we will be able to find
find people to fill these jobs uh it
goes without saying that there's a
chance we we may not be and if we aren't
I think we're going to have to to
reevaluate but but they're confident we
can find people to take these jobs
um we'd start with the individuals who
were currently using as contractors
perhaps not all of them would want to
work full-time but we think we're
confident that some of them some of them
will so we're confident we certainly
can't guarantee it but we think it's
hi hi uh first of all your presentation
is very pretty did you get it done at
graphic services
of course you did I noticed I'm going to
interrupt and say I did notice it was in
color and I encourage all the future
presentations to be in black and white
it looks very expensive foreign
in Kathy's case though having previously
run graphic Services I suspect she got a
deal
um a couple of questions your Consumer
Protection Bureau and do you have stats
for maybe four or five years on how much
that's raised each year I know there's
the over over and above a number goes
back to the general fund I think that
might help make your case
I don't expect you to have them with you
yeah so one slide I I glided right past
but probably to our disadvantages is
slide number four in the presentation
this
this slide gives a high level overview
of the money that the Department of
Justice has brought in over the last two
years and it's
significant money so we've collected and
deposited 126.7 million dollars into the
general fund over the last two years
that does not include the 52.7 million
dollars from the opioid the opioid
settlements and the Consumer Protection
Bureau did a lot of work on the on those
opioid cases
um the Consumer Protection Bureau itself
just for consumers so getting
restitution for consumers collected 2.79
million dollars over the last two years
that's just a small component of what it
collected
so that that gives uh that gives a high
level overview that answers your
question but we certainly have
stats that give the exact amounts
brought into the consumer escrow fund
over the last few years which we could
provide both you and and the governor's
team
that's great this is a great Slide by
the way
um attorney raises I want to make a
reference to everybody here not
everybody will know this that collective
bargaining agreement affects everybody
all classified and non-cut or
unclassified employees one group of
people it does not affect is Attorneys
at the Department of Justice other than
the attorney and Deputy attorney general
and it's worth noting that
that's why nobody else has money in
their budget that way and that then that
you do and I think it's just not
everybody realizes that you there's this
one group of people that's paid a little
bit differently
um as our 2010 reform
the second thing I wanted to ask about
was ADM admes and it and it goes to the
budget directors question
um
hiring is it possible you end up in a
situation where you hire some positions
and you have some people stay as
contractors so in that sense the request
is scalable
yes that is possible the way I've
thought about this is that if if the
governor and his team are
Grant this request then I think that
will entail some additional work working
with the budget director working with
Kathy to structure this in a way that
allows for some flexibility on that
front
so I I think if if there's an interest
in moving forward with making that
conversion we can certainly assist with
that work to do it in a way that
allows it to be flexible in case we
can't fill all the positions right away
thanks
good morning good morning um this also
has to do with those positions I know
that during the federal IRS audits this
definitely has come up
um in the Bureau of accounts area I know
they are subject to the they usually
deal with all the federal audits have we
gotten any penalties for these positions
yet or is it just something that they've
come up and they've been concerned about
but we haven't actually been
if you had any penalties for it we've
not been issued any penalties and we've
not been told definitively by the IRS
that we have to do this I think the
concern has come up enough that that
that's a reason that it might be a good
idea to get out in front of it but I
would to be to be perfectly truthful and
transparent I don't see this as legally
required at this point could be down the
road and then just more of a general
question because a lot of your both in
efficiency and prioritize these are
position related what's your current
vacancy and with adding some of these
positions do you think that do you are
you struggling with the same Workforce
work for the shoes as everyone else
foreign
yeah so out of our 166 positions we do
currently have 20 vacancies between
um
I'll say this one that's as of right now
so I we've got some folks coming in to
especially in the civil litigation realm
I actually think part of well we have a
vacancy there
part of our inability to retain in
certain areas of the office is the fact
that certain areas are under resourced
and so the people who are in those areas
are are overworked but we have been
pretty successful in recruiting and
retention over the last year and a half
so it it's certainly a fair question and
I think something for for us to think
about but we feel pretty confident we
can fill the positions if we get them
foreign
okay
okay I'd like to invite the Human
again
you want to move over or yeah I don't
hey I'd like to call this meeting back
to order and again I'd like to invite
the Human Resources Commission for their
testimony
all right good morning
my name is Ani Malachi I am the director
of The Human Rights Commission we are a
small state agency and
um
our opportunity is to help the citizens
of New Hampshire in the area of civil
rights and I'm very pleased to be here
this morning I don't usually have an
opportunity to be an advocate because we
we don't take a side in in the cases
that we have before us but today I get
to Advocate on behalf of my agency and
the amazing staff that I have that do
the work day in and day out if you look
and we are at the back half of the
Department of Justice's presentation so
I believe we start on page 17 and if you
go right on to 18 well I will start with
Who We Are
um so just a very brief history the
commission was established in 1965
and we are governed by RSA 354-a and
um our purpose is to eliminate
discrimination in the areas of
employment housing and public
accommodation and as of 2019 K-12 public
education was included and public
education means Public Schools excuse me
Public Schools public academies as well
as charter schools
the commission is comprised of seven
volunteer Commissioners they are
nominated by the governor and a point uh
confirmed excuse me by the executive
Council they serve a five-year term and
they come from various walks of life
each commissioner
um
provides an opportunity from the from
their perspective of what area of Life
they come from whether they be business
owners people that are just in the
community whether they work with the
disability community and a variety of
other areas
uh the commission and on page 19 now the
commission has the power to receive
investigate and pass upon complaints of
illegal discrimination and we also are
responsible to engage in research
education and community outreach and all
of this is to help to prevent
discrimination
in addition to the authority vested to
the vested in the commission we also
have a workshare agreement with the EEOC
our federal partner and the EEOC is the
United States equal employment
opportunity commission and we work with
them to enforce the federal laws as well
as the local state laws here in the
state of New Hampshire to work towards
ending discrimination
on page 20 I have an organizational
chart
and this is how we are currently
situated
um so there are five full-time
investigators
um there's an intake coordinator that
job is now a full-time position there's
an assistant director who is
specifically
responsible for supervising the staff we
have a part-time paralegal and we also
um currently the administrative
assistant which is a part of our
organizational chart we still have that
position on the on the books so to speak
but it is unfunded and we have a
part-time intake coordinator and that
position is currently unfunded
so we'll do a quick overview over on
page 21 and the numbers so this is an
average of cases that we've taken in
cases that have been closed and our
average number of cases that we have per
year so the way that the commission
works with our federal
um workshare agreement we close a case
and then we are basically reimbursed for
what the EEOC is offering for the
closure of that case and we have a
contract in that contract number changes
every year for this for federal fiscal
year 22 we have a contract amount of 200
cases but actually this year we were
able to Upward modify and we actually
closed 245 cases federal cases not
including the in-state Charge cases that
we have had and have closed
um our budget is in 85 15 so 85 percent
we are General funded 15 percent uh
covers uh is covered by our federal uh
reimbursement work share agreement
and over on page 22
um I have a nice long list of
prioritized needs
um and
um certainly to reinstate the
administrative assistant position that
position has been unfunded since 2020 it
has been definitely a blessing to be to
be administratively attached to the
Department of Justice who helps us
tremendously with some of our
administrative functions but to not have
an administrative assistant has been a
challenge to say the least
um so to also reinstate funding for that
part-time intake coordinator in our
intake department we could have as
little as nine cases
um that come in in a month or as many as
30 uh that we've had over the years it
really just depends but that person is
not simply taking in a charge there's a
lot of administrative paperwork that um
that accompanies that charge as well as
other elements of how we do our internal
process and having the additional set of
hands that part-time employee definitely
will make the difference
I'm also requesting four additional
anti-discrimination investigators
with having five currently we are doing
everything that we can do however having
more hands to pull from the pot so to
speak will certainly assist us in moving
through what we currently have right now
as a case backlog and it will make a big
difference in helping constituents be
able to file charges appropriately to be
able to for us for us to be able to do
things in a very timely manner
and also adding an informational
representative of course there would be
a much snazzier title but that
individual will be responsible for
training
um that is part of our
um statute that we are supposed to do
Outreach Education and Training and
currently that is limited to the time
available for myself or for the
assistant director to be able to provide
training and as any enforcement agency
would tell you certainly you can write
tickets and and serve fines but the way
that you work to assist people in no
longer doing whatever that action is is
through training and doing Outreach and
connecting with whether it's state
agencies non-profits or other
non-governmental entities to further the
information and making sure everyone is
is treating everyone fairly and in a
non-discriminatory way
I'm also requesting the conversion of
two part-time positions So currently the
paralegal position which is funded would
like to have that become a full-time
position as well as our part-time
secretary there is more than enough work
to be able to be done and the creation
of the paralegal position as of 2020
that individual is very
um
important in providing the legal support
work that's necessary for motions that
come in that we need to rule on as well
as preparing for hearings that we do
have and we take care of those in-house
and then having a full-time secretary is
certainly making sure that packages are
received that information leaves
um and in a in a proficient manner as
well as being available for projects
with our contract with the EEOC we are
also responsible in making sure that we
do Outreach events and so having someone
that can feel phone calls and prepare
packets for workshops that we may do
whether free or charged is important to
the agency
and as well as funding a cost for a move
to a new location
potentially There's an opportunity
hopefully to move with our partner the
doj something of that nature would be a
very logical step to have us in the same
building as them not only do they
represent the the Commission in times if
we have need of legal representation but
it is also imperative with our
day-to-day work to be able to have our
client Services
representative available for us and if
there are larger lawsuits that the
commission needs to engage upon on
behalf of the state as well as indeed
for our mission which is ending
discrimination to be right next door or
a floor above or below is a very logical
is a very logical step for us and
in that the move of course costs money
and the larger space would have
certainly be more money because we need
additional space if these additional
um
staff members that I'm requesting are
are awarded to us we will need a larger
space we need a hearing space
etc etc and of course there are doit
shared costs that are always a part of
our prioritized needs budget so with
that I will end and if there are any
questions I'm happy to answer them yeah
thank you very much first good morning
and morning again and on on page 21 you
have a list of the are there a number of
the cases filed per month over a
12-month period of 193. uh and then the
case is closed two-part question
how long is it take to typically close a
case once it's filed and and two is 193
a big number large number historically
is that is the problem getting worse
better staying the same how does that
number work historically okay thank you
for the questions
um so uh I I would not say worse
um I would say that uh in terms of the
193 number and the which you're quoting
is the case is filed
um I think part of it is that
um there has been some Outreach there
has been some education over the past
few years people are beginning to
understand more and more what their
rights are and I think there's become
some clarity in that I think I may have
been discriminated against there's a
place that I can go to get to to find
out if this is the case and we take a
charge based on what the person filing
the charge is telling us and obviously
there has to be an investigation to
determine if there is what we call
probable cause if this discrimination
did happen or not or sometimes we have a
situation where someone so there was
discrimination but the company actually
took did what we call prompter prompt
remedial action and did everything they
were supposed to do the person still can
file a charge with us if they so desire
and then we would go through the process
to determine if the I shouldn't say if
the charge is Merit but if if there's
further action that needs to be taken
based on the investigative findings of
the commission so that part to answer
that first part
um with that said
on the average 193 it actually Ebbs and
flows every year so at the very least
what we're going to have is whatever our
contract number is because that's what
we're obligated to to
um to provide in terms of fulfilling our
work our portion of the workshare
agreement with the EEOC so there are
some here so for example this year we uh
this past Federal fiscal year 22. we had
245 cases so there could be more there
could be fewer
um it really it really does depend right
now where we are is we have a pending
file so we have cases that are waiting
for investigation and we have a little
over 200 of those that are currently
waiting investigation which is why I'm
asking for the four additional
investigators
we have a situation where once the
person brings a charge and it's docketed
and both parties are notified moves very
smoothly and that is of course based on
when the complainant will bring the
charge once the case is invested excuse
me once the case is assigned it moves
pretty smoothly through to investigation
to a determination whether it goes to
court whether it goes to a hearing with
us whether the parties settle that moves
pretty smoothly the the hiccup happens
in between once it's docketed prior to
being assigned that's where it's waiting
obviously they're going to be outlier
cases sometimes they're things that are
very complex sometimes there's a a
bankruptcy for example and we would have
to stay and wait until those proceedings
go those are the outliers on average
um it it may take a year once it's
assigned to completion there are some
that are that long some that are more
complex there are some that could be
three six months it just depends so I
know that's not the pinpoint answer but
it's kind of it's a moving Target
because it really depends on the
complexity of the case how many elements
are in the case so that makes it a
I just wanted to note that the
commission and I are the same age
um
that was nice
um we were both established in 1965.
um
you have uh 193 cases filed 276 closed
and the number that's greater is the
reverse of what I would have expected so
you closed 50 more cases than were filed
I'd suggest a backlog
still yes so within that year within
this time
um we have there there are these other
considerations so we have staff turnover
sometimes and so when a person leaves
their caseload is then reassigned to
other investigators that remain and so
that's on top of whatever their regular
caseload is and so those cases that are
awaiting assignment will need to wait a
little longer until
we're able to to move through the cases
that were reassigned and
um and so for for this year specifically
um even with with investigator turnover
we had two investigators leave the
commission we still were able to Upward
modify and close an additional 45 more
cases than we were contracted to close
with the EEOC yes we do get paid for
those
um sometimes they'll allow even more so
we we go back to the well and we do ask
for additional funds but the the way it
works as you can I'm sure you can assume
here but cases come in that doesn't stop
and so as they're coming in we when we
pull from those that are waiting we take
from the oldest and move to the newest
and so that's that's a part of that
number
I mean it's nice to see that you're
reducing the backlog
um the only other thing I would add is
that on Space you don't seem to I
understand the need for space but you
um in my prioritized needs I did put in
the money for the move
oh where's the move I'm sorry where's
so it's in the efficiency instead of the
prioritize oh okay that's great yeah how
much are you anticipating the new rent
um I am not sure we are still working
with the Department of administrative
services
fine sir uh to to get a uh an actual
Target
um the estimate was around two hundred
thousand dollars I'm certainly hoping it
will be much less than that
oh
well I'll just I'll just make it and
then we should talk about moving costs
too because yes
yes ask Kathy how much she she has to
set aside
I think it's a million dollars to move
doj oh
thank you very much and I'm sorry it was
one other thing so on I think it was on
page 22 at the bottom
um just to add to the moving thank you
for for asking that question
um commissioner arlinghaus
um our lease where we are currently it
expires uh October of 2023 and we do not
have a renewal uh opportunity at this
point
um and uh the building is up for sale so
fingers crossed
okay I'd like to invite The Liquor
Commission to come up next for their
testimony
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the governor and I are most appreciative
New Hampshire Liquor Commission oh
thanks Tina and with me is Tina dimirs
our CFO just a couple of brief numbers
before we get into the presentation I
just wanted to uh let you know that um
our total net profit from The Liquor
Commission year to day through October
31st is a 54 million dollars we've
transferred 11.5 million dollars to the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund and revenue before additional funds
to HHS is 42.5 million so that puts us
on plan where half of us a half a
percent below plan at this point
for the year
uh let's see our retail numbers are down
uh 4.25 or 13.6 million even though
we're on plan
we're pretty pleased with that given
that
the structure of the economy at this
point
and we feel due to the lack of employees
we weren't able to expand our summer
hours this year and we weren't able to
expand holiday hours this year so we
feel that given those additional
employees when the time comes when we
get to that point we would have been on
plan
or above plan
half a million dollars to US is on plan
so we're down at this point about a
hundred part-time employees and about 40
and then we'll go to the presentation
so on page two the introduction is that
the Liquor Commission is self-funded
in a separate fund outside of the
general fund
and none of our Appropriations are used
none of general fund Appropriations are
used to maintain our operations
now last year we did
771 million dollars in F-22
it shows that we operated 67 retail
outlets
Niner state-owned 58 or leased and at
the bottom
the budget presented is a level funding
necessary to accomplish the commission's
good morning good morning
so on page three are our Revenue
estimates and since we're self-funded
our projected revenue is dependent on
the budget that we are requesting and as
the chairman mentioned we're on target
for this year's plan which we think is
notable in this ever-changing business
environment and unpredictable National
economy especially since current year
it's important to also remind everyone
of the rsas governing the revenue
transfers prior to our transfer to the
general fund and you'll see those on the
bottom of the page
um
the first transfer is under RSA 17616
and this is calculated in our plan since
it's the five percent of the prior year
gross profit and this is on line two on
the table and then there's RSA 126 AAA
colon 3. and this one is not in our
Revenue plan because it's the additional
funds by HHS and that is identified as
line five
as additional transfer to granted
advantage
you'll see in the table that our liquor
and beer plant numbers are rows four and
seven our liquor plan for FY 24 is 139.5
million and F 125 is 140.1 million beer
so if you go to page four this is a
listing of a major expense categories
and they correspond to the table and the
line numbers identified on page five as
a map
so I won't read through all the
categories but there are a couple of
categories we think are important to
highlight
the first one is number one salaries and
benefits it's decreasing in FY 24 in
spite of us requesting the 28 new
positions that we have in our efficiency
budget and this is because of a
reduction in overtime and part-time
budget requests and changes in positions
as a result of turnover
and the fy25 increase our result of
salary steps and benefit increases
the next notable items are number six
technology hardware and software and
number seven doit
these are both for increasing for
additional prioritized needs requests to
support the next-gen
d365 software platform that is replacing
our current point of sale and back
office Financial system
the increase in technology hardware and
software is for subscription and
existing support and maintenance
contracts and the doit request is for
two new positions to support the new
system handheld devices and cloud
services
you also see that a few of the
categories are underfunded in FY 23
based on the FY 22 spend which is
causing a greater percent of increase in
the FY 24 numbers and this is a result
of cost increases and shifts in business
needs
Pages six and seven these show the
annual breakdown by class and accounting
unit you'll see that the breakdown is
consistent for both years for the class
and the accounting units our FY
24 efficiency budget is increasing 2.3
million or 2.7 percent more than the FY
23 adjusted authorized budget
plus there's a 3.3 million increase for
the additional prioritized needs which
brings us to a total increase of the 6.9
percent or 5.7 million and that 3.3
million is the increase in hardware and
software technology hardware and
software and the doit
uh salaries and benefits and travel are
decreasing while the other categories
are increasing due to cost inflation and
projected needs such as utilities
equipment or Dent debt rent contracts
and then the doit and Technology
software
and then on page seven you have the fy25
total budget it's 3.1 million or a 3.5
percent increase over the FY 24 total
budget and this is for the salary step
increases and benefits and for the same
cost inflation and projected needs in
so on page eight is our organizational
structure the commission is made up of
three divisions that report to the
chairman and the Deputy Commissioner the
chart shows each division with the
number of unclassified and classified
positions assigned to each along with a
list of the Departments assigned
you'll see in red the 28 new positions
we're requesting two are in audit and
inventory control for an accountant and
an additional internal auditor and this
was based on a recommendation from a
prior audit report
uh the other positions are under
marketing and Merchandising two are in
marketing uh one's for an additional
marketing uh beverage marketing
specialist and a program assistant for
data research and Analysis
and then there are the 24 new retail
store clerk positions that we're asking
for for various retail outlets to meet
the needs of customers processing
transactions and managing inventory in
then you have page 9 through 13 and
these are all a summary by division as
they're listed in the budget requests
with page references to the budget book
uh there's a pie chart on each showing
the breakdown by class category and an
explanation for major changes
so the first is on page nine and this is
the office of the commission
the office of the commission is
overseeing all operations of the
commission with the primary goal to
increase sales and maximize profits
while operating in a cost-effective and
efficient manner
the one item to note is the increase in
FY 24 of about 307 000. this is to add a
consultant line to support doit with the
next gen system we currently are paying
for that out of another class line for
FY 23 so we wanted to add it for the
2425 budget
and 25 is increasing for the same
reasons of salary step increases and
benefits
and then increases in cost to support
so on page 10 is the division of
enforcement this includes enforcement
licensing education and grants the
division is responsible for enforcing
alcoholic beverage laws enforcing youth
access to tobacco and providing
licensing education and support for over
6 100 licensees
in FY 22 the division collected over 19
million in Revenue
in fy24 the but their budget is
decreasing 6.6 percent and this is due
to changes in positions as a result of
turnover and then there increases for
so then on page 11 you have the division
of an Administration this includes doit
HR and finance and included in finance
is audit uh inventory control and legal
all of these departments Provide support
to all the other departments within the
commission
the fy24 increase of 20 or 1.7 million
is primarily for the additional
prioritized needs for doit along with
adding an allocation for indirect costs
and then the two new positions that I
previously mentioned
and then fy25 is also for salary steps
on page 12 is the division of marketing
and Merchandising this includes
marketing merchandising advertising our
retail store outlets and the
headquarters Warehouse
the division oversees the buying pricing
marketing selling and distributing of
products throughout all our channels to
promote sales and maximize profits
fy24 increase of 5.2 percent or 3.5
million is in large part for the
increase in the technology hardware and
software for the additional prioritized
needs to support the next gen system and
for continuing operations for contracts
rent equipment supplies and utilities
and then the fy25 3.9 or 2.7 million
increase is mainly for the salary steps
and benefits and the cost of doing
business in areas such as increases in
our metal store shelving supplies
and then on page 13 is workers comp and
unemployment comp
workers comp and FY 23 is actually
underfunded and the increase in FY 24 is
based on the historical Trend the
increase is because as we continue to be
understaffed and ask more of our
employees we are seeing a higher amount
of claims
and at this point I will turn it back
over to the chairman
thanks Tina
so just quickly uh on page 14
establishing a retail employee incentive
you'll just turn your attention to
paragraph three four and five uh this is
something that is has been adopted has
been through jail car the rules are done
it's something that my I put into action
in 2011 with Governor Lynch it's
something that we've never used at The
Liquor Commission but we've had it
available to us since 2011.
given the circumstances that we're under
basically the the paid disparaging
between what we're seeing on the outside
in business and what the state is paying
we felt that it's now time to put it
into action
it'll be broken down uh by the seven
areas that the supervisors seven
supervisor areas
the employees will be allowed to gain an
incentive based on additional sales so
this is something that we've worked
closely with the governor's office I had
three or four different variations of
how this was done
the governor was very supportive of this
piece because it allows the employees to
Garner some additional rev wages while
the commission Garners some additional
Revenue one of the uh a couple of the
caveats with it uh our average part-time
employee now works about 15 hours a week
this will require anybody that's
involved in this program to work at
least 21 hours a week as you'll see in
paragraph five
obviously our goal is to see part-timers
that have various jobs not only with us
but with other outside businesses to
come work for us for an additional day
or two and then be able to take part in
and then on page 15 you'll see that the
uh
the language and italics that will be
added basically what we're asking for is
for this to be paid from the additional
sales that take place at the commission
give us the ability to pay the res the
incentive program based on the
and on page 16 this is to establish an
independent retail outlet pay scale for
an employee program basically what we're
seeing is just you know it's
every businessman
that's successful and worth his salt
quite frankly has allowed their
employees to take part in some sort of
arrays as they move through covet and
into the post-covet operations of
business
uh we're we're clearly below what other
retailers are paying and that you'll see
the language on page 18 and 19.
uh as I said we weren't able to expand
our summer hours we weren't able to
expand our holiday hours we're certain
that we'll be able to increase sales to
cover these
uh additional expenses we don't know
what that will look like yet as far as
dollars and cents are concerned uh in
addition to the incentive program but
it's something that we certainly think
that we need to look at
as I said the language for that is on
page 19 and both of these
have been brought forth in hb2 now this
is not for the headquarters employees
it's not for enforced and it's not for
marketing or warehousing it's just for
the retail employees in our stores and
obviously that's where the rubber hits
the road retail equals Revenue
and you'll notice on the last page on
page 20 as a summary source that was in
the New Hampshire news
the rates of pay around the state the
medium hours and the goal of any
retailer is to track consumers to the
brand it's to offer competitive prices
it's offer convenient locations
uh we feel that we've done all of that
it's to benefit our business by
consumers having a longer shopping
experience in our stores
which leads to higher basket ranks
which leads to Shorter checkout lines
which leads to a positive experience and
we didn't answer any questions that you
may have
thank you thank you
a quick question
um I believe you mentioned here that a
part-time employee now is around 12 is
it 1283 12 you know around that range
where does it two-part question where
does it need to be in order where you'll
be confident that you can attract
employees and number two do you have uh
even a a rough estimate on for every
full-time employee that you have in the
liquor store is actually selling how
much sales go up absolutely
uh we feel that it needs to be
what a full-time employee brings in
two sales is around around a million
dollars annually per employee
uh and that's historically we've tracked
that data for years and that's it's
varied between 750
000 and a million two
so we're pretty comfortable with the
Million number
per full-time employee
I have two questions
um
first that number's about
a couple of orders of magnitude greater
than I had any idea
um it makes a huge difference so we
should
we should pay them double and add 60.
um I imagine there's a curve at some
point
um one is the incentive program and I
read your your um your 800 rules and
I would ask you to describe the
incentive program to me but I don't
think I could understand it any better
than what I read in the rules but where
are you going to pay that out of the
book class
well we were looking for the authority
to be able to fund the incentive through
the profits so transferring money from
the liquor fund to a class line it'll
probably end up be like the class 10 or
like class 17 special pay
okay
okay so it's not in the budget right now
we're just asking now for the authority
to be able to transfer the additional
profits to fund the incentive post so
it's also not in your efficiency correct
and this would be paid functionally out
of gross correct okay
um secondly my question about the
classification language this would have
to be bargained
for the incentive program no nothing I'm
sorry the removing the retail employees
I would imagine yes that it would be
have you had preliminary discussions
with the sea not at this point
we've uh we've had many many discussions
about
about the the bay itself
but not about the the language that
um
two questions one um on the proposal for
the retail is that part-time and
full-time
or just your or part-time workers for
the incentive program no sorry for the
um
correct for a proposal of a new pay
scale
full-time and part-time and I don't know
if you happen to have these numbers but
on average what is your Workforce split
at your retail is it mostly part-time
mostly full-time
is it depend on the store
it depends on the store but right now
we're at we have about uh 600 part-time
employees and about 230 full-time
employees that's for the whole
commission and as I've said uh we're
down about a hundred part-time employees
and uh we're down about 40 full-time
employees
but we've also noticed the termination
rate being using the terminology
termination rate being that people that
have left the commission voluntarily uh
over over the past four years has nearly
doubled so we're losing employees double
the rate we were four years ago simply
because we're not paying employees
enough
and I I can't stress enough and
in business uh
that time that consumers spend in the
store with an educated employee to
basket build shop and spend more is
imperative to what we do
uh Total Wine who operates seven stores
in Massachusetts and who's the largest
Wine and Spirits retailer in the country
operates in 46 states around 260 stores
um we average about six to six full-time
employees in a 20 000 square foot store
they average between 18 and 22 full-time
so we're clearly lacking there and
previously the the initiative was to run
the stores more with part-timers because
of the benefits but now we're seeing
because we can't entice the part-timers
that's why we're asking for the 24
additional retail employees to see if we
can get more people into the stores
working
legislatively that was something that
was done years ago the legislature
wanted the Liquor Commission to run that
way and the Liquor Commission did uh
you know different times
require different attitudes toward
business
do you find your your uh terminations I
know I know that's the wrong term
um for the public but people leaving
employment are disproportionately
part-time
they are
and so you have a better success with
full-time we certainly do
and what we're seeing now sort of crew
of all of us I think it is what we're
seeing now is a lot of employees being
hired into those full-time positions are
from outside State service so we see a a
quite a few people from other retail
outlets and other retail structures
coming to work for the Commission in
those full-time positions because
obviously the pay is is is equal to but
it's the benefits and that's that's what
we're seeing and and that's something in
my 13 years with the commission this is
really the the last 365 days we've
noticed it
I sort of get that I'm here because of
the benefits too
um my last point would be just a on page
five a terminology thought
which is that something you label as
indirect costs to admin services and I
just I want to point out to everybody
listening
um it's misnamed it is indirect costs
and are deposited into the general fund
it is true that we are an agent of the
state in collecting uh indirect costs
but they do not go to us they do not
affect our budget we have no stake in
them they affected nobody's pay in my
operation
so noted thank you
very good thank you very much very much
now I'd like to invite Employment
good morning for the record George
capatus Commissioner of Employment
Security
good morning Richard lavers Deputy
Commissioner good morning good morning
good morning Jill Revels business
administrator good morning
good morning
so to start off with the Department
receives no General funds and the
majority of our non-matching federal
funds come from usdol the budgets based
on the knowledge and continuation of
core Services which is Employment
Services unemployment insurance and the
labor market information
Department also receives 0.2 percent
diversion of State UI taxes for admin
support shortfalls and from which six
million annually is deposit into the job
training fund without this point two
percent we would be only able we would
only be able to maintain six of our 12
local offices uh the variety of services
we have is for claimants job Seekers and
employers personnel and budget costs
represent the largest portion of our
budget which is 58 percent
when unemployment claims increase we
receive additional funds based on
workloads in excess of the base budget
the growing economy and low unemployment
rate results in decreased funding
on February 2020 just prior to the start
of the pandemic the total staff was 264.
235 full-time and 29 part-time total
full-time staff now it's 280 with seven
being recruited for the highest point of
Staffing during the pandemic was 355 in
April of 2020. at that point we also had
94 extra full-time positions that will
work by existing staff in overtime hours
uh
2020-21 the department paid over two
billion dollars in federal and state UI
benefits to over 175 000 people which
was more money and more people paid in
the past than in the past decade
uh doit represents 11 of New Hampshire
employment security Sports 25 full-time
doit staff and 17 are embedded in in
Employment Security we rely heavily on
technology to administer our programs
and why we were able to get through the
pandemic with lower staff totals with
our dedicated knowledgeable staff
despite much higher claims than during
the Great Recession
12 software equipment and equipment
related maintenance the job training
fund is six million dollars which
represents eleven percent of our overall
budget the remaining eight percent
General operating expenses uh postage
utility supplies three percent
designated for training and subsistence
payments to eligible participants under
the dislocated worker program
uh 14 million nine hundred sixty four
thousand five hundred forty five dollars
is our budget for a fiscal to 2024 and
15 million 269 329 for 2025 in the
category of permanent classified and
unclassified positions 286 classified
with 15 unfunded this biennium and seven
unclassified also 36 full-time temp
positions for 2024 2025 in order to
assist with elevated workloads
the work invest program is available for
businesses that pay quarterly taxes this
allows businesses an opportunity to
upgrade the skills of their employees
and it's a one-on-one cash match work
now New Hampshire's intensive case
management to individuals receiving
Medicaid Medicaid expansion snap or TANF
a New Hampshire employment security will
work with those to connect job ready to
job opportunities and those that aren't
ready would provide support to them to
get them job ready as soon as possible
the Work Ready New Hampshire is a
three-week and intensive uh program
through the Community College it covers
soft skills including effective
communication team building problem
solving decision making and adequate
levels of reading and math
since late 2019 over 3.6 million which
is a total of
221 work invest contracts we've done
with businesses the work now processed
over 2 300 payments totaling 3.5
million and 2 million for work running
on the unemployment trust fund hovers
around 360 million since October 31st
2022 which is over 60 million higher
than the prior the pandemic 23 states
were required to borrow
555 billion from the U.S treasury as of
11 8 22. seven states still have
outstanding balances of 27 billion
dollars the trust fund is higher due to
the growth from historically low claim
volume
employer-based growth and infusions from
the federal pandemic Aid totaling 109
million dollars
employers already receiving or die are
already receiving reductions in the
forecast is for those reductions to last
into the first quarter of 2023 saving
employers 28 million dollars
uh job fairs we've done 57 job fields
this year attracting over 7 000 people
job Seekers and we continue to do five
every month throughout the different
regions of the state
uh we look forward to the next biennium
and continuing to provide essential
services to the citizens of the state as
well as the businesses of the State of
New Hampshire
yeah thank you very much uh person I
want to congratulate you for shuffling
this day through the covid pandemic uh
having the state's unemployment rate in
in March of 2020 go from roughly two
percent up to 16 percent
uh certainly was a jolt and it's been
obviously uh volatile over the last few
years but uh in the governor's opening
remarks he mentioned about the certainly
the the possibility not probability of
an oncoming recession
how well it might seem like if our
employment now goes from 2.2 percent up
to six percent you're probably very uh
capable of being able to handle
something like that but you just talk
about your uh what position you're in to
be able to handle a either a moderate
recession or a deep recession that might
uh thank you for the question so
um some very important Lessons Learned
uh during the pandemic
um and our ability to to Pivot very
quickly not only on an increase in
volume like we experienced seemingly
overnight but also in how we deliver
those Services which I think is even
more important
um so so our staff demonstrated great
skill
um and willingness to take on additional
tasks
um in additional hours during the
pandemic but one of a few of the things
that we
um have pivoted and how we deliver
services that would be very important
regardless of what we encounter next in
terms of what fuels any
um economic downturn that we may
experience in an increase in
unemployment claim volume but now we are
are much more agile in being able to
deliver our services virtually which is
very important um allowing people more
flexibility in their desire whether to
come into a local office to seek
services I also were able to do our
one-on-one services our Workshop
Services those are all able to be
delivered uh virtually
um really um at the turn of the switch
um with with our system
um and we have the ability to
um take on uh more questions over our
hotline and the ability to transition
that service from something that right
now is very localized so that if you
were in the Manchester area or you're
calling in you're going to get an
individual that's sitting in the
Manchester office
um what we would what we did during the
pandemic was all of those calls coming
in they go to the the the
agent that is available regardless of
where they sit in the state so we made
some adjustments
um obviously hopefully we continue to
hope that we do not experience any sort
of downturn but knowing that things are
cyclical we prepare for that we do have
a temporary a full-time positions for
which we would feel as needed the
dollars to support those would be an
additional above base Federal funding if
we need those positions but again I
think we learned a lot of important
lessons during the pandemic on how we
can pivot quickly and how we can rely
very heavily upon both our our system
and the technology that we have and the
the enhancements that we've made to that
system but what our staff of our staff
questions
you have a small amount of money well
not that small but
um overall uh transferred from other
agencies
what's the source of most of that
what are you billing people for so to
speak um so the U.S Department of Labor
requires we have Partners within our
One-Stop centers throughout the state
and so they share in the cost of the
operation of those centers
so that would be the revenue received
from those other partner agencies for
residing in our offices for their
presence no I didn't realize there were
that many of them
I guess there are
that many of what Joe that many offices
you mean well no that many I I thought
any other questions
okay great thank you very much for your
I'm going to take a uh three minute
break and then we'll be back with the
Department of Agriculture for their
testimony
foreign
Department of Agriculture the
is
super Protection Agency
other functions
there are six divisions in addition to
services
forms the animals industry and it's
largely responsible responsible in fact
pneumonic diseases and that's right
the division of pesticides is charged
with regulating the pesticides that are
allowed to be used in this state and
allowing licensing those who are
able to
apply those pesticides and there are
thousands of people who are licensed
with thousands of products that are
licensed by that
division
regulatory Services is protecting
consumers through their animals or for
their animals rather that be domestic or
livestock to make sure that the feed
that is being sold and used in this
state is again only in containing
ingredients that are approved by the
legislature for sale in the in the state
and also lime and fertilizer and we do
testing we've just started the testing
of the fertilizers again which is
something that people have wanted but we
have been understaffed in that area
weights and measures protects people
um from those who might not want to
deliver the exact amount of product that
they claim to whether that be cord would
beer propane oil anything that is sold
in this state by weights or measures is
regulated by that that division we
recently just had a very large
settlement with a Oil Dealer whose
trucks were not delivering that which
they were supposed to and in that case
rather than heavily find that company we
chose to pursue a settlement that'll
that required them to provide
reimbursements to their customers who
were serviced by those trucks plant
industry which is located over it at
Hazen Drive
um regulates all of the plant dealers in
the state and is primarily charged with
making sure that the plants coming into
this this state sold in the state are
not
um infested with invasive species uh and
so that of course protects people
who are planting gardens or having any
anything that they're growing so that we
don't have
any worse
problems with invasives in this state
than than we already do but that is in
some cases unfortunately a losing battle
when the within the commissioner's
office
um
as myself Michelle Tebow who is the
administrative assistant and an
accountant
so the commissioner's office is three
people although we did take
um
from the Department of Health and Human
Services a number of years ago the food
safety modernization act into the office
and that is directly under the
commissioner
so I I am responsible for that that
program
um
we have 42 authorized positions at the
current time one of those is a fully
Federal refunded position uh in plant
plant industry there are four four
part-time positions one of which is the
executive director of the state
Conservation Commission which just began
a couple of years ago after having no
staff there
or contractor for
several years
in this year's budget request
we are requesting a an assistant
commissioner
in the in the office
um and I that has been a priority of
mine
since I became commissioner soon
realizing that um
was really impossible to do everything
that was required of the commissioner
without an assistant but covet got in
the way and other things became a higher
priority
uh and so we are making that request
once again I do have a deputy but he's
the state veterinarian who is busier
than I am and really only acts it in my
absence which is
uh very infrequent
much to my wife's children but um
we have also asked that the state
executive director of State Conservation
Commission
be upgraded to a full-time position
State Conservation Commission is a
something that exists in all 50 states
it's this program that's about 75 years
old the state is broken by County into
districts that have supervisors that
manage it there has been a real lack of
coordination for probably 10 or 12 years
which does not allow us to efficiently
use the resources that exist within the
10 counties because there's nobody there
even knowing what's going on we have
found that having someone there even
part-time has been a great asset to the
state and really beginning to make
once again the system much more
beneficial and of course the state
conservation deals with Farmland what
we're really pushing these days is no
till
soil erosion is mitigated by that it
also sequesters carbon into the soil
which is helping with with climate you
know State like New Hampshire we can't
do much but we need to do what we can so
this is a very important position for us
to go from part-time to full-time
obviously to keep somebody in that
position requires a full-time job and
requires benefits and we've got a a
great individual there who is supported
by everyone within the system last year
the legislature created an invasive
species
position but didn't fund it
and they put money into that so that we
can start to really do a better job of
coordinating with the invasive species
you see not weed probably everywhere you
see the um which is the Japanese knot
yeah I'm always losing what it is that
wraps it throughout itself around the
trees everywhere something very and for
some reason it's it's escaped my mind
again we're losing the state to that if
you've ever been down near Hartford you
might think you're in a jungle because
they've lost that battle where we
haven't lost it yet but if we don't
really start to put some serious effort
into that and coordinate with Dot and
with the towns and give them the support
on how to manage these things we will
solely soon be looking like like other
states in that area but I always use
Hartford as as the example of how bad it
can get and literally
um
trees can be killed with
with these things so we're hopeful that
your Governor is supportive of of that
um so those are really the two new
positions that we are requesting but one
was the legislature put it into the law
but didn't fund it
um
and one upgrade
in the position for the Department
um
if you if you look on the first sheet
of our
budget hearing you'll see that while we
have
um
we really do not require General funding
in in total but of course we do but we'd
return more every year to the to the
general fund so we are not a drag on the
general fund we are a net positive to
the general fund each year uh 2021
obviously was our low Point as we're
moving forward we are expecting that in
in this year we'll return over
um
670 000 to the general fund from the
revenues that we get in
in this proposed budget for 24.25
in total nearly 1.5 million for the
two-year period you will see that our
our budget numbers have increased
relatively substantially a lot of that
is due to the fact that we have two
revolving funds within the department
and during the pandemic
my choice was to draw those funds down
rather than lay off people because of
the important work that we have to do
and so some of that is a reflection of
the fact that at the time I said this
was not sustainable that if we continue
to draw down we would we would empty
those funds and not be able to do what
we're doing we didn't purchase uh
vehicles our Fleet is about 24 vehicles
and we did not buy vehicles during that
time we need to get back on our
replacement schedule
um
but again you know while the numbers
the reality is that we will still return
money to the to the general fund when
all is said and done and
from there I I could ramble on for
another half an hour but uh I'd be glad
to answer any questions
that you have or if I can't turn them
over to Michelle and see if she can do
better than I can
thank you thank you for the presentation
um could you just talk you have a you
have a a relatively small number of
employees uh other agencies have
a fairly significant vacancy rates you
know averaging around 20 percent
what's yours and have you found it uh
difficult to hire employees for your
agency and you could just expand on that
a little bit
so when I became commissioner we had a
fairly High vacancy rate and there was
no attempt to fill those
um I eventually discovered what the
reasoning was on that but we've since
since corrected that it was an
overestimation of revenues in an order
to make everything work we left
positions vacant
right now I have four vacancies one is a
new position which we just interviewed
you for that's in fisma which is a
hundred percent federally funded that
whole program
um is funded by feds and will end if
they stop funding it there was a
full-time position there when we took it
over from HHS but none of us could
really figure out why and it's a program
that ratchets up based on or ratchets
down in this case you start with Farms
that have very high income and then it
goes down each year to cover more and
more Farms we've gotten to the point
where we need to uh to fill that so they
interviewed on Friday for that position
and do have a candidate I think we had
three qualified for that one and other
than that what we have is a few people
who have retired or left for other
opportunities I get
for a very brief period of time I do get
to 100 percent
and in this in this case the reason
there's actually still four is that two
people within the department moved up
which is a you know from my opinion a
great thing all of those positions are
advertised and we have found that we
have had no no trouble whatsoever
filling our positions probably with one
exception a while back but we've been
doing very well and uh expect to be back
up at 100 percent uh within the month
and then we'll see if anybody else
John just because your neighbors I'm
going to say hi hi Michelle
hi
um and that's about it so
um plant industry is housed at HHS over
with public health yes
um it's a dumb question but why
well I never asked I I don't know
because that's what my lab is I guess
they have a lab over there they have
they have an incredible collection of
insects over there and probably I'll
take your word for that probably because
there wasn't room over here when they
moved the department is has moved a
number of a number of times over the
years and I think they've been I was
there for a long time but of all the
questions I've thought to ask that's not
morning
um this is on your prioritized needs
um looks like there's about a million
give or take in prioritized needs it's
100 generally funded
um you mentioned uh you know a few
positions what's the other maybe is
there a big chunk that's somewhere else
or is it just a lot of little things
that make that up Michelle a lot of our
uh prioritize beans are based on like uh
transfers to oit transverse General
services
um
and instead of
dividing that fund out of all the
general funds we've just all lumped it
into the commissioner's budget instead
of breaking it out
and I should have touched on on it this
year for the first time we do have a
embedded I.T person which is very
helpful my joke has been that before I
leave as commissioner I'd like to to get
us into the 1990s with our technology of
course given what's going on right now I
might not
see that goal to fruition we are we do
have one that is going out to bit
shortly on the animal
database which is very important
unfortunately we had a huge setback in
weights and measures a contract was
awarded prior to my becoming
commissioner and just a couple of months
ago we all came to the realization that
they would not be able to fulfill their
contract so we're still operating on a
system that was developed by a prisoner
of the New Hampshire state prison and we
did find somebody who was able to
maintain that because it was crashing so
we've got to start over again do
anticipate that there will be a bill in
the legislature that will be looking to
fund RIT needs to get the other programs
done we're developing the current one
with the idea that they would be able to
actually build off of the animal
database probably everything except for
to Sherry's point one of your one of
your prioritized needs is a 250 000
in the office of the commissioner
something about state fairs the state oh
the state the state fair program this
this last year
um representative Ladd put forth a uh a
bill to fund
um infrastructure at at our state fairs
and this would be the idea when he had
put it in was going to be that it would
be a yearly appropriation
um and that ended up being a one-time
fund and so we've asked to continue that
uh program some of our state fairs are
in desperate need of of infrastructure
upgrades and are having a difficult time
because of course if we could guarantee
that the weather would be good every
year we wouldn't be looking for this but
sometimes the
weather or pandemics can really do a
number on the fairs they're a critical
part of of who we are as New Hampshire
um and as some of you may know
um the state fair has got a lot more
money than what we're proposing back as
late as 1980 because they were funded
um for premiums primarily but it freed
up a lot of money by um a quarter
percent of the total take at Rockingham
Park
and that was a program that went on from
the 1940s it's pretty much the walking
hand closed
I'm just gonna say that takes a lot
lower than it used to be
um you also have a 350 000 uh grants and
grants Improvement is where I noticed
the
uh prioritize need
and I've not yet discovered which
division it's okay
I wonder if you recall what that is off
it just looked like maybe it was a
program
probably
that the
um
Charlie what page are you on well I I
saw it in the summary if I look at the
first uh the beginning of the document
um
the department roll up
shows 340 500 in additional prioritize
needs both years
for Grants and grants Administration
and then I don't know exactly which
which division it was in because I
it may not be a big deal it might just
be the slump off of other things but
you don't know exactly where in the
summer you're seeing no
fail you know what it's not anything
that we need to figure out today we can
certainly
um yeah no rush
yeah
bottom of page six I just don't know
which division it is and I think I think
that's probably I think it might under
the animal industry oh okay
um
foreign
yeah yeah no rush I just thought I'd ask
no good question and obviously one we
I believe it is that
um
well that probably explains mostly and
then I think it's got to do with the
animal industry if you spot something
and no reason we need to do it today
foreign
I like I see they're on their way
banking Commission
thank you departments all right is on
there
way and invite you to give your
testimony
foreign
good morning uh for the record my name
is Amelia galderi and I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire with me is Michael
jacksonowski he's the director of
operations for the banking Department
thank you for the opportunity to present
our budget the banking Department's
budget proposal today
uh so I provide a handout
um at the top of the handout you'll see
the banking Department's mission
statement
um the banking department is committed
to protecting the Public's interests
through the professional supervision of
the financial services it regulates
um everything in our budget proposal is
in support of that mission so I thought
it was important to start with that
so um the banking department is
organized into two divisions for the
purposes of our budget
one is the Banking and Trust division in
that that division oversees the
activities of 17 State chartered Banks
nine State chartered credit unions and
currently 41 non-depository trust
companies and Family Trust companies
um there's a couple in the hopper right
now so by your end we expect that number
to be perhaps one bigger
um the second division is the consumer
credit division that division oversees
the uh several thousand Consumer Credit
division licensees
um so Mortgage Bankers Brokers small
loan lenders money transmitters
um several of those entities are what
you what are commonly known as fintech
companies so companies that utilize
technology to provide financial services
and is a growing field
um the banking within those two
divisions the banking department has 48
positions which includes three vacant
funded positions as well as three
positions that are actively being
recruited to fill
the banking department is a self-funded
agency
um so
um a hundred percent of our funds are
other funds
um every year we receive an
appropriation and over the course of
that year we collect fees fines and
finally an assessment and those monies
are used to offset the initial
appropriation
uh moving on to our budget proposal
um I've included some like high level
figures from our budget proposal
um the key takeaway for our budget
proposal is that our budget it is
roughly probably a little bit more than
this 80 percent
um salaries and benefits of our staff
plus
um related expenses such as it support
for that staff and training expenses
um if you flip to the back of the
handout
um you'll see that the banking
department has been tasked by the
legislature with regulating a vibrant
but ever growing number of licensed
entities cue back to the fintech
companies I mentioned earlier and
non-depository Trust companies and these
numbers sort of reflect that kind of
exponential growth we've been
experiencing
in past budget Cycles we've been able to
absorb this growth by increasing
efficient efficiencies by for example
leveraging information Technologies and
making good use of existing positions
however the industry growth is now
starting to outpace those strategies and
soon we'll have more exams to do than we
have examiners to do them and you can
see with the trust companies um the
director of trust supervision Nancy
degler not projected those numbers out
so you can get a feel for how that
growth is happening
um for this reason in this budget we've
made a targeted and strategic strategic
request for two new positions in fiscal
year 24 and three new positions in
fiscal year 25
and then outside of the budget we plan
to make use of those three vacant and
funded positions we're going to do a
combination of reclassifications and
re-allocations to make the best and
highest use of those positions to help
us cope with the enormous influx of
licensed and chartered entities
um
so I think all of that hopefully
accomplishes our goal
um which is at the end of my hand out of
providing the banking Department with
adequate experienced and professional
staff
to cope with the extraordinary growth in
the emergency emerging fintech companies
and the exponential increase in the
number of trust companies supervised by
the department and
um
because we're largely staff and that's
most of our budget that's the extent of
my presentation
um and I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have
sure
um
first trusted admission I know extremely
little about cryptocurrency
however I I it appears I do know a lot
more than the people who have been
investing in cryptocurrency over the
last few years
um I was wondering if you could explain
or just how you position to deal with
cryptocurrency especially how it impacts
Banking and banking regulations sure so
um right now with the current news that
we're all hearing about FTX and
um block five Voyager those have been
the names in the news of the um failing
companies those entities are licensed
with us to do a very small component of
their business which is money
transmission so traditionally money
transmission is you think of Western
Union they transfer money fiat currency
back and forth between people
um these companies are licensed by the
banking Department to take in either
people's cash or their crypto and then
transmit
catch to other people if they're doing
business where they're taking in crypto
and transmitting crypto the legislature
accepted that from our jurisdiction
so we really just regulate a small
portion
of what the companies that you're
hearing about in the news do
that said
um there are other ways that entities
under our regulation could potentially
interact with cryptocurrency
um we have trust companies that could
potentially be holding it in custody for
their clients
um and I think that's trying to think if
there's any other ones that I've heard
of I think that's the bulk of what how
we interact with cryptocurrency at the
banking Department and so this
um part of the positions will go to the
consumer credit division which is really
experiencing and having to cope with all
of this cryptocurrency
information that is coming at them in
the news right now even though it is
just
small component of what these bigger
companies do is what we regulate
uh so okay thank you for that uh
Switching gears I know you're
maybe not uniquely qualified but you are
certainly qualified to have a lot of
your employees be able to work off-site
and whether it's work from home or work
in other locations
where there's the space you're in now is
that going to be a continued home and
are you looking given your expense your
plan to have people work from home
please question if I'm wrong on that but
um whether there's been any sort of of
downsizing that position or maybe
changing up your position where you're
located now yeah so we're actively
looking at that issue right now our
lease is up in May so we're currently
kind of discussing with our current
landlord whether our space can be
reconfigured because if you were to walk
into the banking Department right now we
have
um a cube Farm as we call it at the
banking Department of cubicles that used
to be house examiners pre-pandemic but
we've found that they can be completely
in the field doing their examination so
they maybe come into the office
occasionally but certainly not the need
for that cute Farm
um so we're currently engaging with our
landlord to try to reconfigure the space
reduce the space
um however it's taking a bit longer
because of construction finding people
to provide quotes for the construction
is a
problem right now I believe if my
landlord was here to talk to you that's
what he would say so it's taking a
little bit longer than we anticipate but
it is something we're actively looking
at because we have space that's
I'm good
hi
okay very good thank you very much thank
you
good morning I need to hit the button
good morning my name is Kim McKay I'm
the commoner of the New Hampshire
veterans home and today with me I have
Stephanie Kelly our business
administrator
okay I'm gonna get my glasses out
all right
um in this slideshow you'll see today we
have some slides here that talk about
the veterans home and the history of
this
um it has been around since 1890 I think
it predates Charlie
um and we are uh 250 bed long-term care
facility no skilled care all long-term
care we're currently funded by three
Revenue sources the general fund the U.S
Department of Veteran Affairs and the
residents themselves pay room on board
uh today we have a statutory capacity of
250 we are budgeted around 225
um due to the covet situation and
Staffing that we're all experiencing our
current resident snapshot is 124
residents we have seven more admissions
coming uh over the next four weeks and
our average age of a veteran is 84 years
old
we have two 384 full-time staff
to provide services to the residents
in theory we are we have quite a bit of
vacancy rate on the New Hampshire
Veterans Home utilizes the VA Grant
Program enabled under CFR 5141 which
allows us to get partial or full payment
for living reimbursements
the mission statement of the Veterans
Home is to provide the best quality of
life for New Hampshire veterans with
dignity honor and respect and I would
say I'm pretty new to the facility I
came in January and the one thing you
will feel as the staff take this
position and this mission statement
with great pride and provide the best
services for the residents
I thought it was important to just point
out a couple of our challenges and our
achievements
um and because they they affect our
budget so much so the first one is uh
our current challenge of Recruitment and
Retention of staff and it's not just
clinical staff but also our non-clinical
staff
historically in the state system we saw
if a support service position was open
people would take it even if it was part
time to get their foot in the door with
a state position but now we can see
vacancies in our laundry
our food service they can get paid so
much in the community setting so
um we are struggling in those
non-clinical areas as well
uh some of our achievements to try to uh
approach that and and turn that around
is that we launched an internal LNA
licensed nursing assistant program in
our facility uh so they um I'm sorry I
didn't number them I'm pretty I don't
know if everybody's with me
um they we've had three classes uh We've
graduated nine lnas so far we just
started a class uh two weeks ago and
there's seven students in that class so
within this fiscal year we will have 16
new lnas in our in our facility and our
plan is to continue those classes back
to back we were able to work with dop to
enact the LNA trainee position we
created part-time positions so the staff
we can hire staff part-time before the
class takes place and then they can earn
as they learn so they work with us in
the facility help residents do the
things they can within their licensing
restore frictions and then they take the
class which is paid for and if they stay
with us for one year they don't have to
pay that class back
and then they become full-time lnas and
so it's been really rewarding and we've
had some great successes with that so
when we saw that we're working so well
there's something called an m a medical
nursing assistant program where lnas
with certain criteria through the Board
of Nursing they actually can take
another Pro another class and they can
pass medications that don't require
assessments so we're seeing big needs in
our nursing department and having M A's
that can pass traditional meds
medications is really helpful so we have
created a program and that has been
forwarded to the New Hampshire Board of
Nursing and they're going to be
reviewing that in December our hope is
to create a career path so not only will
we be able to recruit people to become
lnas join the nursing field but they can
also see a career path within our
facility
we reclassed a vacant position to focus
on recruitment that position starts on
the 2nd of December we've been improving
onboarding and retention with more
support and mentorship so if you're new
to the facility what does that mean who
do you go to if you need help because
it's not just getting them to the front
door and hire them but it's keeping
people if we invest that time we want to
keep them there
we're also improving Communications I
was surprised when I came to the
facility that not everybody had email
um and so I know there's a cost with
that but communication is so important
in a healthcare facility things happen
daily that could change the way we act
so we could have one person test
positive and we may treat that unit
differently and we were having a hard
time getting that communication out to
staff in a quick
um and a quick process so we've now have
everybody has email
um and including that part of the
communication and I think this employee
satisfaction is that they know what's
happening in their facility they have
some ownership to that so I meet with
staff on all shifts on a quarterly basis
so we're trying to do some of those
kinds of communication building we
recognize outstanding employees with
hero awards that they their co-workers
or their peers
um you know nominate them so we're
trying that piece we that challenge also
comes our census so low staffed low
census and that is not what we want to
see we have a very significant wait list
we have right now about 20 veterans in
the community that are ready to come in
the moment we have a bed and we have
about 46 applications that are being
processed so we know we could fill our
beds we just physically cannot do that
with our staffing the way it is so one
of our challenges is the Staffing we've
gone up about 10 since I got there I
basically met with all the staff and
said how many can we have here to
provide the quality of care that they
expect so our goal is 131 with our
staffing schedules like they are right
now so how do we meet those needs so we
Consolidated partial units we had some
units that weren't full so we we
combined them we expanded light duty
return to work programs so we had
instead of them just being out of work
what else can they do here and maybe
they are in L A but maybe they could do
some office work because we have uh
openings or they can fold laundry so
we're trying to bring people back sooner
we have increased the number of our
volunteer opportunities
the Veterans Home has so many supporters
in the community from veterans service
organizations to individuals we have
approximately a hundred active
volunteers and and that's a lot a lot of
support that we can feel and we continue
to mandate four-hour shifts every pay
period for nursing all nursing including
nursing that our office so our nurse
managers our assistant nurse managers
just to cover those shifts
on our vacancy snapshot our overall
vacancy rate is 35 for our facility we
realize the biggest
um vacancy is actually our nurses and we
Define that as nurse practitioner RN or
LPN licensed practical nurse or
registered nurse we're about 48 without
vacancy rate and for the lnas we're a
little less with 43. we envision that
that will keep getting smaller as we
have more and more classes but it is
very difficult to recruit nurses and
have nurses come join our team right now
what we're seeing is that we're seeing
other nurses come from other state
organizations and that that just harms
others so we're hoping that we'll see
more uh one of the things I would like
to do is just look at if there is a
bridging program that we can do for
nurses nursing assistants to help
support them to become LPNs and LPN CPM
sources and maybe we can sponsor some of
those educational costs but it's not in
the budget we stayed on on task for the
budget
um we have as I mentioned three revenue
streams and so general fund is the
largest amount of forty percent seven
percent
um and then the VA is a per diem rate
and there's two different ways we get
paid
um a basic per diem rate is 121 dollars
per day if the veteran has 70 percent or
more of a disability that is related to
um their service we actually get uh
485.77 a day we have currently 11 of
those residents on the higher rate the
other piece of that is the residents
themselves we have room and board costs
if they have over thirty thousand
dollars worth of assets they pay the
full room and board until they hit that
thirty thousand dollar less threshold if
they have below 30 000 we do a formula
based on their total monthly income
about it
strategic priorities grow this census
with the employee support our goal is to
be at 225 veterans
um with that finding that fine balance
of providing the service but also the
quality we still need to make sure we
provide the quality because to get those
per diem rates we must meet the VA
survey requirements they come out every
April and they look at us and do a full
survey of this Services we're providing
the physical campus that type of thing
um we are looking at some health uh life
safety initiatives
um for uh I think some people in this
room are at our capital budget proposal
we do have some water that runs right
through our basement uh area so we do
have some projects that we're hoping to
address
um and we also are looking at enhancing
our security readers we have security
cards right now on most of our doors but
not all Outdoors all of the exits so we
like to try to improve in that
in this budget coming we have asked for
to replace aging Vans we have some vans
that are quite old and
um I think they've reached their end as
far as welding them together
um so we're hoping to see that go
through we also are looking at
installing some mechanical lifts into
our ceilings so we can improve the
ability to move people safely and lower
the risk of having injuries to our staff
and then we are looking to increase our
contracted Services we need to provide
more
in-house services around Physical
Therapy around a laboratory and then we
also we do have a temporary staffing
contract that was approved from the
governor Council and the fiscal
committee however the agency has not
been able to provide us with one not one
person so we are going to need to look
at expanding that so we can go for a
nursing contract we really feel the
burden of the lack of nurses during
weekends holidays if we have coveted in
that facility and people are sick so we
need to have some kind of backup plan
with the contracts and then the it
infrastructure upgrades like I said we
um need to be able to communicate with
staff we need to be able to communicate
with our residents and the residents
communicate with their families when we
have a coveted outbreak it makes the
facility uh close down a little bit and
so the families still need access and
right now in most of our building you
cannot get Wi-Fi and based on the
building structure
uh then there's just a snapshot of our
budget of what we're asking for
um over the next two years executive
summary we did uh just we stayed within
the governor's parameters we did a three
percent increase over the last budget uh
we level funded for 25. again as I spoke
about we asked for additional funding
for Consultation Services we also know
that in the next the next year our
medical service contract is going to be
up and so we have a very low medical
service contract
um and so the concern is will that stay
that way because we all know how hard it
is to find staff
um and I talked about investing in
clinical and custodial equipment
we have a high tradition of providing
care our high level of quality of care
our residents expected our families
expected and our staff expectant and so
with the continuing support of the
governor and this committee we hope to
thank you very much thank you you
mentioned the 35 percent vacancy rate
and especially highlighted by the
nursing yes has the the state's
incentive program for nursing
helped at all in that in bringing in
nurses in the you know the last few
months and and what does that look like
going forward yes I believe so I I think
that we are cautious about how we
presented to any new employee that's
coming from the outside to let them know
that this is a 15 enhancement
um that for us expires March 2024 and
then the additional 15 until June 30.
but we have had we just hired a staff
development nurse from the community so
we are seeing some movement and again we
are we've also seen some movement from
other agencies which I feel bad about
but at the same time we need them so um
so I think the enhancements are
definitely helping
um helping with the lnas for sure people
are wanting to join our team because it
is equivalent to what they're making in
the community nursing a little slower
and I just think that's because the
community there's less nurses is this a
matter of with nursing is this a matter
of for many state agencies just a matter
of payment they will come yes you know
but with nursing it's different I mean
nursing the nursing nursing shortage
isn't something unique to New Hampshire
or New England or Regional it's
Nationwide yes uh is this more of a
long-term problem in actually training
nurses because obviously it's not a
quick fix you can't get someone in here
and have them be a nurse two months from
now right I think part of it is we have
to find ways to speak to them so the
quality of life
um and so someone who's a licensed
practical nurse may be at our facility
and has thought about becoming an RN but
doesn't have the monies or how am I
going to leave my job to do that it
takes a year to make that happen it's
twenty three thousand dollars for them
to become an RN I feel like that's an
excellent investment if we can ask for
them to sign a contract with it stays
for two years so I think there are ways
that we can make it even more attractive
to come to the veterans home but I think
the other comments of all the other
facilities in this across the country
are experiencing the same thing and I
don't know if that means we need more
nursing schools I don't know how we
speak to that
okay thank you
in here you mentioned that 24
basically private pay people paying out
of their own pocket for their revenue is
that mostly through insurance or are
they just writing a check from their
bank accounts it comes from their
pensions usually their retirement's a
portion of their pensions so they keep a
10 percent I'm gonna look at Stephanie
if I start to misspeak they keep 10
percent
um and 100 which I'm not sure one
hundred dollars and then 10 and um again
we're not we're not tacking on the
spouse at home's income this is just
their income that they pay okay and
that's two housekeeping items uh one you
had a position where we have talked
about and I might understand is you
withdrawn that position yes sir okay uh
if you want to talk about that yes um so
we have a combination of a CFO and a COO
position at the veterans home it's very
unique
um and uh unfortunately our person who's
doing that has well fortunately and
unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately for me but for the country
great
um he has been deployed and so that has
left
um a bit of a learning curve for me to
cover that CFO uh position so I was
going to be requesting a full-time CFO
position from the
um for the budget however we're going to
move towards the 80 ask for a temporary
position while he is not in service and
then
um consider he is expected to be back in
the next year so I think the 18 will
bring us through that okay great and
again just housekeeping uh in in the
capital budget you're requesting money
for it basically expanding the sprinkler
system yes uh that was met I believe
through Opera funding yeah so you no
longer have that it's not it yes not
needed um it was yes absolutely okay
thank you very much that answers my
questions
he asked most of mine he did yeah you
have nothing uh the only thing I want to
say is uh I've been to the veterans home
only twice and each time was a very
moving experience and it's uh obvious
from the people who work there and uh in
the time I spent there what a dedicated
staff you have and how dedicated they
are to their mission
I absolutely agree incredibly dedicated
you can feel it when you come in and the
community support as well and we're
we're very lucky our veterans are
um they deserve it they definitely
deserve it I feel that way when I come
into administrative Services too but
it's slightly different they're like oh
questions
thank you very much all right thank you
all right like to invite peace
Development Authority up for their
testimony
foreign thank you Paul Breen executive
director of Peace Development Authority
good morning and director Marconi
division of ports and harbors
and to my right is Grant Nichols
assistant director of ports and harbors
uh first and foremost peace Development
Authority does not have an impact on the
general fund we do have administrative
oversight of the division of ports and
harbors and I'll ask Mr Marconi to
well thank you and and almost good
afternoon
um
the New Hampshire Port Authority was
established by the statute in 1957 and
it was a standalone state agency until
2001 when the legislature emerged as
administratively with the peace
Development Authority
at that time the statute said that any
existing classified employees such shall
remain so at the time of that
administrator
change there was there were six
classified positions through attrition
one was replaced with a non-classified
PDA position
we've just recently replaced another one
so we're the books say we have five but
we're actually down to down to four
positions
um as Paul said
um even though it shows up in the budget
because they are classified positions we
reimburse 100 of the salaries and
benefits back to the state uh through
revenues that we generate from our
businesses at the port
um so uh as of right now we have eight
full-time non-classified positions and
we only have
um the five that are on the books but we
have only filled
um actually I I misspoke we have we have
four five positions one of them was
filled with a non-classified we do have
an empty position and we're interviewing
and that is a deputy chief Harbor Master
uh and under the statute the deputy
chief Harbor Master has to be certified
by cstc as a police officer so that
position will remain a classified
position
so uh our statutory charge is to promote
the movement of freight throughout ports
and harbors and provide the development
of boating facilities for the boat
travel that moves up and down the
coaster in our tidal waterways
and we've been pretty successful for the
last 20 years supporting ourselves
um yeah you're sort of my model budget
because there are no no General funds
and your budget actually looks like it
decreased by about a hundred thousand
dollars from 23 to 24 you have no
additional prioritized needs
that's as clean as it gets well I I will
say this
um with all due respect
when they first merged us with peas I
didn't know anything about them I only
knew what I read in the newspapers it
wasn't until I got there and I got
involved in the administration as a
senior staff member that I really found
out what a pretty good organization they
are and what they did is they gave us
resources we didn't have before
um you know we've got a finance director
that handles all of our bill paying and
invoicing we've got uh you know
Personnel people we've got
um
information RIT people and most
important of all we've got a
problem-solving team we meet regularly
the senior staff members and we throw it
on the table and somewhere in the mix
there are some good ideas that come out
on how we solve problems and I I give
credit to the peas organization and and
the people in the legislature that set
it up and it's certainly been an
advantage to us to operate as a business
served serve the public and generate the
any questions
I desperately want to ask you know a
question and I can't think of one to ask
so I know we're working with you on the
classified issue and and the final
results that may not be
completely happy for everybody but we're
working out what we're looking for is
the answer just want to congratulate you
on being the second smartest person in
your household
foreign
thank you sir thank you very much thank
you all right thank you uh hearing will
that's your assigned chair you have to
okay it's 1 15 we're going to reconvene
the operational budget hearing
Governor's budget hearing and uh just
for uh housekeeping I know there's noise
going on here we have asked them to uh
maybe move to a different task for the
afternoon so we can get through this if
not just you know it's debatable whether
or not to be able to but uh we are
listening above and beyond so if you can
get through it we can certainly listen
beyond that because we're now used to it
having spent the morning doing so
uh and at this point I'd like to invite
the department of safety to come up and
good afternoon uh Robert Quinn
commissioner of the Department of Safety
and with me today is Steve Lavoy the
director of administration today we will
speak to the Department of safeties FY
2425 agency budget request the mission
of the Department of Safety is to
continually enhance the safety security
and quality of life in New Hampshire
throughout professional collaborative
and Innovative service to all
the department has seven divisions each
with a unique Public Safety Mission and
unique sources of funding demands for
Public Safety Services continue to grow
in all areas as do demands in our
employees the department has struggled
over the last several years with
increased vacancies and our dedicated
employees have worked tirelessly at all
levels of the organization to maintain
the highest level of service possible
with fuel resources while we have been
successful in meeting the public safety
mission to date continuing to do so at
existing Staffing levels is not
sustainable vacancies must be funded and
filled this budget funds existing Public
Safety Services required to maintain
safety in New Hampshire through FY 24
and 25. however there are several
critical vacant positions that are
currently in prioritized needs due to
their funding constraints applied at
this phase of the budget
salaries and benefits increases combined
with increased equipment replacement
costs and increased Reliance on it
infrastructures and systems have
increased the overall cost of doing
business
prioritize needs of 16.1 million in FY
24 and 13.8 million in fy25 are critical
to maintaining Public Safety as a
department works to meet increased
demands for service services at all
levels uh prioritize needs include
63 State Police sworn positions that
were previously funded in FY 22 and 23.
18 civilian positions across the
department that were previously funded
in FY 2223 nine new positions required
to meet demands for services and lastly
48 replacement State Police cruises
throughout the presentation we will
discuss how these prioritized needs will
impact Public Safety Services across New
Hampshire funding all vacant positions
is a priority for the department and we
request that consideration be given to
do so if resources are available
director Steve Lavoy will now spend some
time discussing the important Public
Safety mission of each of our seven
divisions and provide a summary of
changes prioritized needs and related
impacts in the service delivery we're
happy to take any questions that may
have throughout the presentation thank
you Steve
thank you commissioner oh good afternoon
everyone so we'll dive into the
presentation here starting on page two
which provides an organizational summary
of the department as a whole as the
commissioner mentioned there are seven
divisions within the department of
safety each is funded uniquely with
various funding sources and so it really
makes sense for us to present our budget
request at a divisional level and that's
what we're going to do today
page three before we get into the
division level was the overall summary
request for the Department as a whole so
for FY 24 of the Department of Safety is
requesting a total of 240 million
dollars and in 25
240.7 million dollars to fund Public
Safety Services across the state
um those funds support
1151 full-time classified positions and
13 unclassified Physicians however there
are 107 classified positions that are
currently within prioritized needs and
not included in those amounts
what's also presented here is the fact
that we're very people-driven
organization 55 of our costs are
associated with salaries and benefits
with the remaining factoring in with
operating costs many of those operating
costs are funds and grants that are
distributed to locals and other state
agencies
our 24 budget increased by 7.2 million
dollars due to Inc General increase in
the cost of doing business operating
cost increases including replacement
equipment supplies and contracts there's
also an increase in federal fund
expenditures uh that's associated
primarily With Disaster grant funding a
lot of that being related to the covet
disaster that occurred over the last
several years and those are funds that
will be distributed to State and local
agencies
5.8 million in the increase is due to a
change in administrative budgeting
practice which results in in a double
budgeting because of the dedicated funds
that are used to support those areas and
three million dollars an increase is due
to increased doit related costs and
those are attributed to Major I.T
systems at DMV and at State Police that
had significant cost increases over the
last year
as the commissioner mentioned we have
several positions in prioritized need
with a total of 16.1 million in uh 24
and 13.8 million in 25.
so we turn to page four we'll move on to
the office of the commissioner
the office of the commissioner in
addition to overseeing the entire
department and all seven divisions also
directly oversees the office of Highway
Safety the department of safety's legal
unit and the Bro of hearings
page five shows the office of the
commissioner's budget request for fy24
the office of the commissioner is
requesting 20.0 million dollars and for
22 20.2 million dollars
32 percent of those funds support salary
and benefits for the positions within
the office of the commissioner which are
45 classified and three unclassified
Physicians there are no unfunded
positions within this unit
the office of the commissioner as I
mentioned includes the Bureau of
hearings which conducts uh over 14 000
hearings every year and also the office
of Highway Safety which in FY 22 awarded
over 886 thousand dollars to 81 local
police departments for enforcement
activities
uh the budget is relatively flat there's
a little bit of a decrease from prior
year amounts and that's due primarily to
moving some Debt Service expenditures
that were being paid for out of the
office of the commissioner to a separate
accounting unit within special expenses
to ensure that the funding is
appropriate in those areas and there are
a few prioritized needs small amounts
but 199 000 and 24 and 132 025 which are
to fund additional costs for maintenance
conducted by the department of
administrative services for our 33 Hazen
Drive facilities then also twelve
thousand dollars to fund additional
retiree Health estimated payments and
those were prioritized by the department
page six uh is the division of
administration's organizational chart
in the division of administration
provides internal Support Services to
all the divisions within the department
of safety and is comprised of six
bureaus financial management Human
Resources asset and Resource Management
road toll grants management and
Facilities Management
page seven shows the division of
administration's budget request of 11.2
million dollars for FY 24 and 11.5
million dollars for fy25
66 percent of those funds support salary
and benefits for the employees within
that within this division those are 85
classified and two unclassified
employees there are three unfunded
full-time positions that are in
prioritized need one of those is a new
position and two of those are existing
vacant unfunded positions
and some highlights for the division in
22 the road till Bureau collected 181
million dollars in Road till revenues to
support the highway fund and Pros the
mail unit process 1.8 million pieces of
incoming mail and 1.3 million pieces of
outgoing mail and the plate room
distributed 567
000 license plates and 1.8 million plate
decals to municipalities and DMV
substations across the state
there's a slight decrease in overall
budget from FY 23 and that's due to a
reallocation of doit expenses to other
divisions within the department
another change in the division of
administration is the transfer of three
existing facilities positions which were
funded in other divisions moving them
into the facilities management Bureau to
support the department as a whole
on page 8 there's some details of the
prioritized needs within the division of
administration including the two
existing vacant Road till auditor two
positions just noting that audits are an
important way to ensure voluntary
compliance with the road toll which is
also known as the state's gas tax and
that not filling all auditor positions
increases the risk of incomplete
reporting and potentially leads to
declines in Highway fund Revenue
collections
the new position being requested by this
division is a new human resources
coordinator 2 position the department of
safety has employees represented by five
different collective bargaining units
and they include sworn civilian
employees as well as 24 7 operations
it's it's a heavy lift there's over 1600
employees in total and our HR operations
need additional support to ensure that
we can provide services to all employees
finally there's 1.2 million dollars in
doit expenditures for additional
Staffing hardware and software that are
in prioritized needs these are costs
that the division the department as a
whole absolutely needs including
Staffing Hardware replacement and
software licensing these costs are in
the division of administration but
support the department of safety as a
whole
on page nine we move on to the Division
of Motor Vehicles
whose mission is to enhance Public
Safety on the roadways of New Hampshire
by ensuring that all drivers vehicles
and service providers are properly
credentialed
the division is comprised of six bureaus
driver licensing financial
responsibility which is driving history
records are recorded Bureau of
operations Bureau of registration Bureau
of title and then also the
administration section
page 10 shows the Division of Motor
Vehicles 24-25 budget request the
division is requesting 31.7 million
dollars in 24 and 32.5 million dollars
in 25.
54 of those funds are salary and
benefits supporting 208 full-time
classified positions and two
unclassified Physicians there are an
additional eight classified Physicians
that are currently unfunded and sitting
in prioritized needs
in FY 22 the DMV issued 405 167 motor
vehicle titles performs 36 219 skills
and road tests and produced 381 497
driver licenses and ID cards
the increase from 23 to 24 is due in
large part to an increase in doit
expenses as mentioned earlier and those
are for ongoing maintenance related to
the DMV subsystems the vision system and
the map system both of these systems are
critical to the day-to-day operations of
the DMV both at DMV substations and also
at local municipalities and both um have
to be both of the costs are required to
ensure that these systems remain
operational
perfect
return to page 11 the prioritized needs
for the Division of Motor Vehicles
primarily dealing with the Personnel so
the first is to fully fund part-time
positions across the entire division
part-timers are used at Opera at
locations across the state as well as
for back office functions and are
utilized to help leverage and change
Staffing Resources as volumes fluctuate
throughout the year
also funding two uh one one data entry
operator to three and one clerk two
position in the Bro certificate of title
these positions are required to process
title transactions and limit delays and
also not funding these positions could
result in delays in implementing new
efficiencies including e-title
processing
there's also requests to fund four data
control clerk three positions these
positions are in the financial
responsibility Bureau and without these
positions there will be impacts of
driver history records and ensuring that
those records remain up to date
finally the EMV the DMV Epping
relocation request the DMV currently
operates out of the Epping location
shared with the State Police Troop
station in Epping the
the area has we've outgrown the existing
location uh the volume is just too large
it's also not a great location to get
driver licensing
um tests out of of that area there's
been increased traffic along that area
and so the DMV is looking to relocate to
a different location within Epping and
those funds would be required in order
to do that and then finally the DMV is
looking to open a new location in
Plymouth right now customer wait times
in both Concord and Tamworth continue to
increase because individuals in The
Lakes Region have to choose to go to one
of those two locations this would meet a
need in that area and would hopefully
reduce wait times in both those areas as
well
foreign
shows the division of State Police
organizational structure
as the state law enforcement agency
State Police patrols New Hampshire's
highways toll roads and interstates
enforcing state criminal motor vehicle
and other public safety laws
State Police operates seven troop
stations a Marine Patrol facility
aircraft Hangar and provides visital
visible law enforcement presence across
the state
in addition the division also operates
the state's forensic lab the criminals
records unit permits and Licensing unit
and provide security at legislative
office building state house and New
Hampshire Hospital campus
page 13 shows the division of State
Police request of 106.9 million dollars
in FY 24 and 105.7 million dollars in
fy25
65 percent of those funds support
salaries and benefits of 578 full-time
classified and one unclassified position
has the commissioner mentioned there are
currently 90 classified positions within
prioritized need
in FY 22 New Hampshire State Police
Stopped 74 671 Motor Vehicles arrested
753 impaired drivers and conducted 6299
criminal investigations
foreign
decrease in salaries and benefits as
noted from the unfunded positions
there's also an increase in funding of
part-time auxiliary Troopers of six
hundred thirty thousand dollars and
that's to address ongoing demand for law
enforcement services
4.2 million dollars of the increase in
FY 24 is due to the increased cost of
replacement equipment including portable
radios and State Police fleet vehicles
the state police vehicle replacement
plan was not fully funded in Prior
biennium and then supply chain shortages
over supply shortages limited our
ability to make all budgeted
Replacements that were planned in the
prior two years
2.2 million in increases are due to
increased costs for ongoing maintenance
of critical New Hampshire State Police
I.T systems included including
computer-aided dispatch and Records
management system
and also increased maintenance of the
state's message platform which is used
to pass criminal justice information
between federal state and local law
on page 14 we start to look at some of
the detailed prioritized needs for state
police
1.5 million dollars is required to fund
10 Troopers two sergeants and one
lieutenant in the detectives Bureau
these are positions that work in the
major crime unit the narcotics
Investigation Unit special investigation
unit and are also serve as troop
detectives and they're critical to
ensuring that we prevent a negative
in the traffic PRL we're requesting 2.3
million dollars to fund 16 Trooper
positions these positions are located in
troop a and Epping Troop B in Bedford
and Troop D and Concord
and correspond to that request is 1.5
million to replace 20 vehicles in FY 24.
it's important to note that a vehicle is
considered equipment for a state police
Troopers perspective a trooper without a
vehicle can't perform their services and
so those two are really linked together
you'll see a similar linking between the
enforcement Bureau request of 14
Troopers and two sergeants and then 24
vehicles in fy24 the enforcement Bureau
operates out of Troop C and Keene troop
e and Tamworth and troop F in Twin
Mountain
on page 14 you'll see a request for 1.5
million for commercial enforcement to
fund 14 Trooper positions and four
vehicles in FY 24 as well
commercial enforcement operates out of
Troop G and there's Statewide Mission
and they're focused primarily on
Commercial Motor Vehicle Enforcement
activities there's also a connect here
to the motor carrier Safety assistance
program also known as mix app which is
federally funded program that requires a
maintenance of effort and so it's
critical that we fund the existing
levels of services at state funded level
to ensure that the federal funds are
324 000 is being requested for substance
abuse enforcement Troopers there's three
positions with a mobile enforcement team
and this is a team that focuses on
decreasing cross-border drug
interdiction
they're needed to prevent negative
impact of Public Safety response time
and then also ensure that officer safety
issues and the mental health and
well-being for remaining law enforcement
employees is considered
there are also civilian positions
included in prioritized needs there's
two criminalists two positions two
criminals three positions and one
criminal evidence technician position
within the state police forensic lab the
forensic lab provides services to all
local New Hampshire police departments
and these positions are required to
ensure the accurate and timely
processing of evidence that's brought
that are brought forward
there's one Sergeant position within
State Police Communications which
provides oversight over the 24 7 State
Police dispatch function
and then on page 16 an administrator 2
position which oversees the criminal
justice information message switch
system this is the piece that we talked
about with the doit expenditures that
transmits data across the criminal
justice system
and then we have some new position
requests for state police one there's
three new criminalist one positions in
the lab this is for the forensic biology
unit which has not increased its number
of full-time positions since 2012.
there's been a delay in the turnaround
time between the receipt of biology
requests in the lab and the issuance of
a report and that has continued to
Triple due to Staffing concerns we're
implementing new technology in this area
but also need new positions to ensure
that we can maintain existing levels of
service and operate that new technology
and then in the traffic bureau there's
one new program specialist two position
to help support the digital evidence
unit uh related to the body camera and
Cruiser camera data that's currently
being collected now that system has been
implemented
and then finally what's listed here at
the very bottom 1.6 million is 17
positions that were previously unfunded
in Prior biennium so these were not
funded in 22 or 23 but they are
positions that are authorized but have
been unfunded for several biennium now
page 17 is the division of Homeland
Security and Emergency Management
which is responsible for coordinating
New Hampshire's response to major
natural or human-caused disasters
on page 18 hsem's FY 24 budget request
is 27.3 million dollars their 25 request
is 26.9 million dollars
26 percent of those funds support the 42
classified into unclassified positions
the 74 of those costs are operating
funds primarily federal grants that are
distributed to locals and state agencies
as part of the homeland security grant
program through FEMA
in FY 22 hsem activated the state
Emergency Operations Center 10 times
facilitated 16 exercises and 67
trainings and conducted 31 initial
reviews and approved 44 local Hazard
7.4 million dollars of the increase in
FY 22 has increased a federal disaster
money which will be distributed to State
and local disaster responses the
majority of that is coming from the
covid-19 disasters
uh 78 000 of the increase is a new
radiological instrument technician
position
uh in the radiological instrument
maintenance and calibration section and
that position is funded 100 by other
funds as part of the annual Seabrook
station assessment
and then there are two positions that
are unfunded and listed as prioritized
needs which are listed on page 19.
in addition to these two positions
there's some additional facility
maintenance costs and also retiree
Health payments that are in prioritized
needs as uh prioritized by the
page 20 is the division of emergency
services and Communications which
oversees and operates the state's
enhanced 911 system
911 staff's two redundant Public Safety
answering Point call centers one in
Concord one Laconia the division also
maintains the state's radio network and
promotes interoperability across the
state
age 21 shows the division's budget
request of 18.5 million dollars for FY
24 and 18.9 million dollars for fy25
73 of these funds support salary and
benefits of 130 classified in one
unclassified employees all positions are
funded there are no positions within
prioritized needs in FY 22 the division
answered 481 032 calls to 9-1-1 and
maintained a 51.64 second transfer time
for emergency medical dispatch calls
and essentially no significant changes
some increases in operating costs due to
telecommunications service contracts
that needed to be rebid ended up coming
at a higher higher cost and also some
software related to computer-aid
dispatch and automatic location
identification
prioritize news on page 22 are those
that related to facility maintenance and
retiree Health payments
um as as prioritized by the department
of administrative services
page 23 is the division of fire
standards and training and EMS
which is committed to training educating
and certifying emergency and Community
responders to protect the citizens and
visitors of New Hampshire
page 24 shows the division's budget
request of 9.3 million dollars in fy24
and 9.5 million dollars in fy25
64 of those funds support 40 classified
and one unclassified employee
in FY 22 the division enrolled 20 140
students issued 1 280 certifications and
no significant changes to salary and
benefits there's actually a decrease in
full-time salaries due to new employees
that were hired at higher rates than
their incumbents but that's being offset
by an increase in part-time wages due to
increased demand for fire training
courses and part-time instructors this
division really relies heavily on
part-timers for fire training
instruction across the state
860 000 of the increase uh is due to the
increased cost of instructional supplies
to meet demands for the classes and
that's in fuel for fire training
replacement equipment as well as a new
candidate physical ability test trailer
there are three new full-time fire
service instructor positions in
prioritized needs that are unfunded
these are required to respond to
increased demand for additional
firefighter one and two courses across
New Hampshire I'm adding a full-time
instructional staff that are necessary
as I mentioned before these programs are
primarily taught by part-time
instructors and it's been a challenge to
find enough part-time instructors to
meet the demand
page 25 is the division of fire safety
whose mission is to prevent deaths
injury and property loss by promoting a
safe buyer building and hazardous
materials environment for the citizens
and visitors of New Hampshire through
education engineering investigation and
enforcement
page 26 shows the division's budget
request of 4.8 million dollars in FY 24
and 4.9 million dollars in fy25
82 percent of those funds support salary
and benefits of the 23 classified and
one unclassified employee within the
division
in FY 22 these employees investigated
123 fire related incidents conducted 323
Fire and Life safety inspections and
conducted 1 139 building Plan reviews
000 of the increase from FY 23 is due to
increases in replacement equipment
including vehicles used by fire
investigators when responding to a fire
related incident
and 105 thousand dollars of the increase
are due to increased salary and benefit
costs as a result of scheduled
increments
what's important to note here is that
the fire fund as it stands which is
supported by fees collected for driver
history records is not sufficient to
fund both the division of fire standards
and training and also the division of
fire safety and so adjustments are going
to be required to ensure that we can
continue to support both of these
divisions with those funds a combination
of expanded authorized use and then
updated per record fees will be required
in order to alleviate any concerns we
have with the fire fund fund balance
and there is one new full-time position
that's being requested by the division
this is a new program Assistant two
which is critical for planning
organizing and coordinating admin rules
and responding to 91a requests because
those responses keep increasing
um the division received 132 requests in
2020 159 and 21 and are on track to
receive 197 and 22 and so timely
responses required by law and is unable
to be met with existing resources
and so that concludes a summary of our
budget request for 24.25 and be happy to
thank you uh quick question first on on
DMV I know DMV has undergone a lot of
technological technological changes over
the last few years for example being
able to renew your license online things
like that
has that manifested itself within your
budget as far as budget savings uh for
example you know maybe unfunding
positions that are currently vacant that
would that have been made sort of
redundant by these technological
advances
uh no there hasn't really been an
opportunity to
um to eliminate positions it's it's
really more of a a convenience factor
for
um for the public
um so they don't have to wait in line
don't have to schedule an appointment or
able to renew certain things online
there's also there is somewhat of a
shift because there's still back office
work that has to happen associated with
all those transactions
um and so while there may be less
positions for front desk related
activities because of less people coming
in
um there's still work that has to occur
and it's just moved to a back office
function okay number one priority State
Police
as far as as far as funding the the the
unfunded positions you have right now
that remains your number one uh
additional prioritizing the the Troopers
yeah yeah the Troopers number one
um it's uh now let the commissioner
speak to that more but it's essentially
maintaining Public Safety Services
um very dedicated Force they've been
doing it with um with less folks due to
vacancies
um we're having success attracting
people now uh the Market's starting to
change that's my next question is
um I know that the state has instituted
an incentive program for you to hire uh
more state troopers and
um if you could comment a little bit
about how successful that program has
been and where you see it going uh
you know assuming we fund a lot of these
unfunded currently unfunded positions
sure thank you for the question I I
think the Recruitment and the retention
bonuses are definitely something that
will benefit uh in the short and the
long term and
our most recent testing uh was a lot
more promising we had more showing up we
had a better class we monitor that very
closely so I think that that has
definitely been a step in the right
direction and they that is our our
number one priority okay
um do you have any sort of projections
that are on the on the given the current
landscape how many additional Troopers
you think you're able to get prior to
the end of this current fiscal year or
well
I I can't give an exact number now but
but what I will say is
um by the time if we bring in if we have
a test and say at the test the the
physical and the written test we get you
know 50 pass rate then that we have to
go through the the rest of the process
which is an oral interview and the
testing the polygraph Etc
um
but like I said the last class
we had 20
that
took the test and 12 went on from there
to the next step so that that looked
promising compared to other classes okay
if if you for example were to hire 20
between now and June 30th is that would
I take the six I believe the 69
positions you want funded and subtracted
20 from that or is that the 69 positions
plus whatever you hire
well I think any any time we hire we're
subtracting them so we would
automatically subtract those so yeah
there I I could say this they're working
very hard in the recruitment side and um
it is their top priority in the state
police but
um but I'm I'm confident in the team
that they have over there that they're
doing everything possible and the
measures that have taken place uh
already I think are going to help okay
thank you so much
yep
um
so you want excuse me you won funded 81
positions and that which is and I'm
going to ask about that just because
it's unusual nobody else is
unfunding positions um they're mostly
refunding positions
I
uh none of them were filled at the time
of the budget development
um some of them may be filled now we
have not stopped recruiting and so um
the positions were were unfunded to meet
the revenue targets that we had at the
time and that was the only way that we
could achieve those targets
so most agencies started with their with
their positions and then you know to the
extent that they didn't do anything
different they didn't
didn't do it on the people side what why
is I'm looking at your budget and you're
you're actually less people than most
parts of the budget are
um you know you're 55 60 percent
people is it is it the nature of where
those people are I mean I know 90 of
your general funds I say police and is
it is that what it comes down to or yeah
it's exactly what it is so the state
police division is funded um by a mix of
General Highway Turnpike funds
um general fund increases were allowed
Turnpike Highway funds were not there
weren't other areas that we could that
we could find savings without
significantly impacting the the
operations
okay
and does every Trooper position come
with a car
when we project we include the car the
radio everything that's right man and so
what are the
what's the other stuff cost
you know salary benefits and then you
know the car and stuff
uh so so the the cars um we budget for a
fully outfitted car
um we're looking at high 40s
okay
and so they is there anything else they
get like that or is that that's all in
that includes the computer and
everything else yeah if you want to if
you want to round out to 50 for
um computer equipment uniform vehicle
vehicle upfit all those components
great
so along the same lines of your your
triple positions
um
does your federal or other sources of
income uh
will that cover any additional Staffing
or is most of your Staffing going to
then be generally generally funded like
I'm not sure how your federal grants
work in your Trooper area in federal
money that comes in but does are you at
a fixed Federal amount or do you do you
have more Troopers can you have
additional Federal money that comes in
to help offset some of the costs
um right now we're pretty much at a
fixed Federal amount for the federally
funded positions
um the risk is the maintenance of effort
requirements associated with those law
enforcement activities and not being
able to meet the state portion which
puts those federally funded positions
you'd like to invite officer
professional licensure and certification
foreign
I think we're ready great
uh well thank you first off my name is
Lindsay Courtney I'm the executive
director of The Office Professional Ace
insurance certification and with me I
have Heather Kelly who's our director of
operations and we certainly appreciate
the opportunity to speak with you today
regarding oplc's FY 24 and 25 budget
requests I wanted to start off on page
two with just a brief agency a review I
know most of you are probably familiar
with the agency although we have seen
some significant organizational changes
recently
we ever see the administration of 50
Professional Licensing boards seven of
those are directly regulated by the
office itself
while we are a fairly new agency
established in 2015 the boards are not
new and oblc's task has been to
consolidate all administrative functions
into one regulatory body
the second bullet point on page two
highlights some of our key licensure
data and certainly more is available in
our annual reports with a licensee pool
that equals the size of 16 of the
state's population oplc's operations
certainly significantly impact Workforce
in this state and so our budget our
proposed budget was designed to fully
resource the agency to ensure it is able
to timely respond to Workforce needs
the third bullet point
um details our personnel
positions that we have currently we have
82 permanent classified positions in
addition to that we presently have 19
full-time temporary positions we are
requesting uh that we that we convert
six of those to permanent positions in
the budget
um essentially we're anticipating that
as we move from an a manual Personnel
driven process to an electronic process
we will be able to
um unfund some of those positions
through attrition and at present we only
have three vacant positions including
the 19 full-time temporary
on page three I just wanted to touch
briefly on our vision which which guided
our proposal today our licensing boards
have for years operated with very
rudimentary manual processes which has
created significant barriers to
Workforce
so our vision is really to transform and
modernize support for New Hampshire's
Professional Licensing boards we propose
to do this over the next several years
by shifting from a manual Personnel
driven process to streamlined electronic
processes
and our budget was designed to help the
agency achieve its vision mission and
strategic goals which were captured more
fully in our strategic plan which you
also have a copy of
on page four
we provide some objectives contained
within our agency budgets and designing
our proposed budget we focused on our
strategic goals for FY 23 fy25
among other things we we want to
increase licensure portability and
enhance customer service by leveraging
technology as well as continue to focus
on establishing internal controls
throughout the agency and for the boards
how are we going to pay for our proposed
budget which I believe stands at about
15.1 million dollars in FY 24. as you
know oplc is a self-funded agency its
revenue must not exceed 125 of its costs
but we are proposing a budget uh that
essentially
um would result in a minimal elapse to
the general fund in other words our
proposed budget does propose an increase
in expenditures but the budget would be
fully funded by existing revenues for
not anticipating an increase in revenues
but just to fully fund the budget with
existing revenues
on page five
we provide a summary of our budget
requests
we are proposing to modernize operations
by leveraging technology in a few ways
we'd like to transition to a fully
electronic customer driven licensing
portal this would virtually eliminate
oplc's receipt of incomplete
applications we estimate our receipt
right now is about 95 percent which
would result in a significantly
decreased licensure time frames
obviously the eliminating barriers to
Workforce
a new portal would also provide the
state with access to important necessary
data for Workforce analysis data that we
don't presently have across the state
and there's I'm not aware of any other
agency that's able to compile that data
we are already working with stakeholders
to understand the important data
elements and we're currently
promulgating rules right now on behalf
of the agency to streamline licensing
procedures in anticipation of
procurement you should know also that
doit did receive we worked with doit to
procure arpa dollars for this purpose
but we do require continued support of
our business analysts that are presently
uh temporary full-time positions in
order to
proceed with the procurement and
implementation of a new system
we are also proposing to transition to a
fully electronic customer driven
continuing education tracking portal
um just to give you every part of oplc's
processes that were created by the
boards many years ago was was governed
required a person to actually take a
step we are trying to transition
completely away from that and have the
user essentially guide themselves
so I'm pH six
just an overview of establishing
internal controls how we're going to do
that through the budget obviously to
leverage technology appropriately we
have to have internal controls in place
as many of you know this has been a
significant challenge for the agency
um it almost would have been easier I
think if the boards if we had just
started fresh
instead of trying to fix everything that
has been going on for years boards
created their own ways of doing business
for many years they operated as their
own fiefdoms establishing internal
controls requires significant support
and a change in the culture that is
supportive to be supportive of complying
with the law we presently have
established temporary full-time
positions to your attorneys and
administrator one who is our internal
controls administrator
who are absolutely necessary to continue
to put internal controls in place and so
we are seeking to convert those
permanent positions to full-time so
that's what you see the increase on last
in class 10 primarily that's on page
nine of our agency budget book we also
anticipate a slight increase in class 26
for organizational dues we are statutory
required to participate and they're
based on our licensing numbers which we
do anticipate to go up a little bit
hopefully if we have increased Workforce
with class 46 we are proposing a fairly
significant increase in Consultants what
we're trying to do is get away from
board members conducting business on
their own on behalf of the boards into
contractual relationship with expert
Consultants so that we can better manage
the course of their conduct and ensure
compliance so that's where we're
proposing a raise or an increase to
class 46 and then a slight increase to
class 66 for staff training and
education
we would we have developed a board
member training portals we would like to
encourage board members to participate
but at least we can control staff and so
we would propose staff training and
education in order to promote compliance
um a couple of other things as outlined
on page nine of the agency budget book I
would just want to note that class 30
the increase in equipment new and
replacement that is primarily for
vehicles we actually may be able to
purchase those Vehicles this year it was
unclear whether or not we'd have
inventory so at the time of establishing
the budget
um we proposed uh to increase that line
item you also see class 531 impaired
programs that is a statutorily required
program that we are required to contract
for specific to nursing but we can also
offer it for dentists and pharmacists
this went out to bed and the contract
price is located there there's also a
separate dedicated fund and we raise
fees specific for that purpose for those
license professions and then finally
will see an increase in our lease to
capture the amendment to our lease that
was approved last year through governor
and Council
so thank you very much for your time I'm
happy to take any questions
okay thank you very much
on the use of Consultants does does the
increased use of Consultants
have a direct impact on the
um
maybe the
operation of the boards they're hiring
do they they tend to make these boards
less relevant
foreign
yes I think that's true
um I think what we found though is is
over the years when boards have taken
upon themselves to perform all functions
be judged jury and executioner that
there are issues with that
um and we'd like to professionalize with
our Workforce and the board members
leverage the board members for their
expertise but solely for their expertise
and their professions and not for their
for their assistance with administrative
functions
okay thank you and and one of the
questions I noticed that uh as a line
item the the rent it's rent leases other
than state has been up and down pretty
much you can just take me through why
that's it's gone from 500 0003 and back
up to 750 and I don't know if you could
take me why that
major operating expenses the second line
it's down are you in a department
summary okay
okay
oh
got it runs Lisa's other than State yes
um so what happened is we were in Phil
Brook which was a state-owned facility
during the pandemic
um
DHHS needed our building so we vacated
the building we procured a portion of
the building that we're in now which was
not sufficient but it was what was
available so we executed part of the
lease that was up you know it was
approximately
I think it was 393 000 and then we
prepared another part of that space once
Deloitte vacated that we went to fiscal
um and so FY 22 that represents the
entirety of the lease except but we only
paid for half of the building for a
certain portion of the year we do need
to go to fiscal for FY 23 in order to
pay for our our lease which totals
approximately 751 and that's what we've
asked for okay great thank you you're
welcome
yes
that's been an ongoing challenge I can
let Heather speak to that a little bit
better it's part of our establishing
so we are using activity codes for each
board to establish where the expenses
are currently going uh some activity
codes are not using used appropriately
and expense classes were not used
appropriately so we have adjusted
internal controls to make sure expenses
are being allocated appropriately to the
board there were some expenses were
being allocated to the agency instead of
foreign
we changed our allocation method last
year
um the allocation method used to be
based on Revenue which really made sense
to me that percentage of Revenue brought
in we'd allocate a certain amount of
that percentage of costs back to the
board
we are proposing to allocate or we do
allocate
um shared costs to the boards based on
licensees
um but license number the idea being
that every licensee has access to the
same services
we there was a whole committee this year
designed to look at our allocation
method as well as our fee so it's a
South try SB 330. the problem is if you
have you know the concern we have is if
you allocate you know particular cost of
a prosecution to a board your fees are
going to go up and down and very
significantly so the idea is that if we
charge on a per licensee basis for
shared costs then it's pretty consistent
um we have been working with the
governor's office not
um decided to put a hold on modifying
any fees if you look at our annual
report you'll see that board revenue is
all over the place in terms of that 125
Mark some are are making it some are
significantly exceeding it some are not
making meeting costs
after the
um work with the committee established
by Senate Bill 330. once we got some
clarification we do anticipate moving
forward with some some rule changes to
make sure everyone is is not greater
no it's it's this one over here
um that um oh good
um
and I worry about that and I remember at
one point it was I don't even know
Architects somebody was paying like 700
percent their fees covered 700 of
expenses and
right at some point if I'm an architect
why don't I sue for my money back
yes that's been our concern as well
um one could make the argument some are
paying way more than they should raising
tax implications which is why we
um have for the past three years tried
to move forward with legislation that
would allow us to make sure everybody is
less than 125 percent this budget is
really designed to be 100 budget um the
feedback we got from the legislative
committee on 330 was that 125 we don't
need to be near 125 percent
um because we we're not functioning the
way we used to and that we need to keep
certain amount of money in the bank so
do you publish annual data yes uh
through our annual report our most
recent one was released November 1st
it's on our website oh and so it'll show
like if I'm an architect I hate to pick
on Architects
um but I'm an architect and go oh
they're collecting 116 percent
yes I can tell you cosmetology is
probably at 46 and there are some that
are about 200
um and you'll see that in our annual
report well that's a better range a few
years back somebody was at 700. so yeah
no we don't have any 700s
outstanding as long as the CPA Group is
not at the 200 percent I'm okay with
that
foreign
thank you for your time thank you very
now invite police standards and training
foreign
good afternoon
uh for the record my name is John skippa
I'm the director of New Hampshire police
standards and training
police engine training's mission is to
shape strengthen and sustain the
competency of professionalism of New
Hampshire law enforcement in service to
our state
the police standards and training
Council regulates the hiring and
educational standards for all police
state corrections and probation parole
officers
here in the state of New Hampshire
we operate the New Hampshire Police
Academy which all Municipal Police
County Sheriff deputies state troopers
conservation officers liquor
investigators and any other full-time
law enforcement officer must attend to
become certified as a full-time police
officer in the state
we also operate the part-time Police
Academy
that all part-time police officers must
complete to obtain their part-time
officer certification as well as the New
Hampshire Corrections Academy that all
State Corrections Officers attend
in order to obtain corrections officer
certification
we also provide specialized advance and
in-service refresher training at our
facility in Concord and regionally
around the state to assist officers in
completing their annual requirements to
maintain their certification
as part of our responsibility for
regulating over 4 000 certified officers
in our state we convene and rule on
disciplinary hearings that may suspend
or Revolt the certification of officers
that have violated Council rules or
committed a crime or an act of moral
turpitude
we are an independent executive branch
agency governed by 14-member police
standards and training Council
we are not affiliated with any law
enforcement or prosecutorial agency
thereby avoiding potential conflicts of
interest with our regulatory function
and decertification duties
we provide services with 26 full-time
and six part-time positions which
include sworn staff administrative and
maintenance employees
our staff is assisted by adjunct
instructors most of whom are unpaid
volunteers and a small number of
contracted instructors
we operate a 77 000 square foot training
facility located on
20.87 Acres of grounds across from nhti
the Das provided pstc with Target
allocations from the governor's office
of no more than three percent increase
for FY 24 and zero percent increase for
fy25 are submitted
uh efficiency budget requests meets
those requirements our adjusted
authorized budget for FY 23 is currently
000 30 dollars
our fy24 request
of five
seven eight eight six three one
represents a three percent increase
above the FY 23 adjusted
and our fy25 request of five seven eight
eight six three one represents a zero
it's important to note that police
standards and training has taken on a
number of new responsibilities since our
last budget cycle
these new responsibilities are the
result of 2022 legislation
through administrative rule changes
based on recommendations made by the
governor's law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission and through
realignment of responsibilities between
state agencies
SB
376--f-n
2022 session assigned pstc with
providing Crisis Intervention training
to the New Hampshire Law Enforcement
Officers with the target of having at
least one officer from every law
enforcement agency in the state trained
executive order
2022-06 assigned pstc with the
responsibility of overseeing the
Statewide accreditation program for law
enforcement agencies
this program is not funded Beyond a doj
grant that will expire at the end of FY
23.
HP
1682-fn-a 2022 session established a law
enforcement conduct Review Committee
under police standards and training this
committee will be responsible for
overseeing and reviewing all
investigations regarding allegations of
police misconduct as defined in statute
through executive order
2020-19 administrative rule
Pol
403-check .01 has been amended to
increase the number of annual in-service
training hours for all certified Law
Enforcement Officers as a condition of
continued certification from eight hours
annually increasing incrementally to 24
hours of annual training by 2025.
police standards and training has
assumed primary responsibility for
overseeing and delivering active shooter
alert training from the Department of
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management in 2022
so as to Define training areas of
responsibility more clearly
our additional prioritized needs
requests
for fy24 includes two full-time
positions
to assist with some of these new
responsibilities
one position is a program specialist
three to manage new programs given to us
that includes the active shooter
training
and the Statewide accreditation for law
the second full-time position is a
training development manager which is
critically needed to to help us develop
online training content for New
Hampshire law enforcement officers and
agencies
through the liac recommendations and
executive order 2020-19 annual
in-service training requirements have
been increased from eight hours to 24
hours annually for all law enforcement
officers
doit has requested an additional 16 998
and fy24 and
18145 in fy25 for shared costs increase
in software costs support and consulting
services and doit increases for
additional funded positions
our total agency additional prioritized
needs request is for an additional
192 105 and fy24
and 196 186 in fy25
our proposed FY 2425 budget re reflects
compliance with Target allocation set
forth by Das while attempting to
properly
inappropriately resource our current
obligations of providing contemporary
recruit training to newly hired officers
creating and delivering in-service
training
regulating and monitoring compliance
with Professional Standards as well as
preparing to meet the number of new
obligations as outlined above
thank you for listening to our
presentation and I stand ready for any
questions
okay thank you very much uh you as far
as
people go you have a smaller agency as
far as a number of employees what's your
current vacancy rate for your and your
employees uh we have uh a background
investigation being conducted on a
candidate for an open position and then
we have just uh last week
advertised for the three positions that
support the conduct Review Committee
that's two training Specialists and one
attorney for position
uh again those are being actively uh
advertised right now
okay
um
with the emphasis on hiring new police
officers not only we just had the
department of safety and in talking with
with their Trooper requests but
obviously municipalities are going
through a lot of the same problems that
the state is having
assuming that they are able to meet
their hiring goals does this budget
reflect do you have enough money in this
budget to be able to train those people
that they want to hire the additional
people that they want to hire
no
okay I think it's important for uh this
committee to recognize that uh because
of Recruitment and Retention issues that
have really manifest themselves in uh
this year where we really saw a push and
really almost at the beginning of this
year
I actually went to uh police answer
training Council to ask permission to
run overlapping police academies and
increase the number of academies that
we're delivering so that uh the choke
point was not at police Sanders and
training to get those new officers
hired through their training and then
back to their their home agencies uh
you know we'd like to think that um
we were able to do that uh very quickly
my staff did a wonderful job uh in
addressing that uh kind of boots on the
ground but uh I think to answer your
question if all of those positions got
hired all at once
we would there would be a backlog of
getting folks through the through the
police academy in a timely fashion that
would be a wonderful thing if we could
fill all those open spots at once and I
don't anticipate that that's going to
happen
but there is a a a kind of a critical
need to move people through the academy
because
most agencies are seeing attrition rates
at let's just say 10 and the recruitment
efforts are probably yielding four
percent
so it's it's that dire need of we got to
hire these people and get them through
good afternoon
um this is along those same lines is are
you seeing class sizes
strength in terms of recruits wanting to
go through the academy whether the
police academy or the correctional
Academy are there less that are just
coming through the door therefore less
on the on the you know the back end in
terms of being able to be hired or as
class size has been relatively
consistent
so uh it it's kind of a strange
manifestation we're seeing a very full
classes at the police academy the
full-time Police Academy
uh and in fact we have a class that's
scheduled to start in January and that's
already full and then we have a a second
class that starts in February we're
going to overlap these classes again uh
and that's already that already has
about 30 registered folks in them uh
on the other hand are part-time police
certification program at the beginning
of the year we were going to have an
academy and we did not even have 10
people and so it it did not make sense
to to run that through uh I do know that
um uh also the Department of Corrections
uh has had some uh classes that are
smaller than usual as well uh again uh
there's we're we're seeing a slow
Hemorrhage if if you would where there's
a lot of people leaving our profession
and uh we don't see as many people
signing up and um and I think more so I
know that commissioner Hanks is here but
more so uh on the on the correction side
uh but it is it is something that we're
seeing here in the state and across the
country
for I mean let's just say you had as
many people as you could take
um what's your capacity to train in a
year
so uh and then I presume different kinds
of
you know part-time Academy Corrections
Etc sure we we could
um we could do a hundred part-time
people in a year
we could do right now in our present
rotation we do 210 full-time people a
year
and I'm sure that
um
we could probably do that same number
210 with corrections as well uh
certainly if uh if we were able to find
more training space which is something
that we we lack as well we might even be
able to uh increase that number if in
fact we were able to find that many
folks that were ready to to join law
enforcement here in New Hampshire well
and it's actually the question I'm I'm
getting at is
um
your limitations right now are based on
a number of people who want to be
trained for Your Capacity based on
physical plant
I I would say that uh if if the number
of people applying was not a variable
then we're clearly limited by uh we're
under resourced we don't we don't have
enough training staff and we don't have
enough training space
uh and that has been like that
uh in my opinion for a very long time uh
we we are literally responsible for
certifying every law enforcement officer
uh in the state of New Hampshire and yet
uh
uh you know our our in-service hours
have increased uh from eight hours to 24
hours uh we've been asked to do that
mission with less people over the last
probably 10 years
and and candidly ladies and gentlemen uh
in an effort to toe the line and and be
on target uh there was things that we
needed to ask for that I just didn't ask
for
so I I
um
we are under resourced but if you had if
you had more space or you had more uh
trainers if you will
um do you have you know seats in the
chair
you have enough people to sit in the
chairs
uh would you have enough uh students for
a life of a better word
so I I think again
um you know that's uh those those butts
in the chairs that we're talking about
uh they're just not they're not signing
up they're just not signed we're not
seeing
uh
Replacements uh that the attrition rate
is just much you know much greater than
the recruitment rates right now and
that's that really is across the board
can you give me a sense of how dramatic
like what was it like five years ago in
terms of number of let's just say
full-time
police officer candidates so I I would
say that we were
um and I can speak to the short time
that I have been the director
so when I very first was appointed uh we
were running classes at right around 65
and we were running three classes a year
and there might be a couple of a couple
of recruits that would have to wait for
the next class
but it was pretty consistent
I think the Corrections Academy enjoyed
greater numbers as well uh for uh
recruit officers
I we're still seeing people signing up
for that full-time Academy
uh the urgency is coming from the
communities that are probably
experiencing uh we we tried to run a
survey we didn't get a lot of responses
and so you know it's the numbers are
only as good as the numbers but we're
we're seeing a uh
estimated 20 percent
decrease or 20 percent open uh positions
vacancies
on average across the state of New
Hampshire for New Hampshire law
enforcement
uh anecdotally I've been a New Hampshire
police officer for almost 40 years now I
have never in those those 38 nine years
seen that the New Hampshire State Police
have that many vacancies uh and that's
that should serve as an example of
really what this state is experiencing
right now for for
vacancy rates across the board there's
very very few agencies that if any
candidly that have full staffs right now
thank you you're welcome
like to invite the New Hampshire Lottery
foreign
If You Begin by telling yourself no one
in New Hampshire won that billion dollar
uh that's funny the um we've had three
winners over over 100 million dollars in
the last five years uh so you know we
got our numbers anyway so it's it's
warming is it a woman Charlie it's I can
do that why
but that's the wrong dude this is the
wrong hearing to use that money and I
figured you spend it once I hold it out
you know knowing how the state works as
soon as I showed it
um good afternoon everyone good
afternoon my name is Charlie McIntyre
I'm director of New Hampshire lottery uh
otherwise known as the chief bookmaking
officer for the state and with me is our
chief bean counter Jim durris our CFO
um
I remember briefly what I this the slide
I handed out obviously is one we take
tremendous pride in
um in the past two full fiscal years
we've transferred 290 million dollars of
net profit to the state
in the two years prior to that was 205
million dollars in profit to the state
and our expenses barely moved uh in the
private sector when you increase net
revenues by 85 million dollars and
barely increase expenses that is
considered better than good
uh and so I submit our request for the
budget for FY 20 4 and 25. one of the
benefits to my job in our position is
that we are Net Zero to the state budget
ours is just a permission to spend from
our expenses come from our revenues so
that 85 million dollar increase in net
profitability also included our expenses
um one of the worst Parts about my job
and our job is is that you folks spend
it before we make it
uh and so we have to take into account
market conditions and variabilities that
I just can't foresee uh I would note
most heartily the increase in gas prices
and Ukraine war that neither of us saw
when we get a revenue estimates last
time
um there's nothing worse than gas prices
for lottery sales nearly half of our net
revenues our sales the traditional
Lottery happened to places that sell gas
so when gas spikes over four dollars you
don't walk in the store use the bathroom
you poke your tank and leave and so that
being said uh Jim if you wouldn't mind
going through the uh prioritize needs
the there's only a few of them obviously
I know we're behind so I'll be quick
we'll be quick yeah
um so we have uh
seven prioritized needs listed upside
six
um again I'll go quickly one of them is
years ago we had one back office system
that we used with all of our gamer
information which customers in our sense
of the word would be in there now we've
added ilottery platform which is a
completely separate system from that and
now we've also added draftking system
again a third system so whenever we want
to pull data and information about who
our customers are and to increase to
design games increase profits any of
those things we have three separate
systems going on so the first priority
ties need is for 2.4 million dollars
over the two-year span that is to create
a data warehouse and a business
intelligence tool along with a CRM
system so that we can gather all that
information through one one uh system
from those three different systems and
Lord knows what's hap happening on down
the road as well to incorporate those
systems into a into um
a program like that
um
the
other one is we have 126 000 in our
generator is uh over 30 years old at
this point our generator obviously it is
what it is it's our backup power system
which is vital to our agency if we do
lose power and our gaming systems can't
be up and running obviously anytime
you're not selling tickets and uh you're
losing money uh so that's a system
that's been out
um
of
uh according to Engineers report should
have been replaced in 2017.
uh we also have a server room as part of
the same project we've had it engineered
our server room is also protected by
water sprinkler systems
that is not a good idea you don't want
to be dumping water all over your
computer equipment if alarm does go off
um so that's would also include an
upgrade to that system which would get
it into I can't remember what it's
called but it's a something like that
um
and
um we also have a project in that we've
asked for I'm losing my spot here that
would be a roof replacement along those
same lines some we have a very leaky
roof and I know some other agencies have
dealt with that issue for a very long
time
um I would again say a little bit
differences ours is that we have some of
those leaks that are getting very close
to that server room as well
um where if something happens there and
we're shut down and one thing I always
have to keep in mind when I'm looking at
these is
if our internal control systems go down
when you have a Powerball jackpot like
we did a few weeks ago of two billion
dollars if our systems go down because
of some problem like this it's not only
the state of New Hampshire but it's the
entire country that can't verify those
numbers and we're now the state of
Minnesota who's not alone
who's not allowing a 2 billion dollar
so and we also have put in a request for
um
media costs and things like that again
everything's gone up significantly over
the last couple years and I'll let you
adjust that yeah so for example media
cost
um one is first our partnership with
DraftKings requires us to do a media
spend in the state and that's by design
it I don't say limits but it accurately
reflects the amount of media necessary
versus other states which get blasted by
media from sports betting companies
incessantly mass is going to has
legalized sports betting finally we'd
like to thank them for not doing it for
so long that we profited immensely from
their citizen or citizenry
um and so we will be competing in open
market with them also the cost of media
has gone up about 20 percent the cost of
production costs have gone up about 20
percent uh as you see from our budget
the vast majority of our budget is not
people it is services and goods and so
with the inflationary lift all the
things we buy went up similar holy in
terms of cost we had to get from Indiana
to get a vehicle
to find a vehicle we could you could buy
um and so media like I said the half
million dollar increase in both of the
years is specifically for media
purchasing uh production costs
that's it
probably uh your positions if you want
to touch it oh no there's certainly the
seven positions which
growth requires support
and in the last 10 years we've doubled
net profitability and we're looking to
support
essentially that effort uh it's not by
accident it requires people and effort
and such so
um you know we're proud of the number of
accomplishments we have we're amongst
the top lotteries in virtually every
category in the US so
um we're proud of efforts happy to
answer any questions thank you thank you
uh you mentioned Massachusetts I know
they've had a little difficulty
implementing their their program uh much
much to our Delight but
um what sort of impact are we expecting
on our revenues from their
implementation of sports bang so it's a
that's a good question I get a lot as
you could imagine right
um right now we derive probably 25 to 30
percent of our
net revenue net gaming and sports
betting from Massachusetts players
um I would expect it to go down slightly
I don't know how much only for a couple
of reasons one is we now have their
Player information they're now customers
of ours
serve his dad
a large they make up a larger percentage
of actually who visit the facilities
that are at Seabrook in Manchester
and we don't have that fancy state
income tax they have in Massachusetts uh
we plan on taking full effort of that as
a marketing
principle
um and they're comfortable along where
they are now the closest physical
location to Northern Massachusetts is
Everett
which is not really built out for a
physical sports book
parking is tricky they're trying to put
kiosks for sports betting in the parking
lot which is about the dumbest thing you
could do
and not having much success so
I don't think it's 25 is my point I
don't know the exact number New Jersey
thought they were going to take a
massive hit when New York legalized it
it barely moved the needle so I'm hoping
to to what extent
um first of all nice opening I mean
I picture a thousand words you must have
a shot
um the uh
to what extent are are you know we still
know people who who were addicted or
maybe that's the wrong word sorry
scratch tickets right and they would
just you know every Tuesday and they'd
buy like 12 scratch tickets and sit and
Dunkin Donuts scratching away
um to what extent is uh do the online
things and the keno and all the sort of
new availability of of sort of the
instant gratification
betting cannibal has that so you're
asking them what's the meaning of life
question essentially like what's what
does new gaming do
um if you read the research which I do
um it would suggest that the number of
folks who have problem gambling is not a
variable that changes it's one half two
percent that member exists even in
Hawaii which has no lawful gambling
the availability of gambling increases
those folks's spend and problems and so
any increase in the amount of gambling
should be met commensurably with an
increase in treatment
so in a population of a million adults
for example in New Hampshire two percent
is you know 20 000 people would have a
problem who if they're engaged or not in
recovery should have an issue that
should be addressed
I don't think more stuff equals more
gambling and oddly sports betting is a
very Niche product
meaning very few people do it and they
in our biggest Munch which was last
month we only had 30 000 people
actively engaged with the platform so
that's less than three percent of the
adults in the state and that included
almost a third from Massachusetts and so
it's not a big pool of people that do it
if that makes sense how's that compare
does it say scratch tickets
um the most ubiquitous would be
Powerball
um and so Powerball would be I'm just
saying though if you're looking for the
biggest pool Powerball we sold 60 of the
adults in the state of Powerball ticket
last year
so that's the biggest pool really yes
I wouldn't uh I'd have lost a bet on
that
did you were you one of them I was not
okay I'm not gonna say that um gambling
I didn't I didn't feel like buying a
ticket appreciably changed my odds I
apprecially change drugs it's it's so
funny I when this person who won
Powerball when they signed the back of
the ticket I said Well why'd you sign it
well I didn't think I'd win I'm like
well you they won you know 400 million
so they had a good day not a bad day I
would like to have that day
we forgot the director's 10 contribution
too so
thank you very much thank you you just
need that stack of money with
administrative Services over there
[Laughter]
thank you
and I see the Department of Corrections
is here I'd like to invite them to come
foreign
good afternoon
I am on afternoon commissioner good
afternoon for the record my name is
Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections and with me is
John Hanson our director of
administration I do find the accounting
irony going after Lottery and listening
to that presentation to corrections as
we are primarily a general funded
organization so thank you in advance
the Department of Corrections mission is
to reduce recidivism by providing safe
secure and Humane supervision and
evidence-based Rehabilitation to enhance
Public Safety in New Hampshire and we
have been proudly doing that and doing
it quite well we were created in Statute
in July of 1983 and by RSA we are
responsible for providing maintaining
administrating such correctional
facilities and programs as may be
required for custody safety keeping
control and Correctional treatment and
Rehabilitation of people incarcerated
New Hampshire we're also responsible for
the supervision of persons place on
probation to Parole in New Hampshire and
administering those probation and parole
Services across the state of New
Hampshire and across the state lines we
act in an advisory capacity and
assisting other law enforcement agencies
and community in preventing crime and
delinquency and importantly and please
do not forget we ensure that victims of
crime are treated in a manner consistent
with their victim Rights bill and that
the Primal axed engaged upon them have
rehabilitative qualities
on page two we list a short list of
challenges and accomplishments we are
continually experiencing major
challenges in Recruitment and Retention
and have certainly seen those
exacerbations post covid-19 the
Department of Corrections held its own
and did an amazing job with the staff
there through those very tough years in
a correctional environment fighting a
infectious disease you can't see with
our staff and our staff that were
working 24 7 in our state facilities and
who are not home about working very hard
but post covid we've had a lot of people
choose to retire deservedly and as you
just heard in the previous testimony of
police dance and training Council the
deficits we saw before are only further
exacerbated by the current law
enforcement deficits not just in the
state but nationally and in Corrections
and as time leaves things are the State
of Florida has an article out about
putting 300 National Guard service
members across the their Correctional
Facilities to fulfill their mission and
as the state of New Hampshire has done
that on occasion we continue to
persevere
each month and each day and look forward
to finding additional resources to help
this agency but it is a real problem
just not in the state of New Hampshire
it is a real problem across the country
we are challenged primarily with aging
infrastructure at the New Hampshire
state prison for men the institution in
the North country as we refer to it as
ncf or North Country facility was built
in 2000 our new women's facility built
in 2018 the infrastructure at the
Concord state prison for men is a
historical research project in and of
itself but it needs to be rebuilt and I
think the governor advance for his
opening sentence sentiments about moving
us forward in that direction over time
uh with that said we have implemented a
lot of things to try to improve the
health and wellness of our staff given
the overtime requirements we place on
them as a state and we've implemented an
employee wellness program which we
continue to advance
we've increased increased capacity to
provide substance use disorder treatment
services through a program we call our
Focus program and I will affirm for you
that substance use disorder is one of
the number one drivers of
reincarceration
um
with that said we've also turned our our
minds to medication-assisted treatment
and accomplished increasing the
medications that we employ in that
treatment regimen and there's details of
that work and happy to talk further
about that with anyone offline as I love
to Intrigue commissionerling house with
our work we have collaborated with the
community college system of New
Hampshire to allow residents to
participate in computer numerical
control Machining boot camp for nine
weeks and continue to have those those
are important advancements that we've
made during covid post covet I know so
we're still in covid
um to improve the education of
vocational training that we offer people
who are incarcerated because that is one
of the number one rehabilitative
activities that we can do to reduce
reincarceration with that said we've
also continued to work with some grant
funding we do get some grant funding by
the National Science Foundation titled
prisons evolving as connected
communities and we've been engaging with
Community stakeholders to develop a
prism model of connected community that
will address information and Technology
to create both a in and out model if you
will of incarcerated education and
Vocational skills I'm a member as well
as another member of my team of a newly
formed New England Commission on the
future of higher education Behind Bars
and we've done really unique things
working with Partners such as cast in
Universal Design learning to change
curriculums that you'll see and see in
our our school institutions our Choose
Love program and have adapted that to
adults who are incarcerated and that was
a national first for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections and that
program is often running and changing
people's perspectives and reducing
violence
foreign those are just a small List look
forward to our future annual report or
pass annual reports to learn more about
our accomplishments and our challenges
on page three is a high level summary of
our proposal for fy24 and fy25
our costs are primarily I don't think
you'll be surprised salary and benefits
we are human resources driven
organization the other large area is our
medical and pharmaceutical expenses and
there are other operational costs
that'll get into the detail as you can
see we show our actual of FY 2022 our
adjusted authorized of 2023 and the
differences between our three percent
efficiency because you'll go that's more
than three percent I can do that math is
associated with the inclusion of funding
we had for body worn cameras that was
not part of FY 2024 forecast as well as
adjustments in our probation and parole
teams salaries and and rent I wonder who
charges us rent
um so those allowed us to have a
slightly larger what appear to be a
larger but it is still within that three
percent efficiency for 2024 and then uh
trying to stay relatively static in
2025.
I will not go through all of these lines
as I know you will look at them with the
intent in which you have received them
and I will certainly continue to be
available to ask questions on page four
we dive into our Personnel Services they
do average about 74 percent of our total
general fund requests over the biennium
that is our classified unclassified and
part-time salaries it includes our
holiday paid part-time pay overtime pay
and benefits
um we continue to aggressively recruit
and work for retention uh the FY
2024-2025 budget does include funding
973 positions it sets our overtime at
5.49 you might ask me why I will tell
you why a little further
that it's not a higher number
we are still asking for the statutory
authority to continue to move monies
associated with vacant positions that
has been a very effective Financial
strategy we do that very transparency
going transparently going before the
fiscal committee and governor and
Council we did up that over timeline as
a base because of different bargained
salaries and wages that would affect it
normally so you'll see the budget
footnote that we propose underneath on
page four
on page five we show you a trended
analysis of our overtime some of that
over time is indicative of adjustments
in salaries through bargaining but also
increased vacancies right now
organizationally we have 28 vacancy rate
when we look at targeted areas ones that
hurt us the most our security positions
are as high as 39 across the whole
organization other positions that
deserve recognition our chef positions
are at 50 those chefs feed 5 700 meals a
day yes with resident labor but they are
the lead behind that project every
single day we have a high vacancy rate
in our Southern clinical team who
provide those medication assisted
treatment and other mental health
disorder treatment services so in need
of Rehabilitation and this over time is
indicative of continuing to move the
agency forward so overtime strategies
we've engaged in we talk and ask all of
our retirees if they want to come back
and work part-time as long as they're in
good standing and we have anywhere range
from 19 to 25 people choose to do that
that helps in any way shape or form as
you can imagine based on both this
Finance but that last year for example
we had over 300 hours 300 000 hours of
overtime across all sites that were
filled by existing staff
we've created new opportunities to use
our group 2 Correctional line Personnel
to do trained jobs such as one-on-one
precautionary watches and or using them
in control rooms that are not armed not
weaponed posts that has helped fill some
voids and allowed our correctional
officers to go home which we do want
them to have the chance to be with their
families we continue to explore other
opportunities to do that to advance the
burden of the work that we do but to use
people who are certified and trained to
do the work we're not going to do that
without providing appropriate
certification to orient people to those
posts
we've also taken that opportunity
because our population has decreased
over the last decade so significantly
that we shut down the second floor of
our Hancock building which was over a
hundred beds that reduced our security
post requirement by 14. now granted our
our vacancy rate has gone up so absent
that it would have been a worse
situation at our new women's prison
facility we have closed a 56 bed C3
General prison housing unit that reduced
Us by approximately four and a half
posts so we look for those opportunities
on Page Six
you'll see our trended of new hire
correction officer trainees uniform
staff terminations those are separations
that could be people being recruited by
other law enforcement to go to other
agencies such as state troopers liquor
enforcement and Municipal law
enforcement and then staff retirements
you can see that post the height of
covid we had a large departure that was
normal across the country
and in
an advanced news since October 7th that
new hire corrections officer training
number is now 12. so we've gone from 5
to 12 just since October that's a good
sign
we've engaged in numerous Recruitment
and Retention strategies we have
recruitment retention committees
Southern Tier that represent all
professions across our agency on the
Southern Tier we have the same in our
Northern organizations we participate I
participate as well as other members of
my staff in a correctional leaders
Association Recruitment and Retention
committee so we can learn from others
what they're doing in their Corrections
departments and what we can teach them
about what we're doing in our department
we've been very assertive in doing exit
interviews we've increased our employee
recognition both through their longevity
and their acts of Valor as well as acts
of kindness and any other acts in which
we can appreciate employees we have
enhanced our employee Communications
we've established actual employee
dedicated spaces some are still under
construction with the hope of being
finished I think this week to give
employees spaces without our
Correctional Facilities that feel
distinctly different than working in a
prison tier every single day and they
deserve that
we have created a Leadership Academy and
for employee development and that will
be deployed soon as well as Contracting
for Corrections employee specific
Wellness application that's for your
telephone not a software product for
your computer and we're um moving
forward with establishing a family
support organization and these are just
some of the things that we have
accomplished on page seven we can talk
about our recruiting strategies we've
had a dedicated part-time recruiting
corrections officer as well as
reassigned through a temporary voluntary
opportunity to recruit a sergeant to
work full-time to be dedicated to job
fairs school events security onboarding
and any other retention efforts we've
updated our marketing materials so that
we can show people that orange is not
the New Black we are the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections a law
enforcement organization full of
professionals and we have even in 2021
we went to 16 different job fairs and
speaking engagements virtual Roar in
person and from
um it says calendar year 2022 we
attended 91 and just looking at
September through today uh those are 27
different events that we've gone to
uh to teach people about what
Corrections is and opportunities to work
with us we started an introductions to
Corrections program course that's
offered at the Berlin High School on the
Milan High School and those have been
great opportunities for our North
Country Partners as well as we have a
standalone part-time corrections officer
Academy that doesn't involve having
retirees come back but that hasn't taken
off and we're exploring what we can do
to just make that a fully functional
opportunity for college students and
people who are unsure if this is that
profession they want to go in but we can
get them in and get them in a limited
post capacity and use them through a
part-time corrections officer Academy we
have increased and elevated our social
media presence because that is a reality
of how people learn about what's going
on in our world today but we do that
through factual presentation and we've
participated in local community events
even just recently we received the
number one Public Safety float in the
Concord Christmas parade and yes I was
the conductor of the correctional Polar
Express
uh We've streamlined our job website for
hiring and we're constantly looking at
opportunities to improve our hiring
process and keeping people engaged as we
move along
so we are fully committed to being a
solution to our solution and I hope that
those cards help you be part of our
Solution by recruiting someone to our
agency even if you want them in yours
send them to ours on page eight I
overview our medical and pharmaceutical
services that averages about 12.8
percent of our costs it's important to
recognize our Health Care Partners are
in the community and our community
health care costs are predicated by the
HealthCare Marketplace which that costs
more and it goes up when we look at the
center for Medicaid and Medicare
Services cost projection as a way to try
to understand where we're headed as a
state as far as those costs are
incurred to us for those that are in our
care and custody it is important to also
state that those who are incarcerated
are the only population who have a
constitutional right to the access to
health care and we take that seriously
we will continue to ask for the footnote
that has allowed us to go back before
the fiscal committee if we have not been
able to forecast expenditures so that we
can continue to cover those costs on
behalf of the State of New Hampshire
within our department
um we have had some significant
accomplishments there even though they
weren't on the first page our medical
forensics team has through the
partnership with the Department of
Health and Human Services
um been approved for a 340b purchasing
opportunity and we've targeted those
with our
um hepatitis C Drugs and we'll continue
to look for opportunities to expand
those because we can get Pharmaceuticals
as significantly reduced cost and that
is our plan is to provide services to
reduce costs but provide effective
treatment services
on page nine we go over operational
expenses that each cost perhaps more
than a million dollars that represents
about 9.4 percent of the budget food
should not be a surprise the Commodities
market around food has increased
gasoline has increased and the way we
get things to in thither is costing us
all more
current expense the things that we need
on a daily basis those have gone up
those numbers are there that is the
consumables we experience every single
day and this budget we use the
opportunity with the three percent
increase to really Target equipment that
is old and needed to be replaced five
years ago and that includes our fleet
vehicles for our probation parole team
our Industries team and our warehouse
team so we take a very targeted Approach
at our budget Target by trying to move
some things forward in the next biennium
budget that we've been trying to
accomplish over the last several and it
also includes improving infrastructure
in our Dental Suite because our dental
equipment is almost Beyond its aged use
and that will come up in the next
biennium budget and a dental chair is
very expensive surprisingly enough
um and we continue to look at the
automation of our Pharmacy
on page 10 I think everyone understands
that utility costs have increased and
are escalated I want to make it clear
that the Department of Corrections we
run small communities we run small
communities we have
numerous individuals living the same
space moving through water electricity
you name it we're using it our costs are
impressive this year and we don't expect
that to change in 2024 or 2025 included
here is a similar budget but no we have
not been afforded the opportunity to
have in the past in which we want to be
prepared as we move into 2024 and 2025
which would allow us to look for
Appropriations in that line moving
forward if so needed
in our office of Information Technology
expenses we have similar expenses but
multiple locations we have 10 district
offices for probation and parole I I
think it's important to recognize we
don't just run prisons we run 10
different district offices we want three
prisons three transitional housing units
a transitional work center and Partridge
and a pear tree you name it we have it
and it requires technological
infrastructure the department had made
grounds upgrading and um moving to what
we call Base technology we lost some of
that ground during 2020 and 2021 this
budget tries to continue to move that
forward because with reduced Staffing we
need to find efficient Technology
Solutions to help them be more efficient
in the work that they do while we
all right moving right along
page 11.
you'll find is our list of additional
prioritized needs we forecast that we'll
need more in our utilities line uh we'll
need more in our oit expenses
we have a fender Management Systems
electronic health records we need new
software for the in-service please
stands and training councils
requirements for law enforcement
training we'll need to meet those and
match those as our employees are under
those requirements as well as use of
fiscal Force reporting creating a
transparent fast and efficient
technological solution is part of
keeping our staff in the work site so we
can prove what happened and what did not
happen in addition to there's a portion
associated with our employee assistance
program those are small amounts and our
workman's comp those are an additional
prioritized needs as the agency wanted
to dedicate its Target to the things the
agency needed on a regular basis in to
move the agency forward
on the last page page 12 is a summary of
everything I just discussed in detail
for your reading pleasure it does not
include the parole board as they are up
next is my understanding with that I
will certainly Avail myself to any
questions you may have and thank you for
your time thank you very much
um quick question here on page three at
the bottom
you illustrate how prescription drugs
and and medical payments to Providers
from from 23 to 24 and 23 looks like
they're going up about 10 percent in
above for for prescription drugs and
about maybe 50 for medical payments to
providers
could you just briefly explain what's
driving that number one and number two
whether you've seen anything coming out
of Washington whether it's the inflation
reduction act or anything which are
designed to bring down costs uh
certainly prescription drugs and other
medical procedures that will
may change this number downward
uh certainly that is a fair question
part of the work that we have done is
changed the statute to cap our payments
in state law to Medicare plus 15 or
Medicare plus 25 depending on what type
of license provider you are the other
work we've done is we've worked with
director Lipman of our state department
of Medicaid and Medicare services to ask
the federal government to Grant a waiver
What's called the inmate exclusion which
means we cannot use Medicaid for
anything other than an inpatient
eligible stay while someone is
incarcerated and we've targeted what we
call our re-entry encounters 45 days
prior to release that we're asking
Medicaid to Grant a waiver so that those
people who are can be Medicaid eligible
can have those encounters to reduce
their reincarceration I reference
substance use disorder one of those
encounters is mat and moud with a
provider it's instinctual that if you
meet your provider face to face you're
likely to go see them again when they
are a ghost appointment and you've never
met them we have a disconnect Post
Release onto supervision trying to get
them to their providers so from the
federal perspective those Medicaid
waivers being asked for not just by New
Hampshire but other states are important
to the Continuum associated with
corrections as far as rates of payment
that's a tough question given the
current HealthCare Marketplace and their
shortage of staff were going to be
driven by that same shortage of Staff
but we're going to continue to look to
Medicaid and hopeful that the state
continues to reinvigorate Medicaid
expansion because that is a critical
resource and tool for Corrections and
those leaving corrections as a pathway
otherwise our state will be back in what
I call the insurance Cliff there is no
mechanism except for fee for service if
the state does not reauthorize Medicaid
expansion we as I mentioned have that
340b purchasing opportunity we are
looking to where we can expand that to
reduce the cost of pharmaceuticals but
when we look at treatments for HIV and
even hepatitis C and that being one of
the primary hepatitis see
infections that were fighting in
Corrections those are recurring costs
and are driven by the cost of those
Pharmaceuticals
as far as Switching gears to Corrections
Officers the number what are the number
of Corrections Officers you have on
staff today and then I realize that that
number is too low
uh what is the ideal for what is the
minimum number that you feel comfortable
with the state having to meet the needs
of your department the minimum number I
will feel comfortable would be somewhere
over the 500 Mark and right now we're
about 350. so filling the current funded
positions is our most critical Mission
once we fill those we'll come back and
ask for more and that's been my
presentation the whole time I've been
the commissioner of the department okay
hi hi
um I'm not going to ask you about being
conductor on the Polar Express it was
fun you're jealous
a little bit maybe just a little bit you
could have no money like Scrooge
I have a question about your
um
residence what's the right term guests
president it's fine some aren't leaving
yes residents thank you
um your resident population over time is
relatively stable declining increasing
so it has been declining for over a
decade we continue to monitor however
what's going on post covid with
Judiciary proceedings we've seen a
slight uptick in parole violations but
not a significant increase in new
admissions for new crime but we watched
that on a monthly basis
so I say that we were already short
staffed while it was going down so the
population decreasing allowed us to shut
down areas to help our short staffing
but our short staffing has increased
significantly since yeah I'm I didn't
mean to draw a connection between the
staffing issues to be clear that the
public watching understands them
probably a very important Point are
there operational cost differences
between
um
the men's facilities in Concord and the
ones in Berlin
significant significantly dramat okay
from the perspective that given a more
efficient
um design
in the Concord Men's prison we don't
know what gains we could make with the
existing staff so
yes and no the North Country facility
was designed in 2000 it was designed
clearly with efficiency in mind it was
also designed so if we needed more
housing units they could literally drop
them in like a Lego set the New
Hampshire state prison for men was
designed to wasn't designed at all it
was built over time and expanded upon
and is like a college campus which is
the most inefficient design for
Corrections Facility
thank you
great thank you very much thank you
foreign
good afternoon panel members my name is
Roger Phillips and I'm chairman of the
adult referral board with me today is
Jade Mackey who's director of operations
um for we submitted a uh basically a
two-page uh memorandum here with us the
support of request uh basically the our
budget
for the next Beyond biennium
excuse me
is uh without priority needs is
basically that's the same as it had been
in
2002-2003 uh I think it's a one and a
half percent increase basically for for
such things as interest travel costs
both in-state and out of state and and
really some minimal things like uh in
the event we needed a translator to have
a little money in the budget to do that
and then a little money in the budget to
do overtime our prioritized requests of
what I'm concerned with
um and and that the
the first one which doesn't require
legislative action and the other one
that that does require uh we we need
another person in the six-member parole
office uh another staff person a CCM
memorandum a request I think outlines
the duties of the CCM
what happens is that one person is
assigned the responsibility of preparing
parole packets it's a very uh
time-consuming intense project there are
only there are more than 23 different
categories a lot of information has come
from the chorus system uh so that we can
put that together so Pro board members
can
can make a decision as to whether or not
parole should be should be granted or
not
as best we Pro board members as best we
can try to predict future behavior and
that's really based upon the behavior of
the past and then the rehabilitation
that occurred within the prison system
so that what I am really concerned about
is that in this the person who who's
done this who does it now
it's just kind of a rough job it's
really labor of intensive and it's very
stressful
um and the two people who had done this
before left the parole office really
because of stress related reasons I
don't want
I want to prevent burnout and I think
it's extremely important to have this
position approved
the other positions really concern
legislative action
and that is when the a few years ago
2002 when they when
we change the
parole board from a nine member
essentially voluntary position to a to a
five-member uh paid position
um the the initial proposal was would
was that they were going to receive 30
000 per year that was reduced in
committee to to 20. we have really very
fortunate in having an excellent parole
office and an excellent parole board but
I'm really concerned that I want to keep
it that way I think it's really in the
best interest of New Hampshire to do
that there'll be a position that opens
up in 2023 hopefully that the person
who's there now would would be willing
to continue on but that's why we're
we're asking for that in increased
compensation and the other thing is that
I think there ought to be some
compensation for the vice chair of the
parole board
um and we also that asked that that made
ten thousand dollars more than the the
parole member uh and then the other
final thing for uh
statutory Amendment concerns that that
once in a while I think it happened
three times last in this past year that
we we couldn't put together a three uh
member board which is required for our
hearings because
of sickness or other reasons for
unavailability uh and we had to cancel a
a hearing day and so that I had proposed
that perhaps we could call those who had
previously served in that position to
fill to fill in and that I don't think
that would happen very often but it's a
really just a fifteen hundred dollar
item that we we propose for that if we
could just call on him and that would be
a lot less expensive than increasing the
number of of pro board members and I
think would be uh an appropriate
solution
so I think that's it for my five minutes
but but happy to answer any questions
all right thank you a couple couple
questions uh how
on average in a rough estimate does a
parole board
member work per week on proboard
activities well it it varies obviously
there we always have hearings on
Tuesdays and Thursdays so statute
requires we have 36 herrings we've we
normally have 45 or more per year
um
It Isn't So Much the hearing day time as
much as the preparation time for those
hairs especially for parole hearings
those those digital packets uh consist
of you know up to 60 Pages there's a lot
to read without even getting into the
through the other so
um it's not a 40 Hour Week by any means
but it's I would if it's really three
and a half to four days depending upon
whether they have to sit one or two days
that week
okay and the composition of the pro
board are attorneys
the composition is is they require two
attorneys also they require someone with
either law enforcement or Correctional
background also someone who is is in the
criminal justice field perhaps a teacher
or or something and then someone without
any official designation as a general
member okay right now we're fortunate in
in having a someone who is a retired
happen from
California of San Quentin who is
extremely knowledgeable in these matters
representing Correctional side we also
have uh uh someone who served as a
police officer who's now uh trading uh
in in criminal justice who teaches at a
college
and then we also have a retired surgeon
who's sitting on that I bought we have a
really a dedicated board and
um I'm pleased with with that's going on
but I want to make sure that we can
continue in that fashion
okay thank you
yeah
I'm good I just want to say thank you
for your service the parole board's been
through some ups and downs lately and
it's nice to see it on and up
well I I would be remiss if I didn't
thank the commissioner of the of the
Department of Correction and her staff
they've really been helpful and of
course I've had to call you and in in
August to find out how do I for this is
my you know I was disappointed in April
but so this is my first time with the
state budget
um so but it it's really nice working uh
uh with the state at the New Hampshire
and seeing people work together on a
common goal right I think it's working
great thank you very much we appreciate
your testimony thank you thank you hey
we are now going to take a uh three
minute recess and we'll be back with
foreign
yeah good afternoon I'd like to
reconvene the governor's budget hearing
up next is the Department of
administrative services
and good afternoon
hi I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of administrative services
and joining me is Cassie Keane I'm the
Deputy Commissioner and then I would
just note for the for the record that
um it's only half the room is employed
by the department of administrative
Services most of the rest of the people
in the room are administratively
attached to us
and then the only other people are
people who will soon work for us if I
get my way
so
um
we're a complicated agency and I like to
start presentations with
um a big giant sheet of paper which is
the org chart for our organization and I
and I do that because uh first of all
because if it's on a regular size sheet
of paper it's completely unreadable
um which says something about our
organization I think that if you put us
on a regular sheet we're unreadable
um we're a large complicated and diverse
agency and my presentation will talk a
little bit about why
oh who I think is where we start
um Sherry helped with the slides and She
Came Upon This who why what where that's
the organizing game if you're clever
you'll notice that in the presentation
um
we're a big diverse agency that's kind
of hard to describe to people and I I
let me start with something I do want to
I do in an interview
um typically Cassie and I are sharing I
do a final interview with everybody we
hire and part of what we do is talk
about the parts of the agency they don't
know we have eight major divisions right
um
and they run a gamut and uh the who who
we are a central Service Agency explains
who they are we start with Healthcare
the division of risk and benefits does a
lot of things right they do workers comp
they do lots of insurance
um but first and foremost and the thing
that's probably important to everybody
who has appeared today and will appear
tomorrow is we run a 500 million dollar
per biennium probably a little bit more
than that now health plan it is a
central component of our benefits
package and the benefits package is one
of the things that attracts people to
work for the state of New Hampshire it's
in large part why I'm here except my
Love of All Things administratively
serviced too but that's a big piece of
it it's a very complicated Endeavor and
it's something that is that that we do
accounting we do all of the state's
accounting the division of accounting
services is a function it's actually the
core of how our agency started
um to have a state budget and didn't
used to be a Governor's budget before
that and agencies would sort of spend
and then accidentally run out of money
people decided that was a bad idea we
came up with systems of pre-auditing and
encumbrances and and whatnot we pay 13
000 people every two weeks it's a lot of
people and a lot of pay and it's and
it's uh something that happens without
anyone noticing but is an enormous
amount of work constantly correcting
issues so somebody accidentally doesn't
get paid two million dollars one day
um although if it's me I invest them not
to correct that
um although I think I think I'd have to
give it back so that's not that's a work
but we you know we pre-audit a couple
hundred thousand payments every year now
running the state of New Hampshire is an
enormous operation there's a lot behind
the scenes the State Comptroller in some
uh States is an elected official here
it's an employee of administrative
Services
software the the Machinery the software
that runs everything that we do not the
state's Financial system but yes not the
state's budget system but yes not to say
its Personnel system but yes but
everything the state does is run by a
division that we call Enterprise
applications management occasionally it
used to be called fdm it's not just
financial data it's everything
and we do that facility management
um where there'll be a big piece of my
presentation in a slide or two and we
manage more than four million square
feet of office space two and a half
million ballpark in the city of Concord
Alone
um 90 buildings and that's uh Cameron
Tamaki who's probably somewhere where
I'm pointing
um and she's here because uh
um at some point out it gets complicated
and I will need her help in making sure
I don't say anything stupid
um which I might be too late for already
um purchasing we buy stuff the state
purchasing agent was one of the first
pieces of centralization in the state or
some also to speak in 1915 and the idea
that that we should buy things we should
we should procure competitively for two
reasons one is we procure competitively
so that we get a good price we get a
good product and so everybody's got a
shot of the state's business it's
taxpayer dollars and uh we have no right
we have no ability we have no uh
justification for making sure that that
a company that we trust and like gets
the business all the time everybody gets
a shot because it's taxpayer dollars
this is a very large and complicated
agency it gets more and more complicated
to the government Council sees some
contracts and they see more and more
every
um every time they meet they decide
there's another group that they want to
see and it ends up being a lot more work
personnel uh personnel has featured most
of today in this hearing and discussing
Personnel we we hire people we make sure
we hire people correctly we we make sure
we pay people correctly we make sure we
have policies and procedures we try to
work from people a lot of people are
retiring we try to recruit them as best
we can
um to fill in for the people retiring
there are now 14 unions in the state
employee relations was set up in the mid
70s when there was when there were two
one or two in the sca and then the
Troopers now there are 14 unions it's a
collective bargaining is a massively
complicated Endeavor both for management
and employees and the employee
Representatives it's a big piece of what
we do budget control you perhaps are
familiar with this Mr chairman
um and various sundry people around the
room are familiar but the state budget
office and our state budget officer is
point I think I'm pointing in the
general vicinity of who doesn't just
keep me from using yardsticks but um
manage the state budget process we do an
enormous amount of fiscal control for
the State of New Hampshire it's a
central part of our mission
and budgets go really well we enjoy them
but they go really well Public Works we
build stuff
design engineering construction we don't
build roads and bridges but we build
everything else and it's a massively
complicated thing that we do we have
engineers and Architects working for us
we have accountants who work for us we
have purchasing agents we have
budgeteers we have picked something we
got it
um and and I'm not mentioning all the
other little things we do on the big
giant org chart you see in front of you
there's a list of every nook and cranny
you can possibly imagine 10 or 15 things
I don't do I haven't talked about and I
probably won't today but we are like a
giant English muffin of state government
we have lots of tiny nooks and crannies
that the peanut butter if you like it
that way will melt itself into that's
how I like my English muffins
but it's a great complicated thing what
do all those things have in common it's
a little weird isn't it if you think of
everything that we do it's it's almost
like they just assigned everything and
couldn't think of where else to put to
this one agency but there is a rhyme and
there is a reason to what it does we're
Central Service Agency we don't regulate
Banks we don't sell lottery tickets we
don't limit the state's Medicaid Program
we don't run a prison none of those
people can do their job if we don't do
ours I believe that very strongly and
sincerely and that adds an ability to
what we do and that's a tremendous sense
of Mission to what we do we are that
Central Service Agency we're not a
central Service Agency we are the
central Service Agency
and that gets into why you should care
um
why you should care is not just because
we're the first Department
alphabetically
although that's a good thing too but
every agency relies on the processes and
procedures and approvals and whatnot
that come out of administrative Services
they're Central to their mission we're
aware of that every day and we try to
make sure that we keep it in mind every
day that we make differences big and
small no matter how big or small you are
um the state and its policy makers rely
on us on a regular basis to know the
answers to questions
um cherries had to run out of the room
two or three times from elected
officials asking her questions and doing
little minor research projects for her
for them
um she's doing for them
um but our we are a fiscal policy and
control organization that that um
that manages the laws the rules the
regulations of the state
um
we do a really good job I expect way too
much out of the people
who work at administrative services and
I get more than I expect
um because I have I I said two years ago
in this budget hearing all the smartest
people in state government work for me
and and then I said to somebody well or
will soon
and uh and I but I think it's true I
have uh it's a tremendous place to work
because of the tremendous staff but a
lot is expected of us and it's and and
we try to deliver every day despite
staff reductions I list here the staff
reductions 40 41 full-time staff from
2010 to 2017. we haven't lost much since
then we've been pretty stable
um but
um with no reduction in work in fact
increases in work I think right
um
uh I I don't say that just to Cassie but
um but particularly to Cassie
um
so day in and day out we balance the
needs that
are presented to us every every
commissioner every Governor every
legislator wants greater speed greater
flexibility greater operational ability
to do their job
um but we also have a statutory role as
the state's Chief and actually written
in statute this way the chase States
Chief fiscal and policy control officer
I think that that's technically me but
it's us as a as a unit and and it's a
responsibility that we uh relish and we
don't do it by spending a lot more money
than you think how do we spend the money
so this um this slide is
um
is occasionally somewhat misleading but
I'm going to show it to you and then
describe it to you you can divide our
budget into three bits and you have to
divide our budget into three bits
um I used to say that we are retiree
health and everything else we are a
department that does a lot of things and
we also provide retiree health
care to thousands of State retirees that
is not an operational thing that is a
that is a benefit that is afforded to
people and it's called under the law and
it's costs are our
um are something that that we have to do
so every time I talk about our budget I
will describe it that way
um
there is a central facilities Bureau
which I'm going to describe in a minute
which is functionally double counting
it's not an 8 million dollar increase to
the budget but it's a it's an internal
service allocation formula so I'm going
to set that aside and if you look at the
everything else part of the budgets um
75.1 million to 75.2 million to 75.5
million that's not a dramatic increase
why do I say that you need to exclude
the central facilities charges out of
everything else well if you turn to the
next slide It's a Wonderful chart on
page five
um
at least I like it
what do we do we are like doit we uh we
bill every agency every agency will talk
about how much money they're paying if
they're in a State Building how much
money they transfer transfer to General
Services it's listed in in the class
lines
um and they list how they do it and to
some extent we tell them what to charge
and they charge it in the past we uh we
allocated staff rather poorly
we took the most expensive guy and
charged him I said guy because it was a
guy and charged him to the most
expensive accounting unit
um we are the biggest accounting you
know we took the second most highly paid
person and charged him to the second
biggest accounting unit at some point
that's vaguely sort of kind of
allocating but not really like the one
guy the number two guy was charged him
an accounting unit where he he almost
literally one year didn't go into that
building but we were charging that and
it's just because they didn't do
anything uh differently but um
uh we challenged the division of plant
and property to come up with a better
way of doing it and some of this grew
out of one of the governor's challenges
to try to
um combine some of our facilities
bureaus in a way that made sense Court
facilities is a big Bureau is still
separate because they're they have a
governing structure that's different
because of Court accreditation and their
Court facility is a different branch but
um the other facilities are combined we
try to centralize facilities expenses
and and Karen and Andrea in particular
spent a lot of time going through our
charges and said what's centralized and
what's building specific and I'm going
to oversimplify think of uh think of a
utility bill for a bit for laundry gun
that's clearly a charge that should be
assigned to laundry again and only the
agencies in laundering
um
the state's electrician or one of the
state's electricians who does work in 20
or 30 buildings should not be assigned
that way he should be assigned centrally
and then Bill and then get billed out
build out so we put those Central
charges in an accounting unit called
Central facilities hence the Box Au
Central facilities
I use two pretend buildings well they're
actually real buildings
one is the Spalding building and one
other is the m s building which dra is
and
and so we allocate costs to those
buildings that that accounting unit will
reimburse the central facilities
accounting and Associate it's an intra
agency transfer and it and it's
essentially the equivalent of an
internal service fund uh to allocate our
costs the cost then in the Spalding
billing building building accounting
unit are the actual Spalding building
charges which are in this particular
case paid entirely by the Department of
Labor we then build a Department of
Labor because we Bill actual expenses in
this Arena and they then pay us
um for those charges on an annual basis
that's how that's done it's a more
accurate way of doing things because we
will be charging the money that is
actually spent and we will be allocating
the centralized
um expenses correctly instead of you
know there used to be a building I won't
say which one that looked like it had no
work done on it because we didn't assign
a staff member to it so it looked like
nothing was done there which just simply
wasn't true but just the way things sort
of worked out this way everybody is
paying their allocated share what's
actually happening in the business
on the other hand though that creates an
eight million dollar charge that that is
just circling and it's not it's not new
money it's allocated money and that's uh
functionally double counted so that's
why I exclude the 8 million in that so
if you turn the page
six I almost skipped a page
um what's our budget story
um if you have the color version you'd
notice that all of the who how what are
all in blue it's very clever actually
um so what's our budget story um you can
see it I have our efficiency budget here
our prioritized needs budget here
um I told you what's happening on
everything else
um uh I list here General funds and
other funding so you can see that both
for retiree health and for
um for the Department's operations
itself our uh our cost increase is is uh
minimal to say the least on General
funds we actually on the operating part
of the budget declined 2.3 percent on
retiree Health in the first year we
declined 6.4 percent
um
in the um second year of the of the
efficiency budget in 2025
um we're still down 0.07 and on retiree
Health we're up up three but there's
money in prioritized needs and I'm going
to get to that retiree Health we
budgeted don't exceed three percent
and if the costs are greater than that
even if you have to pay them stick them
in prioritizing so there is a cost in
prioritized needs if you turn to page
seven you can see how this breaks out
across the department
um by uh by division
and you can see that it's it's fairly
Equitable
um by division if anybody really wanted
to talk about a specific division we
could go into detail
I suspect nobody really wants to get
into that level of detail so I'm going
to skip to page eight although plenty of
time for that in questions and I'm going
to talk about what our prioritized needs
are that we talked about before
um the biggest one on the top line is
retiree health
um I'm really proud of retiree Health
um and the and the work that's done
there and the work that's done in risk
and benefits in fact our Deputy
Commissioner used to be the director of
Riskin benefits but don't tell her I
told you that
um
it's a very well run
division with an I on the bottom line
provide tremendous customer service but
when I on the bottom line and we pulled
a massive rabbit out of our hat a couple
years ago by moving toward medicated
Medicare Medicare Advantage I do that
every time Medicare Advantage and
dramatically reducing the amount of
money estate dollars that were being
spent on retiree Health that is not
going to keep happening and I've tried
to alert lawmakers for the last three or
four years that we have no more rabbits
and we have no more hats and costs like
Health Care are going to go up and
health care costs go up this is how much
health care costs go up we have some
residual from the the savings actual
expense on retired Health was 52 million
instead of a much higher budgeted number
and it's why the adjusted authorization
in fiscal 23 is 67.8
um we'll probably come in under that for
the same reason but we'll be at we'll be
at 64 million in fiscal 24.
um you know still analysis that comes in
and we do a we do a constant reanalysis
of that but the cost in the second year
are higher than that and total funds
it's 75 million and that would require
an additional 3.4 million in general
funds beyond our efficiency Target
um so you have that the other items here
we try to put as much of utilities into
um
into the efficiency budget as we could
we did a pretty good job of that but
utilities are
uh difficult shall we say this year
um you may have noticed that if you um
if you have heating oil at home
um I certainly did
um we have some additional general fund
needs for deferred maintenance around
and deferred maintenance just means the
state has an aging physical plant and we
don't do a great job we do a great job
keeping up with it as best we can but
it's aging and uh
um you know it's a request for 2.5
million in the first year and a little
less than that in the second year you
give me 10 times that amount of money I
would be able to spend
10 times that our deferred maintenance
list is hundreds of millions of dollars
and that's only because
we don't make it complete
because it's just you know you've been
in some of the buildings and say
government and um
some of them some of them the dra
building for example is quite nice
um some of them are less uh pristine
than that if you go in the main building
on the State House campus and we're
doing the best we can there are a
handful of position requests
um in our budget and um
um there are a couple worth highlighting
one is the the general fund requests
that are one is um an accounting
position that is essentially for federal
reporting there's some discussion about
federal reporting being done to go for
federal reporting being done at
administrative Services because we do
the federal reporting
um and it will be have to be done over
time all of the ARP and all of that
money will roll out over many many years
and um that um that is the biggest
general fund portion of that request the
second biggest on our list is uh is an
HR position we have a very large
complicated agency with 450 positions
many of them are part-time and one of
the smallest HR staffs in the uh in the
state
administratively attached agencies and
whatnot and um it is a it is a critical
position in addition to that
um
we've looked at redoing some of the
maintenance positions to create some
full-time positions our vacancy rate is
about is about 18 and
um
among full-time positions it's about 18
um it goes up and down a little bit
we've actually hired more than 100
people over the last 12 months maybe a
hundred and
115 118 I haven't looked at the numbers
that recently but at least 10 a month
um but we lose a lot of people too we're
up net a handful of positions but like a
lot of places we're just we're trying to
keep up with that but there's a lot of a
lot of churn that goes into that and um
and you know we have a small HR staff
and a small payroll staff and we're
trying to keep up so that's one of those
positions uh doit transfers is something
everybody has in in their prioritized
needs but um those are just some things
I wanted to I want to talk to you about
more generally
there are a handful of things I want to
highlight though on page nine where do
we go from here
um
there could be 20 things on this list
and and I struggle to make it fit on a
page
um particularly when Sherry did that the
weird V on the side that that lost me a
little bit of space
um one is the cloud people need to be
aware of that that that that's happening
the state's uh the state's enterprise
system is going to go to the cloud it
can't not we can't not update whether
it's with the existing vendor or new
vendor um it's going to be expect an
expensive Enterprise that is going to
have an impact on every Department
um and uh the only real alternative is
stagnation which isn't really an
alternative that's why I mentioned it
procurement standardization is something
we take for granted I know the governor
has a strong interest in in the notion
of people you know and stop shopping if
you want to sell tea cups to the state
for example
um you would need to be able to go to
one website and figure out how can I bid
on the teacup business or the tea cozy
business or the tea pot business I want
to I want a shot at that and for every
agency not just the Statewide contracts
and uh we're working jointly with dyt on
that but in addition to that the the
States state procurement committee
um
which Senator Carson has played a big
role in for about a decade
um but uh and goes back to the 2015-16
changes that created
um 21g and the rules there but
um one of the things that they've pushed
us on dramatically is standardized
procedures so departments aren't doing
things differently
uh best practice
um and uh and better reporting better
reporting in what we do a component of
that software upgrades will get us there
but there'll be a lot of little projects
that get there but procurement
um doing a better job on procurement and
taking into account
not just the needs of the agency
procuring but the needs of the people
doing business with the state and
wanting to do business with the state is
uh is going to inform a lot of things we
do
I want to talk about strategic facility
management
um and and I put in parenthesis here 90
buildings
um somebody mentioned to me that it
might be a good idea to kind of refresh
people's memory that there are a lot of
buildings this we're not talking about a
physical plant we're talking about the
state's ailing physical plant
I mentioned the main building and I
don't say that the market or laundry
going to say that to Market but there
are buildings that need a lot of work
and you walk around the bill I had a
meeting we have a lot of meetings in
room five in the annex which is a lovely
place but you forget
if you don't have a lot of meetings
there that it's awkward and so every
time we have a meeting with somebody
from out of state they spend the whole
or out of the state government they
spend the whole time like staring at the
ceiling and looking around at the pipes
in the 1970 paneling in the wall and the
green pipes that are exposed and
thinking where am I I actually had a
State Rep who said to me hey you know
what in the capital budget next year why
don't you make sure you've got some
money in it we shouldn't be bringing
people into a room like this and I
always think why we're in here every day
and we work here and and it's not good
enough for people to come in from to if
it's good enough for people to work here
it's good enough for everybody else on
the other hand it really does need a
little bit of work and a lot of the
buildings like that we need to do a
better job figuring that out the central
facilities Bureau is a step in that
direction in modernizing our operation
it's something Karen thinks about every
day
oh yeah she's there
um raise your hand oh there you go
um
thinks about every day we need to do
better long-range planning in particular
for the greater Concord campuses if you
think about our buildings it's a Sops
campus the old hospital campus there's
the downtown area there's the Hazen
Drive bit and the Smoky Bear Boulevard
bed and we need to do a better job
planning and we're working on on
efficiencies within our operation but
it's something the governor has been
supportive of from uh from before he was
sworn in about the notion that there are
significant deferred maintenance needs
of the state we need to be there
human resource support unit human Human
Resources is an issue with every bit of
state government not just doing payroll
correctly that's a really big thing
though doing payroll correctly and we
need to do a better job doing payroll
correctly and not having to fix
everything all the time but some
agencies are quite large we've met with
some of them today we're quite large and
have a much larger staff than others
some are quite small and we're going to
talk to some of them in a few minutes
um and you know if you have 3 000
employees you probably have a slightly
larger HR operation than
um than say we met with Department of
Agriculture earlier with 40 people they
know I'm an HR person they don't have a
CFO there are a lot of things they they
can't do which means there's a different
level of service knowledge expertise Etc
we created an HR RSU to answer the
question centralized or decentralized by
saying both big agencies do a good job
without having to pull people away from
them and take everybody and ship them
off somewhere but small agencies can't
and we want to build safety in numbers
and and create that and we work very
hard by combining
resources to create to create critical
mass and provide better service for
people we're doing that in the HR SEO we
want to keep doing it more directly in
that and um and we probably want to do
more with payroll along those lines
mostly though I want to say to you that
everything we service every agency and I
said before I'm very proud of that it's
everything every other agency do ends up
affecting us you go to discussion with
Justice about rent payments
um guess who takes care of the facility
gets who signed the lease for example we
sign the lease we take care of the
facility we're going to manage that
facility
um we might need a position to help
manage that facility if we buy the
Granite State College building for
example the Department of Education is
not going to put
Facilities Management people in its
budget at least they're not supposed to
but they're uh
um and we would manage that if somebody
builds a new computer system liquor has
been and it's been for a few years
building a giant new computer system and
I think I uh I think we have as many
admin services staff hours on that
project as our liquor of sapphire
Arizona project and and so what happens
is everybody's priorities suddenly
become ours and upend our business and I
would just ask you as you go through the
budget hearings and budget discussions
on an ongoing basis
remember that and it's not that it's not
that we're opposed to that it's not that
we mind that
um we we relish it and that's what we're
here for but but we we would like to
know and you know I'm thinking of a
project two years ago where it made it
all the way through the budget and then
somebody called me up and said by the
way you understand that that
um they're giving that to you to
administer and it and it took um it
doesn't matter which project right now
um but it could have a p and an F in it
but it um but it took an enormous amount
of time away from people who were
already fully committed and if we're
going to plan ahead for things like that
we need to be able to plan ahead for
things like that with that
anybody there ask a question
please thanks gets going on uh yeah just
a high level question uh many many
questions which we'll can deal with
offline but the um
the assumptions that you use to to make
the budget now you as you said you're
responsible for purchasing procuring
real estate your other State's real
estate or the landlord basically you
provide heat air conditioning other fuel
uh you pay and provide Health Care all
at a time when we have record-setting
inflation real estate prices have gone
through the roof uh we've had record
fuel costs and income uh in the state
that you're competing against is
skyrocketing
what assumptions did you put into what
those prices
of goods and services real estate uh
fuel into the budget are you
without giving I don't need specific
numbers now but are you saying things
might get better things are going to say
the same are you planning things getting
worse I think the assumptions we use are
relatively conservative we we you know
over the years as a balancing act right
I don't use Healthcare as an example
um
if you don't budget enough money for
health care it's a catastrophe and we
people remember 15 and 16 there were
sort of huge issues around retiree
health if you budget too much money for
healthcare everyone's mad at you because
you have budgeted money that could have
been used for something else and so over
the years we've done a significant
amount of refining and you know Cassie
can talk to you about um we'll talk to
talk a little bit about about seagull
and and some of the how we sort of
refined what we do on and let's use
Healthcare as an example
came with the same Healthcare consult
firm for about
since we became
care and we we
um every cycle do budget working rates
we start in April before the budget year
and then we refine those numbers later
in the year based on what's our
experience well how how's our enrollment
going and our experience is made up of
who goes to the doctor who goes in the
hospital how many readmissions those
kinds of things but also what's going on
in health care and what what are the
inflationary factors so we're constantly
revisiting the numbers to try and refine
them and since I've been working in the
department which is about 10 years now
we have worked really hard to
um to not build in as much cushion to
address what Charlie was saying which is
that you need enough to to take into
account growth and health care costs but
when you have budget too much it hurts
other programs and people in state
government so we work with our
Healthcare consultant all the time to
revisit the numbers and to revise them
so that they come in as sound as they
can be and we've been very very
successful
I think along those lines it's it's I
mean it's a good question so on you know
pick an area you know our utilities
numbers
um uh Karen and Donnie Perrin will have
sat down you know both having been a
former energy managers uh and kind of go
over what's happening in the market what
do we want to look at in budget and what
are we doing in electric what are we
doing on gas what are we doing on the
various components of it and and try to
predict
can we predict so we did a really bad
job two years ago predicting right
because
um if you thought inflation was going to
be eight and a half percent
um good for you
um but I didn't
um and right now you know what are we
guessing you know uh Gary lunetta and
procurement is doing supply chain
analysis um based on industry numbers
every month and guessing but
you know we had a salt contract where we
saved 36 percent we were all proud of
ourselves and the next year went up five
um because and and by the way
um we did an equally good job then we
got a good price it just went up I think
that what we're thinking broadly is that
inflation is leveling off but nobody
dare think it's ending and
um
like from a price standpoint I heard the
governor talking about a recession and
possible recession this this morning and
I thought
in my head this is terrible right I'm
thinking what's it going to do the
prices it's not going to help them hurt
I'm not even sure anymore and what's it
going to do for recruiting in terms of
jobs and I and it's sort of where we are
operationally
okay great sure this is probably a
combination of a more of a comment than
a question but um Department of
Corrections when they did their
presentation how to comment or proposal
for House Bill 2 from for their
utilities asking for it to be
non-lapsing between the biennium and
then
um if it fell short to have
um money appropriated from funds not
always appropriated and I just wanted to
add that in the department of
administrative Services budget they have
that same language that's usually built
in every year on utilities so I just in
case those that didn't know
um what correction was proposing is
something that administrative Services
already has in their budget and I think
it was probably safe to say is that in
terms of the efficiency budget
um it was up to the targeted three
percent and the prioritized needs is
what brought it to a more
estimated number
um I look over to Karen all of that and
some
great thank you very much commissioner
thank you thank you I think I don't get
to leave
like to invite the advocate for special
education
hi
I believe the record uh my name is
Charlie arlinghaus the advocate for
special education who has not been
selected yet is administratively
attached to the Department of
administrative services
um
I was going to say I know a little bit
about special education but um I don't
want to go there
um there's a placeholder in the budget
for you like I said the position has not
been filled yet my understanding is it's
likely I'm not involved in the filling
of it but that's likely to happen in the
next month or two what would happen is
we would then work with the new Advocate
to fill
um to fill positions the budget if you
look at it is actually modeled to an
extent on I don't oversell this but to
an extent on the on the child advocate
but at a smaller number
um and it is the it's the amount of
money essentially in the appropriation
and it's uh uh the I think the vision of
it is uh two to four people
um and and in the first year or two
they're gonna figure out their path as
that was easy thank you
conservation land stewardship program
we might be a Nook or a cranny I'm not
sure this is the first time CLS is going
through the biennial budget process that
said CLS continues to do what it has
done for its nearly three decades of
existence with little change
in short the CLS mission is to protect
the state's interests and conservation
Investments it is made the majority of
land conservation projects occurred
through the land conservation investment
program lcip that ran between 1987 and
1993.
after this acquisition phase ended the
first iteration of CLS was set up and
staffed in 1994.
the lcip was considered such a
successful Endeavor than 2000 the more
familiar l-chip was created
each year CLS prepares an annual status
report for the Council on resources and
development cord
this document found on the CLS website
succinctly explains the program RSA 162c
governs court and includes clcip
properties the main source of funding
for CLS comes from the endowment
administered by cord that was set up in
1993 to provide for the Perpetual
stewardship of the lcip conservation
interests in front of you are two charts
that illustrate the makeup of CLS the
first chart articulates the parts of
lcip land conservation investment
program which was the original program
the second chart illustrates the entire
CLS program
that includes the responsibilities that
CLS has taken on through memorandum
agreement with New Hampshire Fish and
Game and the division of forest and
landsat dncr these moas provide the
other sources of funding that support
CLS CLS does not receive General funds
the majority of these properties CLS
Works primarily with are conservation
easements these are privately owned
properties in which the state holds a
legal interest and has a primary
stewardship responsibility
CLS also works with 78 municipalities
that participated in lcip as well the
municipalities hold the primary
stewardship responsibility for these 250
plus conservation properties
we refer to the overarching function
that CLS performs as stewardship and
monitoring the responsibility is to keep
an eye on each property to ensure that
the conservation conservation values the
state invested in remain intact we do
this through regular Communications with
the landowners and municipalities in
conjunction with site visits
and lastly I would since we're a new
agency I'd just like to thank the Das
fiscal and HR folks for being so
welcoming and helpful
to us as a new entity so happy to take
any questions and
you're as long as you can just talk
about some of your challenges maybe you
had agencies and departments come in
here and talk about that the workforce
is their largest challenge we have
others that uh affording the the proper
amount of technology is their major
Challenge and things like that what what
are yours going forward do you see that
you're going to have to address as far
as a budgetary standpoint probably the
the single largest one is we our sources
are funding are very limited and uh
uh we keep bumping up against what we
can draw respect
respectfully from the endowment which is
5.5 percent is a Max on a rolling
12-year 12 quarter uh average and
um
that we just have to figure out the sort
of functional challenge is
the 78 municipalities with their 250
properties and the 200 land owner or
properties that have landowners are
constantly changing
um every property changes ownership or
managers
and so we have to keep on top of that
just
um because a new owner
is
um
we need to get to know them they need to
get to know us
um
a good landowner what we really the most
important thing we do is to uh
strive to have very good landowner
relationships because if we have those
our work goes well
so um oh and we can use a new car
and that I haven't figured out but uh
so if things are quiet it tends to mean
we're doing our job well because really
it's to
um prevent
problems from occurring solve them from
the bottom up whenever we can
thank you but that answer that get it
down Okay I uh so I traveled the
countryside with Steve the other day
um weeks ago and his interest in the
land and um
um knowledge of his job is tremendous
um the car wasn't great I I agree with
that
um but um you know for state car it
wasn't bad
um
I think you're the only person to have
ever visited every single property am I
correct in that statement correct yeah
so uh that in and of itself is
impressive
um your transfers from other agencies
declined from about 68 Grand to about 35
Grand in the second year of the budget
and and walk us through that because I
think broadly speaking that's a
challenge we might want to look into yes
it is a challenge and uh and we had the
opportunity to chat in the car a little
bit about it
um basically uh force and lands as part
of dncr
um we our contract was the for the
properties south of Route 2 we'll say
you know from Lancaster to Berlin and
they have acquired very large 20 uh uh
Connecticut Lakes 143 000 Acres a number
of 20 25
000 Acre Properties
and they are sort of at a staffing
capacity and they need to get some other
staff help for some other things
and so they kind of came to you should
get it in their words but I think they
came to a a Tipping Point where they
said we really need someone to look
after all of our easements north of
root 2 which tend to be commercial
forests
um by and large
and so they said let's just have one
person do all of our conservation
easements along with the other
um
assignments that this person will get so
that means that contract goes away that
means we push up against our endowment
limit that the other made the major
portion of our program and
um what I
uh conversed with uh commissioner
arlinghaus about was is there may either
we have to find a new contract
um or
Stephen retires and and they create a
different model I'm very serious I mean
they're you know it something will have
to be figured out the good news is
um we have
a couple years to figure it out and um
I'm all ears for any ideas on anything
and uh
um so that it sounds to me like the
issue is we have to either solve a
thirty thousand dollar problem
um a few years from now
um or get rid of the one guy who knows
what he's doing yeah
which doesn't sound to me like the best
option well no you ask my partner and uh
I I am very fortunate to also have a uh
a young 31 year old um person who joined
in June of 2021 who's just uh
technologically
much Superior to myself and very hard
worker and so um teaching her everything
there is to know so I am replaceable
very good thank you thank you very much
in the housing appeal board
invite you to come up and give your
so do I need to hit the button nope it's
all the red lights on you're good all
right fine
well
um my name is Elizabeth Fisher I am
chair of the New Hampshire housing
appeals board I'm here with our very
capable Clerk Elizabeth Menard
um so there are two elizabeths at the
house new pills board there are also two
other employees one is Edward Rogers he
is a licensed land surveyor and engineer
and
um also our last board member is
um
Michael class and some of you may know
Michael because he's worked for the
state for a few years he's an attorney
we were formed in 2020 through some
legislative action RSA 679.
um I was appointed in July of that year
and then through some budget issues and
the rest of it actually
opened the agency over Johnson Hall in
October of 2020. we took our first
excuse me we hired Elizabeth and she
started right after Christmas
of 2021 and we opened our doors on 20 in
January of 2021 prior to that we
literally were shown our space
and the next day I brought in pens and
paper and then about three weeks later
some deaths showed up and so in a very
short time period we were able to uh put
the agency together but I want to at
this point Thank the folks from
administrative services and the rest of
the State of New Hampshire who um
literally held our hand and brought us
up to speed
um I was one board member the chair at
the time Greg Michaels neither of us had
ever worked for the State of New
Hampshire and we brought Elizabeth back
from California thank you very much his
New Hampshire gal but brought her back
and so we were truly clueless on all of
this how this all worked and I have to
tell you as a native of New Hampshire
um I have daily impressed with the
quality of the folks that work for our
state and and I want to thank these
folks here as well as anybody else who
ever got a phone call from me or anybody
or Elizabeth and and answer the call
call explaining in detail what it is
that we needed to do
so as I mentioned earlier with three
board members we have a clerk we
function very similar to Superior Court
and so our clerk is the face of the
agency
anytime there is an appeal let me
explain what it is that we do if there
is an appeal that a town or city has
denied some aspect of a planning zoning
historic district anything involved with
housing
application in a city or town and they
are denied whatever it is that they they
have asked for or a piece of it they
have two choices within 30 days they can
either go to Superior Court or they can
come to the house and appeals board
and So within those 30 days they file an
appeal it's very inexpensive for them to
do that within our legislative mandate
and also our rules of which Elizabeth
was very involved with writing that was
an interesting process that we went
through
they can choose to hire an attorney or
they can come pro se
and appear before our board we're under
legislative mandate to within 90 days of
the file of that appeal that they have a
hearing and that within 60 days
following that that they actually get a
decision out of us if either party is
unhappy with that they have the
opportunity within 30 days to to appeal
it directly to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court the beauty of that is if any of
you are familiar with housing
development it's a long hard pull to try
and get
projects across the state in any
Community
to be approved and there are many many
cities and towns in the state that do it
very very efficiently but there are some
towns and cities that struggle with that
and so we are an alternative to Superior
Court in that we have a short window in
which they have to that we need to
respond and often and this is not a dig
at Superior Court but often it can be
nine months before you even get your
initial hearing and then you get ready
to go to court so we think that um what
we're doing is a service to the property
owners of the state and also the cities
and towns
um this is our first budget process
um the first one I think came out of the
governor's office
um and um through the legislative
process and then even the revision of
that because at one point we were
defunded
was through the legislative process and
so again I want to thank everybody from
the division of administrative services
for helping us understand what we needed
to do the numbers that you see before us
I think are pretty Bare Bones 99 of them
have been provided to us by the various
state agencies that we depend on to
fulfill our mission and and our
legislative mandate
um
if you have questions with regards to
our orders and our decisions we have a
very robust uh um website in which once
the 30 days have passed from when we've
made a decision we put all of our orders
up on on the website and so they're
available to the communities to read to
the anybody who's interested in this and
we take a lot of time to write these
orders and try and use them as an
educational opportunity to explain to
people just what the rules and
regulations are with regards to housing
and Housing Development one last thing
is uh often people will say well you
know you're a super zoning board or your
super planning board we're not we take a
look at what your rules are in your
community and we act accordingly so I'll
answer any questions that you might have
sure I have a lot but it's it's um
your agency is one where where it's one
where uh it's obviously taking a lot of
scrutiny they're not decorating but the
what you do with land and Land
Development and especially the need for
Workforce housing and and things like
that which have come to the Forefront
of of state government and certainly a
politics in the state of New Hampshire
um I just want to be sure that I mean
you you came you were you were born in
an area of covid and came into being in
the state in that in that time frame uh
going forward though looking more
towards a uh hopefully a more
uh calmer time yeah do you believe you
have
the proper resources in this budget to
meet everything that's going on now and
then going forward into the next
biennium
we think that we do the challenge is
that we never know what's going to come
through the door with regards to cases
um we were doing some statistical
information and as I said we opened in
January 2021 and for that first year we
had
um somewhere in the K in the line of 29
cases okay
um we've already surpassed that now and
so more and more entities are
recognizing that this opportunity exists
and are taking advantage of them now
some cases take longer some cases take
shorter time because it might be less
complicated
um so we hope that that is the case we
have within our budget some funds that
if we needed to bring in some additional
Legal Assistance or engineering
assistance then we can do that and so
we'll try very very hard to make sure
that we fit within that now if all of a
sudden you know the floodgates open and
there's all kinds of stuff that is
coming through the door then I suggest
we'll have to have another conversation
but at this particular point in time
we're a pretty well-oiled machine
Elizabeth Keeps Us in line we all know
what we need to do and um I think we're
pretty uh efficient in what it is that
we do how do you provide for your legal
services or additional Legal Services
you contract out at this point we have
not had to do that
um we the legislative mandate there is
the opportunity for recusal should I
have a conflict then I need to
um I don't I don't do but the Supreme
Court identifies somebody to take my
place it's the attorney needs to recuse
themselves because they have a conflict
or whatever the issue is or the engineer
does that so we have some folks who have
been vetted by the Supreme Court and
um they identify who it is that's going
to come on to the case and so those
folks have paid 75 a day in order to do
this and so in many cases they are doing
it for the good of the community in the
good of the state it's certainly
nobody's making any money in this deal
but we try very very hard to make sure
that you know we can do it within a
budget so I'm comfortable with it but
again if all of a sudden we start
getting you know three cases a week then
we're going to have to have a
conversation but at this particular
point in time we're pretty comfortable
with it okay good thank you
foreign
state has a lot of adjudicative bodies
that I'm sorry the state has a lot of
adjudicative bodies that don't have
space yeah where do you hold your
hearings
what do you what where do you hold your
hearings we hold our hearings in um
Johnson Hall in room 315 and
um room 315 is a uh space that is
available for
um pretty much anybody who is tied to
the state of New Hampshire
um we outfitted it
um the office of child advocacy gave us
a table I went over to the barn and the
farm and we got some tables and chairs
and those kinds of things but the space
is available
there is a calendar that folks can go on
to and Reserve that space getting in and
out of the buildings a little bit of a
challenge sometimes for the different
agencies but the space is available and
it's used
do you
ever think that
um
this comes up a lot with a with a bunch
of people who are who are you happen to
have a hearing space that you shared
room in your building but there are a
bunch of people who sort of um
um are vagabonds if you will and uh
probably six six or seven different
boards
um
how often do you use the space do you
think there would be obstacles to being
co-located with other
bodies other boards that have have to
have hearings and sharing the rooms to
come to come to use that well no what if
we moved you let's just say for the sake
of argument somebody once decided that
that building could be made better
oh it seems unlikely yeah um well you
know that's in all honesty that's up to
you folks to make that to make that
decision
um I think that there's certainly
opportunity if some of the Vagabond
groups that you're talking about would
like to come and use a space you know we
reserve Tuesdays and Thursdays for our
hearings
um but that leaves Monday Wednesday and
Friday for folks to be able to use that
space and also if we have don't have a
particular hearing or only have a
hearing in the morning then they can
certainly contact the um the clerk and
we'd be more than happy to to give the
space up part of the challenge was and
why we ended up going up to 315 was that
once covid
um when Once the state opened it up
again we had space about the size of
this area rug in order to hold our
hearings and so if you start to have
parties that come in in the six or seven
people and we do have them we also have
have some visitors people are sometimes
curious about what it is that we do and
so we'll have folks who come in and
there'll be four or five other people
from different communities that are
going what is this happen it feels bored
and and what is it that they do we also
um
uh use the WebEx system and so we often
have many many people that watch the
proceedings and whatever the schedule is
that's clearly onto our website
Elizabeth takes care of all of those
details
so
I just had a
sort of just your resources
um I think you said statutorily you have
90 days that you have to have a hearing
and then you have decisions within 60.
um are you are those deadlines
reasonable for you or you know you said
you are very efficient you know group
but it was that is that well I think
they are
um um and part of it is the makeup of
the board
um all three of us this is not our first
opportunity in dealing with land use and
so
um we're blessed in that both with Ed
and and Mike
um the attorney and the engineer they
have uh been in that business for a long
time I also come from uh I'm second
generation developer my dad was a
developer and I've done quite a few
projects and so this is not a new
um Avenue for us and as we've gotten to
know each other we sort of fairly
quickly get a feel for where this is
probably going to go and then it's a
matter of making sure that we're
following the statutory requirements but
also the statutory decisions that have
been made with regards to land use and
then always looking back at What's
called the certified record which is the
story about how the folks got before us
and what it is at the Town our
municipality did so it's a little tight
and I'm always kind of cracking the whip
that you know we've got an order due
um next Monday right next Monday and so
you know we'll finish that up this week
and then Elizabeth will do her magic and
it will be issued
so it's tight but we get it done and you
know you
you give us another 60 days we'd
probably take it but it just keeps
things moving along and it allows people
to be able to make decisions as well
because time is money yeah all right
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony thank you thank you
okay I'd like to invite the office of
the child advocate
good afternoon good afternoon my name is
Cassandra Sanchez I'm the child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire and I
have with me today program specialist
Karen Kimmel
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you about the office of the child
advocate which I will refer to as the
office moving forward
please allow me to give you a brief
update on the office
which will give you context to the
workload and therefore the resources
needed
the office is in its fifth year of
existence it was established as an
independent and impartial oversight
agency in 2018 in response to multiple
gaps of infunctioning of the child
welfare system
culminating in tragedy in September of
2020 chapter 21v was established
replacing RSA 170g 18 codifying the
office of the child advocate in its own
statue and expanding the mandate to
provide oversight of all state provided
funded or agreed upon services for
children that fall under the executive
branch
the new statute also mandates that we
visit children who are in state custody
and assist them when needed further
under RSA 21v2 the child's Advocate
ensures children receive timely safe and
effective services
strengthens the state by collaborating
with parties on cases under review
ensures children receive dignified
treatment examine system-wide services
to make recommendations advises the
governor legislature agencies and the
public on how to improve Services
reviews policies procedures and practice
to contribute to their Improvement
the child Advocates mandate further
includes investigating complaints
providing assistance to a child
Consulting with policy makers providing
information and referral services
performing educational Outreach and
advocacy and reviewing facilities where
children may be placed this broad
mandate empowerizes empowers authorizes
and equips the child advocate to
advocate for children with concerns
about unmet needs
in January 2022 the office adopted a new
mission to lift up children by promoting
Equitable and effective reforms that
meet the best interests of all New
Hampshire children and strengthen public
confidence and accountability in the
state systems that support Children and
Families
current operations include seven
full-time employees and one temporary
part-time employee position
with the fiscal year 2023 operating
budget which is 824
274 dollars
the office of child Advocates most
recently reporting year ran from October
2021 to September 30th 2022 the
following data speaks to the volume of
work managed in the office we received
and reviewed
258 incident reports which is a 31
increase from the prior reporting year
I received reviewed responded to a
monitored 318 citizen complaints
facilitated three System review mappings
of critical incidents with teams of dcyf
personnel we reviewed 120 critical
incident reports and completed
approximately 50 summaries which include
child apparent deaths missing children
near-death incidents and domestic
violence
in June of 2022 we started producing
monthly data reports to the oversight
Commission on children's services
and since July 1st 2022 we participated
in over 25 events of Outreach education
we are attached to the Department of
administrative services for
administrative purposes only apart from
certain Personnel matters we still
conduct the majority of our
administrative responsibilities such as
Recruitment and hiring purchasing
inventory budget development and
training to name a few given the extent
of administrative duties the office is
responsible for two out of our seven and
that part-time staff spend a significant
amount of time focusing on these duties
this leaves five full-time and one
part-time staff dedicated to other
duties within the mission and mandate
well we have been remarkably productive
we need additional positions to meet all
mandated obligations
the office has identified a need to add
a full-time public relations
representative and training officer for
fiscal year 24th one of the goals
established through our strategic
planning process is to expand public
knowledge of the office as a resource to
understand and advocate for children and
the best child serving system
food is within this role would include
extended Outreach efforts via an active
social media presence an enhanced
website additional education efforts
through Community partner sites and
trainings offered about the Mandate of
the office of the child advocate state
agencies policy and procedure and
available community-based programs
much of the world has shifted to
utilizing technology for information
gathering and sharing youth especially
currently the office of social media
accounts and website but given the
limited resources within the office it
is difficult to keep these up to date
and to offer creative forms of Outreach
such as educational videos
this position will ensure the office is
known as a resource and recognized as
well as assist children families to
navigate systems most effectively
so sorry I mentioned that already there
um there have been requests for
additional Community Partners by
additional Community Partners to attend
meetings for further Outreach and
explaining of a mandate of the office
but given the high workload and current
Staffing much of these have had to be
scheduled for 2023.
the office currently has a legal
secretary part-time position which we
would like to extend to a full-time
position for fiscal year 24. the primary
responsibility for this role is to
manage data entry of all the incidents
we receive including restraints and
seclusion
dcy of compliance with reporting
incidents commenced in December 2019 in
2021 we received 1909 where as I
mentioned in 2022 we received 2508.
which is that 31 increase the volume is
beyond capacity for other positions
within the office the mandates or
surveil incidents will go unmet without
this position with the increase in
critical incident reports received is
impossible to review and enter all
immediately which decreases our capacity
to provide timely relevant data analysis
for system support and reform
more hours for this position would
optimize the data analysis and further
support the mission of the office
in 2021 the office worked with the
Department of Information Technology and
Department administrative services to
enhance our ability to use and format
Salesforce that is our our third
prioritized need there
we use the Salesforce platform for case
management and data collection
concurrently
and with this we monitor for Trends and
make recommendations to improve systems
our sales force case management system
is an unfinished pilot of the State of
New Hampshire New Hampshire Enterprise
that must now be enhanced for purposes
of usability and generation of
meaningful data including measuring
outcomes of the office's work this
product is intended to better capture
data
allowing for consistency and data entry
and optimizing substance of reporting at
the end of the project the office will
be able to provide more context in
reports and system reform efforts
system improvements will also allow for
better ability to track state agency and
child serving agencies compliance with
contracts laws and policies and
procedures
without this enhancement the office will
have delayed or insufficient data
capture and less timely investigations
related directly to Children's current
safety and well-being the office will
also have decreased capacity to measure
outcomes and provide timely relevant
recommendations for system support and
reform and RFI was put out in the fall
of 2021 and our queue process was
completed in the spring of 2022 looking
at the most minimal version to meet the
office's needs and it was determined the
minimum amount needed for that project
is two hundred thousand dollars which
would be a one-time project
the office was created for oversight the
importance of which elevates in times of
economic and social crisis there is an
abundance of evidence demonstrating
societal stress paralleling stress on
state Social Services
this is a point of highest risk and
liability for State systems both the
children and the state benefit from a
focus on prevention by accessing
services within the community and an
independent eye on overwhelmed systems
to ensure best outcomes for children
to meet this Mandate of RSA 21v
equitably in a timely manner the office
is requesting a prioritized budget of
one million two hundred and five
thousand for fiscal year 24 and 1
million 27 000 for fiscal year 25.
thank you and please let me know if you
have any questions thank you
yeah
um the question is on in this handle you
mentioned that from the last the last
year from October 1st 2021 to September
30th 2022 you had 2508 incident reports
how does that Stack Up historically and
is there I guess my assumption would be
that that number is low because during
that time it was covered people kids
were locked down they weren't in school
they abused it some were facing couldn't
be visibly seen and reported uh since
we've come out of that and because
you're back in school have you started
to see an uptick of that and so really
that 2508 number historically where has
this been and where do you think it's
going so there's not too much historical
data unfortunately because the data
capture
um with the division began in 2019 so
they don't have extremely extensive
historical data but what we do
understand also is that there are some
limitations to the the compliance and
the reporting
um so we do foresee there being more
than than what we have here we have
programs that replace children out of
state and although they are contracted
with our state to provide reports for
all incidents the ability to oversee and
ensure their compliance is a bit more
difficult to do than in-state programs
so we may be missing some of those in
our data capture and we also at this
time do not receive any incidents of
um restraints our seclusions in schools
specifically and that would be another
area where we would have the ability to
oversee and if we did receive that data
we would have a great uptick because we
do understand there are a lot of
restraints and seclusions happening in
schools across the state okay and uh on
your
we mentioned when you illustrate the
current budget budget requests the 810
966 figure that does not include the
additional prioritized needs is that
correct
yes that is correct okay
that's just that's your that would be
your operating budget for or your
efficiency budget for correct now that
is what the efficiency budget would look
like yes separate from um the final
amounts of the prioritized budget are on
hi
um
you have so I'm thinking about the
incident reports and to what extent are
people reporting to you or people
reporting to HHS at some point so we are
to receive the same reporting that HHS
receives so they are there are reports
that are generated and sent to them and
we are linked to their system to receive
those reports
um through an email chain so we do
receive the same reports that HHS does
we are working to ensure compliance
internally so we do have regular
meetings with them to talk about what
they are receiving and ensuring that we
have the same number of incident reports
that we also have in our are able to
review internally oh okay so this is in
addition to this is it's this the
the same report so to speak I mean in
theory if the system works just so
they also received 2508 reports correct
okay thank you that's helpful
um my only other question is the
the I forgot what it's called now even
though I just testified special
education Advocates yes
um
and and I realize it's a different thing
but to what extent is their overlap
so I believe the overlap for the special
education child advocate would be for
the complaints that we are receiving
from families in regards to concerns for
their child's IEP not being met at this
time we do field those calls and we
refer them out to other agencies that
can address their concerns because that
is not the specialty within our office
and with a change in mandate given the
creation of the the new office that has
shifted for us so we it would reduce
some of our complaint calls
um but the they would not necessarily
have the overlapping view to look into
the restraint and seclusion unless it
was in some way related to the child's
IEP where our view of the child is the
holistic view of the child and would
include a child in a general education
classroom that may be restrained or
you're struggling in some way that we
would be taking a look at what their
behavioral outcomes are and what the
behavior management plan of the school
is
to where do you refer those calls today
a lot of them refer to the parent
information center
um some of some we refer to Legal Aid
Services
um and some of the families we are just
educating on the process of special
education sending them back to the
school district
those are probably
pick is better than referring them back
to them yes Sam
good okay thank you I'm yeah I'm done
okay next and and final for today on the
agenda is a New Hampshire State
commission for the Aging my
understanding as of this morning is that
the person who would testify as the
tested positive for a virus of some sort
which I won't name
and uh has decided that it would be in
our best interest for her to send
written testimony and not to come into
the office I can present her written
testimony but I don't think I need to
and we could take it as read you know
submit the written testimony yes and we
will read it very good
great uh thank you everyone who uh
testified today thank you for all the
people on the on the committee here who
uh to help me out and put all this
together and we will adjourn for today
and reconvene tomorrow at 8 30.
I believe it is
let's presume that's
okay Michelle is nodding it must be true
yeah